Wo ist sie aufgetreten?
Bei Wetten, dass?
Ach ja, den hast du ja einst bei YouTube.
Das habe ich mir einst bei YouTube angesehen, das reicht ja dann auch.
Mir ist nochmal so klar geworden, was eigentlich die Funktion dieser Couch ist.
Und zwar ist es ja so, dass diese großen Stars auftreten und dann müssen sie
aber alle noch auf die Couch kommen.
Hier war es, wenn ich es jetzt richtig in Erinnerung habe, auch so,
dass Cher der einzige Weltstar war dort.
Helene Fischer war doch da und Bastian Schweinsteiger.
Weltstar wie gesagt, es waren noch Take That da, aber ich glaube die sind auch
nur noch hier in Deutschland groß.
Zumindest sind die keine Weltstars, also Cher ist ein Weltstar.
Gary Barlow auch.
Und sie musste dann aber auch noch auf diese Couch und dann ist selbst so ein
Star wie Cher plötzlich so heruntergedampft auf das Gewöhnliche.
Ich glaube, diese Couch hat die Funktion, dass ein jeder nicht mehr den Star
sehen kann, dass also dem gewöhnlichen Zuschauer daheim auf der Couchlandschaft gesagt wird,
sieh her, die sitzen auch auf so einer Couchlandschaft und die können auch sich
nicht so richtig da halten.
Und sobald man auf einer Couchlandschaft ist, ist man auch nur noch Mensch.
Und das war, glaube ich, schon immer so die große Funktion von Betten,
dass man zwar die die Stars da hatte,
sie aber dann vom Sockel holte und dann mussten sie sich ja auch regelmäßig
blamieren oder wurden blamiert, indem sie irgendwelche Hütchen aufsetzten.
Und hier war es dann so, aber da habe ich dann tatsächlich den Stream beendet,
beziehungsweise dieses Video beendet.
Jan-Josef Liefers sang dann mit einer Kollegin zusammen I Got You Babe in Anwesenheit
von Schea und das wollte ich mir dort nicht antun.
Jan-Josef Lievers wird wieder eingeladen. Ich dachte, der hat sich disqualifiziert.
Er ist ja der beliebteste Tatortkommissar, soweit ich weiß. Münster.
Ah ja, hat er Deutschland mal wieder Danke gesagt, so wie er damals Danke gesagt hat.
Ich hab das immer noch so im Ohr. Ich wollte einmal Danke sagen,
dass sich alle so schön an die Regeln halten. Okay, ich hab kein Wetten, dass geguckt.
Ich hab's mir fast gedacht, ja.
Ich habe auf TikTok ein bisschen mitbekommen, dass die eine,
die mit Helene Fischer zusammensang, Widerworte gab.
Shirin David.
Ja.
Das wollte ich mir nochmal anschauen, die Kontroverse.
Ja, Gottschalk sagte, du siehst gar nicht aus wie eine Feministin und eine,
die in die Oper geht. Und daraufhin hat sie dann gekontert.
Ja, das war aber jetzt auch kein besonders interessanter Schlagabtausch.
Ich glaube, was sehr viral gegangen ist auf TikTok, war tatsächlich diese Schlussrede
von Gottschalk, dass er nicht einfach gesagt hat, vielen Dank, war schön,
sondern dass er noch hinzugefügt hat, dass er inzwischen nicht mehr so in seiner
Show spricht wie daheim und dann sagt er lieber gar nichts mehr.
Also so im Sinne von, man darf ja nichts mehr sagen und naja,
da würde ich auch mal festhalten wollen, generell beobachten wir auch einen
sich immer mal wieder verengenden Meinungskorridor.
Ob da ein Thomas Gottschalk von betroffen ist, das wage ich dann doch mal zu
bezweifeln, da der Mann nun sich zum siebten Mal oder was von Wetten,
dass... verabschiedet, eine große Show mit Günter Jauch zusammen bei RTL hat.
Und dann wurde er am Ende dieser Wetten, dass?
Show noch auf einem Bagger abgeholt von Mike Krüger.
Und so sah ich, dass er auch noch mit Mike Krüger einen RTL-Podcast hat.
Ich halte also Thomas Gottschalk jetzt nicht für denjenigen,
der kaum noch in der Öffentlichkeit stattfindet.
Und wenn er auch dann in einem Interview davor den Fernsehschaffenden,
vor allem dem ZDF, so ein Schnasentum unterstellt,
dann stimmen wir dem zwar zu, würden aber hinzufügen, ja und das zeigt sich
vor allem daran, dass jemand wie Thomas Gottschalk seit 100 Jahren diese Sendung
moderiert und das nicht gerade besser geworden ist.
Also was ich da jetzt sah in diesem Gespräch mit Shea, naja,
sagen wir mal so, er wusste ihren Namen.
Ja genau. Und dass sie früher mal eine große Rolle spielte und wahrscheinlich
für viele immer noch ein Hingucker ist, wie für dich zum Beispiel.
Aber es ist ihm nicht gelungen, sonst lädt man ja immer die jungen Leute aus
dem Internet ein, also wie Shirin zum Beispiel, um dann das junge Publikum zu ziehen.
Bei Cher wollte man vielleicht nochmal dich anmachen.
Nein, Cher ist ja für alle Generationen einfach ein großer Star und sie hat
ein neues Album rausgebracht, DJ Play A Christmas Song, ja ein Weihnachtsalbum
und deshalb war sie da, aber.
Weiß man wie alt sie ist heute?
77.
77, cool.
Ist seit über 60 Jahren im Business.
Ja, ich habe, fällt mir gerade ein auf TikTok noch, Matthias Schweighöfer ließ
sich filmen hinter der Bühne bei Ankunft des großen Zampanos und da hat man nochmal gesehen,
wie sinnlos aufwendig die ganze Show ist.
Also zum einen wie die Kulisse von hinten aussieht, also Bühne halt von hinten,
hinter Bühne, nicht ohne Grund so prominent in der Soziologie und dann Thomas
Gottschalk kommt halt da an.
Und alle so, da ist er. Also auch der Typ, der für Matthias Schweighöfer dieses
Video macht, ne, da so, jetzt, Anspannung, er kommt, er kommt,
ja, und dann ist sozusagen die große Thomas Gottschalk Show schon hinter der Bühne,
aber nur für das kleine Publikum, nämlich diejenigen, mit denen er dann vor
der Bühne performen muss, und alle zupfeln nochmal an ihm rum.
Und dann denke ich mir so ein bisschen, okay, wenn er mit dem großen Spruch
geht, ich kann hier nicht sagen, was ich zu Hause sage, was ja sowieso schon finde ich eine sehr.
Also da muss man ja genau verstehen, was er da meint, nämlich,
ja, ja, ich habe zwar ein Millionenpublikum, aber ich kann ja nicht alles sagen.
Und deswegen gibt's, ja keine Ahnung, ist das dann schon Cancel Culture oder
wie auch immer, erzähl dann bei dem Satz belassen, nur ich kann mir auch nicht
vorstellen, dass Thomas Gottschalk gerne vor Kameras sich so wie zu Hause geben möchte.
Anhand des Videos, das ich gesehen hab, wie er sich hinter der Bühne nochmal
von drei Leuten bis zuletzt die Haare legen lässt und das Jackett nochmal staubfrei
machen lässt und so weiter.
Also es scheint mir doch so die Natur der Sache zu sein, dass Thomas Gottschalk
im Fernsehen gerne den Fernsehtypen gibt und er braucht dann echt gar nicht so einen Spruch machen.
Und vielleicht liegt das auch an der Natur des Fernsehens.
Dann solle sich nämlich mal trauen mit Jogginghose da rauszukommen und nicht
vorher nochmal die Haare gemacht und so.
Also es scheint mir so sehr Rosinenpicker mäßig. Ich möchte gerne im Fernsehen
sagen, was ich sagen möchte, aber was ich auch zu Hause sage.
Gleichzeitig möchte ich aber, dass ein 50.000 Euro pro Tag Apparat um mich herum
wenzelt, damit ich dabei dann gut aussehe.
Also es passt alles nicht zusammen, aber so ist das, diese Leute,
die Männer meine ich hiermit, die weißen alten Männer, die werden nicht gut alt.
Also man sieht es immer wieder, dass sie echt Probleme damit haben,
still sicher alt zu werden.
Von still voll gar keine Rede.
Gut, am Samstag war ich übrigens bei Jean-Philipp.
Ich habe sein neues Programm gesehen und habe dann festgestellt,
Ah ja, am Samstag war auch noch Fußball hier in Frankfurt.
Wenn Fußball ist, fällt Infrastruktur zusammen. Ich will es nochmal kurz anmerken.
Du hast ja das letzte Mal oder das vorletzte Mal über das Tempolimit und wir
hatten ja sehr viel Kritik darauf bekommen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir je so viel Kritik bekommen haben.
Ich will nochmal eine zweite Beobachtung anfügen.
Wir haben in Deutschland, das diskutieren wir ja auch gleich,
große Infrastrukturprobleme.
Es fällt wirklich sehr viel aus. Michael Hüther sagt mittlerweile mit Bert Rürup,
dem Chefökonom des Handelsblatt, wie er sich immer vorstellen lässt,
dass das mal ein Standortvorteil war, eine deutsche Adresse zu haben.
Jetzt ist es ein Nachteil.
Also die Zeichen haben sich einmal verkehrt. Und ich habe es jetzt zweimal am
eigenen Leib erfahren, wie es ist,
wenn man sowieso schon behindert wird durch Ausfallende, was auch immer,
dann kommt noch Schnee dazu. Dann sagt man sich, okay, ich hole ein Uber.
Und dann steht da, kommt eventuell in 14 Minuten, kostet 35 Euro,
wo die normale Fahrzeit nur 10 Minuten ist und der Preis irgendwie 9,60 Euro,
den man erwartet hat. Das heißt...
Ich hab's mir dann erklären lassen von dem Uber-Fahrer, ja, wenn die Situation
zu heikel ist, Schneefall, Fußballspiele, was auch immer, und die Erwartung der Uber-Fahrer ist,
naja, wenn ich jetzt eine Fahrt annehme und dann fahre ich schon mal zwei Kilometer,
hin und es ist eh Stau und man kommt eh nicht vorwärts und dann storniert der,
auch noch, dann schalten wir lieber den ganzen Service ab.
Uber schaltet also einfach den Service komplett ab.
Die sagen sich einfach, okay, wir haben jetzt einmal den ganzen Taxi-Markt zerstört,
indem wir einfach die von uns nicht verpflichtend zu zahlenden Sozialversicherungsbeiträge,
und was auch immer als unser Arbitrage-Mehrwert abkassieren.
Und wenn es dann heikel wird, also wenn die Leute besonders darauf angewiesen
sind, dass dieser Dienst funktioniert, geht er einfach nicht.
Weil die sich BWL-Kalkulationsmäßig sagen, ne, wir bieten jetzt gerade mal zwei
Stunden keine Fahrten an.
So, das ist irgendwie die Zukunft, habe ich so gedacht. Okay,
das ist jetzt die Zukunft. Uns wurde mal versprochen, Uber ist so,
drückst auf deine Apple Watch, da kommt ein Uber vorgefahren.
Du hast mir das auch gesagt und mein Lieber, vor zwei Wochen stand ich an der
Hauptwache hier in Frankfurt mit einem Freund, es fing an zu regnen und dann
sagte er, ich buche uns einfach ein Uber, denn wir hatten kein Schirm, nichts dabei.
Und dann standen wir dort und standen dort und es hat 25 Minuten an der Hauptwache
gedauert, bis dieses U-Bahn-Anfahren.
Und das ist hier für die Leute, die das nicht wissen, so einer der zentralsten
Orte überhaupt in Frankfurt. Völlig irre.
Und ich kann ja auch noch hinzufügen, dieser besagte Freund kam aus Berlin angereist,
hatte sich, hatte eine anstrengende Woche gedacht, ich fahre erste Klasse,
dann ist es komfortabel. Nichts da, er saß von Berlin bis Frankfurt auf dem Boden.
Ja, sehr gut.
Für 140 Euro.
Ja, es funktioniert wirklich alles nicht mehr. Uns wurde die Zukunft versprochen
und wir kriegen gar nichts.
Und das zweite große Thema heute,
neben dem Schuldenthema von meiner Seite aus, ist dieser Open AI Coup.
Ich will es nochmal einmal ganz deutlich am Anfang des Podcasts sagen.
Vielleicht kommen wir heute nicht dazu, dann verschieben wir das einfach in
den Salon, in unserem Live-Salon, denn ich denke, das sollte man auch mal mit Publikum diskutieren.
Es gibt zwei Leute, zum einen der Economist-Podcast, dem wir nun auch mal Reputation zurechnen.
Und zum anderen Scott Galloway, dem ich persönlich Reputation zurechne,
ich hab ihn ja häufiger hier erwähnt.
Und in beiden Podcasts wird das, was bei Open My Eye passiert ist, als Coup beschrieben.
Im einen Fall sogar verglichen mit Erdogan, Türkei, Staatsstreich und so weiter.
Das ist ein bisschen irre, was in diesem Monat alles passiert ist.
Also der Oktober war so voll, das waren so viele Zäsuren, dieser November waren
so viele Zäsuren auf einmal.
Man kann es gar nicht richtig. Wir hatten nicht nur diese Wahlen in Niederlanden
und Argentinien und so weiter.
Niederlande auch so völlig überraschend, das ist unser Nachbarland.
Wir fahren alle in Urlaub. Gerd Wilders kennen wir seit zehn Jahren.
Ah ja, der hat jetzt gewonnen. Ah ja, krass und so. Und man stellt das so am
Morgen einfach fest, wenn man mal so die Zeitung liest.
Also das ist wirklich erstaunlich, mit was wir es hier zu tun haben.
Und wir haben immer noch die langfristigen Krisen, den Krieg in der Ukraine
und da gibt es ganz interessante Zahlen jetzt mal. Ich habe sie hier aus der Welt.
Seit dem 24. Februar 2022, dem Beginn der russischen Offensive, sind.
221.000 ukrainische,
Männer zwischen 18 und 60 Jahren nach Deutschland gekommen, im wehrfähigen Alter also.
Davon halten sich heute knapp 190.000,
Männer im Land auf, teilt das Bundesinnenministerium auf Anfrage mit.
Das ist jetzt Stand 31. August. Dazu heißt es dann noch weiter,
dass wenn man sich die 27 EU-Staaten ansieht, dann kommt man auf 650.000 ukrainische.
Männer im Alter von 18 bis 64 Jahren. Und ich hatte schon mal hier kritisiert
vor vielen Monaten, warum lese
ich eigentlich immer nur Berichte von Männern, die an der Front waren,
die schon beide Arme abgeschlagen bekommen haben und immer noch sagen,
ich will morgen wieder kämpfen gehen. Warum immer nur diese Berichte?
Kann das sein, dass alle ukrainischen Männer genau so sind?
Oder könnte es auch Leute geben, die sagen, ich will nicht kämpfen,
ich fliehe vor diesem Krieg.
Und jetzt hat man hier mal die Zahlen und in der Welt steht dann auch,
ja es sei doch beachtlich, wenn 650.000 ukrainische wehrfähige Männer sich in
EU-Staaten befinden und die Armee,
aber nur aus 800.000 Soldaten besteht und man gerade sagt, wir haben so wenig
Leute, dann ist es ja interessant.
Und jemand wie Roderich Kiesewetter von der CDU, einer dieser Hardliner,
sagt dann auch noch tatsächlich der Welt, ich habe kein Verständnis dafür,
dass sich wehrfähige ukrainische Männer in Deutschland der Verteidigung ihres Landes entziehen.
Und weiter sagt er, viele der Ukrainer, die man hier sieht, machen einen robusten
Eindruck. Also er prüft die schon mal so auf Werttauglichkeit,
ob die auch noch sterben gehen können.
Also an mir ist letztens ein Tesla vorbeigefahren, immer noch hier in der Gegend,
wo ich wohne, so ein bisschen aufsehenerregend, weil typischerweise fährt man
hier 30 Jahre alt Autos, weil man selber 100 Jahre alt ist und da habe ich gesehen,
ah, ukrainisches Kennzeichen, eine ganze Familie drin.
Jetzt gibt es zwei Denkmöglichkeiten.
Entweder ich sage, cool, dass ihr hier seid, klar dürft ihr hier und so weiter
mit eurem Tesla rumfahren. Oder ich sage, was macht denn der Mann da drin?
Mal anklopfen und fragen, wieso bist du nicht da drin?
Sie sehen aber noch robust aus.
Sie sehen noch robust aus, gehen Sie mal nach Hause.
Ja, er sagt dann auch, rechnet man ihre Zahl hoch, fehlen der ukrainischen Armee
allein durch jene Staatsbürger, die sich in Deutschland aufhalten,
acht bis zehn Divisionen.
Also so wird darüber gedacht. Das heißt, die Menschen sind nur Material.
Um hier nochmal unsere alte These. Es geht hier nicht um die Menschen.
Die Menschen sind hier nur Material zu unterstützen.
Kriegsmittel. Ja, es sind Kriegsmittel und nichts anderes.
Weiche Ziele.
Weiche Ziele. Es ist völlig irre. Und naja, das ist jemand, der dann ja laufend
Gehör findet mit Strackzimmermann und Co. zusammen.
Das Time Magazine.
Wir erinnern uns, hat im letzten Jahr Selenskyj als den Mann des Jahres ausgerufen.
Jetzt, ein Jahr später, hast du es gelesen, gab es ein Riesenporträt,
wie es Selenskyj geht, wie er so drauf ist.
Und dann lesen sich diese Passagen doch plötzlich ganz anders.
Da heißt es dann, sein Optimismus, sein Sinn für Humor, seine Neigung,
eine Sitzung im Kriegsraum mit einem kleinen Scherz oder einem unzüchtigen Witz
zu beleben, all das hat auch im zweiten Jahr des Krieges nicht überlebt.
Jetzt geht er rein, holt sich die neuesten Informationen, gibt die Befehle und
geht wieder, sagt ein langjähriges Mitglied seines Teams.
Und zwar ist es so, dass nicht nur die innere Stimmung sich bei Selensky verändert
hat, sondern auch der Frust seiner Berater relativ hoch ist.
Und zwar heißt es da, trotz der jüngsten Rückschläge auf dem Schlachtfeld,
hat Selensky nicht die Absicht, den Kampf aufzugeben oder in irgendeiner Art
von Frieden zu ersuchen.
Im Gegenteil, sein Glaube an den Endsieg der Ukraine über Russland hat sich
in einer Form verfestigt, die einige seiner Berater beunruhigt.
Er ist unerschütterlich und grenzt ans Messianische, sagen die.
Er macht sich etwas vor, sagt mir, sagt dann der Reporter, einer seiner engsten Berater frustriert.
Wir haben keine Optionen mehr, wir werden nicht gewinnen. aber versuchen sie
ihm das zu sagen. Weiter heißt es dann im Time-Artikel.
Selenskys Sturheit, so sagen einige seiner Mitarbeiter, hat den Bemühungen ihres
Teams eine neue Strategie, eine neue Botschaft zu entwickeln geschadet.
Während sie über die Zukunft des Krieges debattierend blieb,
ein Thema tabu, die Möglichkeit mit den Russen ein Friedensabkommen auszuhandeln.
Also es ist kein Rankommen da an ihn.
Ich meine, wir haben im letzten Monat ganz ausführlich über den Ostkonflikt bzw.
Krieg gesprochen und wir sehen jetzt, dass bei allem, was da an Verheerendem
stattfindet, es ja doch so ist,
dass es Kanäle gibt,
über die kommuniziert wird mit dem Verhandlungspartner Katar,
dass nun jetzt die Geiseln aus den Händen der Hamas so nach und nach freigelassen werden.
Gegen große Austausche dann von Gefangenen auf israelischer Seite.
Aber das zeigt ja vor allem auch, dass die israelische Regierung schon eine
ganz klare Priorisierung auch darauf hat, die eigenen Leute möglichst schadlos da rauszuholen.
Oder würde ich jetzt sagen, man hat das auch so ein bisschen gegen die eigene
Regierung, insbesondere mit großen internationalen Bemühungen von Seiten des
Westens, also Biden und so weiter, durchgesetzt.
Das stimmt, aber ich glaube, dass das Leben der der israelischen Bürger schon
ganz, ganz hoch gestellt ist in Israel.
Also da würde man nicht mal so mir nichts, dir nichts sagen.
Geht mal rein, guckt mal, ob das militärische Kommando funktioniert oder nicht.
Man ist natürlich viel stärker sensibilisiert in der Bevölkerung, die das macht.
Man hat auch eine andere Dokumentation davon, wer da zu Tode kommt.
Das ist ja nach wie vor hier alles neblig in der Ukraine.
Stoltenberg ist jetzt aufgetreten, hat noch mal genau verkündet,
wie sehr dieser Krieg Russland geschadet hat, wie viele russische Soldaten verwundet oder gestorben sind.
Aber kein einziges Wort dazu, wie es dann den Ukrainern ergeht,
als seien die immer noch alle quick lebendig dort.
Und dieser Artikel ist also hochinteressant, den zu lesen. Es geht dann auch darum...
Dass man ja eigentlich an Selensky nicht richtig rankommt.
Das Weiße Haus geht aber auch mehr und mehr auf Distanz.
Es wird noch mal erinnert, wie war das im letzten Jahr, wir hatten diesen Besuch
hier auch reportiert, als Selensky in Washington war.
Da heißt es, das Weiße Haus schickte ein Flugzeug der US-Luftwaffe,
das ihn einige Tage vor Weihnachten in Ostpolen abholte und mit der Eskorte
eines NATO-Spionageflugzeugs unter eines F-15-Kampfjets zur.
Joint Base Andrews außerhalb der US-Hauptstadt brachte.
Am selben Abend erklärte Zelenskyy vor einer gemeinsamen Sitzung des Kongresses,
die Ukraine habe Russland im Kampf um die Köpfe der Welt besiegt.
Als ich seine Rede vom Balkon aus verfolgte, zählte ich 13 stehende Ovationen,
bevor ich aufhörte zu zählen, schreibt also jetzt dieser Journalist.
Ein Senator sagte mir, er könne sich nicht daran erinnern, dass in seinen drei
Jahrzehnten auf dem Capitol Hill
jemals ein ausländischer Staatschef so bewundernd empfangen worden sei.
Einige rechtsgerichtete Republikaner weigerten sich für Selensky zu stehen oder
zu applaudieren, aber die Stimmen zu seiner Unterstützung waren überparteilich
und im letzten Jahr überwältigend. Wie ist es nun?
Selensky war ja wieder da vor einigen Wochen. Dieses Mal hatte sich die Atmosphäre geändert.
Die Hilfe für die Ukraine war zu einem Knackpunkt in der Debatte über den Bundeshaushalt geworden.
Einer von Selenskys außenpolitischen Beratern drängte ihn im September die Reise
abzusagen, da die Atmosphäre zu angespannt sei.
Führer des Kongresses lehnten es ab, Selensky eine öffentliche Rede auf dem
Capitol Hill halten zu lassen.
Seine Berater versuchten für ihn einen persönlichen Auftritt bei Fox News oder
ein Interview mit Oprah Winfrey zu arrangieren.
Beides kam nicht zustande.
So ist die Situation also jetzt.
Jo.
Zudem kommt auch sehr viel zu Korruption da, aber das lassen wir jetzt mal weg,
auch das ist sehr, sehr erhellend.
Und bei dieser Herangehensweise Amerikas,
Wir hatten ja zum einen, also wirklich über Wochen, einen Totalausfall des amerikanischen
Parlamentarismus, was ja recht vielen Amerikanern, insbesondere im Umfeld der
Politik, vor Augen geführt hat, dass man doch relativ nah an der Bananenrepublik dran ist.
Dadurch, dass die damals ihre Statuten so gegründet haben.
Es gibt ja erstmal gar keine Geschäftsfähigkeit des Parlaments,
solange kein Speaker da ist, anders als bei uns, wo halt immer der Alterspräsident
einspringt und man schon mal zusammentritt und dann jemanden wählt und so weiter.
Dort gibt es gar keine Regeln und eigentlich keinen funktionierenden Parlamentarismus,
solange der Kongress, also das Repräsentantenhaus, keinen Speaker hat.
Und eigentlich dachte ich damals noch,
naja, die Republikaner werden sich am Ende immer dazu entschließen,
diese Milliarden zu bewilligen,
weil das wird ja nicht mal faktisch in die Ukraine geliefert,
das Geld, sondern sofort verbucht auf den Rüstungskonzernen des eigenen Landes,
sodass nur Material rüber geschafft wird.
Bestände müssen eh immer mal erneuert werden, also dass es da einfach,
dass es genug Anrufe gibt bei den Kongressabgeordneten, um zu sagen,
ja klar, stimmst du da dafür, egal wie jetzt die Stimmung ansonsten ist.
Und wie schnell sich das gedreht hat.
Dass man vor der öffentlichen Meinung,
und das werden wir ja heute auch in Deutschland diskutieren, dieses,
es ist aber trotzdem eine Geldzahlung zu unseren Ungunsten, nicht mehr drehen
ließ hinsichtlich, naja, es ist eine Zahlung zugunsten der Rüstungskonzerne
und die gibt es in jedem Wahlkreis Amerikas, gibt es irgendwen,
der davon profitiert, fand ich doch erstaunlich.
Und dass die Republikaner in diesen Fragen lieber Haushaltsorthodoxie und wir
nutzen die Schuldenobergrenze als Waffe im politischen Gefecht und so weiter
benutzen, als zu sagen, nee, dann profitiert zumindest nochmal der militärisch-akademische,
wie auch immer industrielle Komplex davon. Und das zu sehen ist schon,
finde ich auch für Deutschland ein bisschen besorgniserregend,
denn wir wissen auch in Deutschland gerade nicht so genau, wie wir mit unserer
Schicksalsstunde 15. November umgehen.
In der Hinsicht dramatisch.
Ja, es sind Zeiten der Ideologie, denn es ist ja hier in Deutschland auch so,
dass wenn man jetzt große investive Ausgaben tätigen würde, dort auch ein gewisser
CDU-Klüngel von profitieren würde.
Die könnten ja auch mal die Hand aufhalten. Das haben sie auch in der Vergangenheit getan.
Also es ist ja keineswegs so, als würde das alles an denen vorbeigehen und nur
in grüne Hände gelangen.
Noch mal ein Wort gerade zu diesen Gefangenen, die Israel jetzt an die Palästinenser
ausliefert und umgekehrt bekommen sie die Geiseln dafür.
Es ist ja so, dass wir zumindest eines da beobachten können.
Wir wissen noch gar nicht, wohin das jetzt führt, Blinken versucht ja sehr jetzt
von diesem Wege, wo man schon kommuniziert hinzukommen, doch zu einem Waffenstillstand.
Also das scheint ja die Strategie von Blinken zu sein und man kann ihm Glück dabei wünschen.
Was man aber erstmal festhalten kann ist, dass Israel als souveräner Staat ja bereit ist,
Um an diese Geyseln zu kommen, mit Terroristen zu verhandeln und wir alle kennen
diese Sätze, mit Terroristen verhandelt man nicht.
Und wir alle kennen diese apodiktischen Sätze, mit Putin kann es keine Verhandlungen geben.
Und dann sieht man plötzlich, okay, da ist Katar jetzt auch nicht mit dem besten
Läumen ausgestattet, involviert und dann machen die das um der Humanität willen.
Vielleicht kann man es einfach mal so sagen.
Und das sollte doch auch eine Lehre sein, noch mal darüber nachzudenken,
ob man nicht doch auch mit anderen verhandeln kann, um vielleicht Menschenleben zu schützen.
Also, dieser November steht unter dem Motto Moment of Surrender.
Irgendwann muss man die Waffen mal strecken, die Realität ins Auge sehen und
sagen, ich weiß, was ich die letzten 20 Jahre gesagt habe, aber es macht weiterhin,
sehe ich jetzt auch, keinen Sinn. So ungefähr.
Und wir haben zum einen das, was du jetzt beschrieben hast, also dass da irgendwo
Bewegung ist, obwohl doch immer
alle sagen, Nee, jetzt muss richtig hart drauf, so Volker Beck mäßig.
Während wir auch insbesondere in Deutschland, da muss man dann aber die internationale
Debatte so ein bisschen ausblenden, so ein Phänomen beobachten,
dass man sagt, nee, wir dürfen nicht mal drei Tage Waffenruhe machen.
Weil die Hamas würde sich ja dann neu ordnen, neu organisieren und wieder besser
zurückschlagen können.
Das kann man natürlich in so einer Mikroperspektive irgendwie sagen,
aber was heißt denn das im Großen und Ganzen?
Ein unendlicher Krieg. Denn die Hamas kriegt man ja nicht besiegt,
indem man jetzt Gaza bombardiert.
Die sitzt ja gar nicht da. Also die Köpfe der Hamas sitzen ja nicht in Gaza.
Im Podcast hören wir jetzt immer schon dieses, ja unter Mithilfe von Katar und
so weiter, wo ich mir denke, unter Mithilfe der Katars, in Katar sitzen die Chefs der Hamas.
Das läuft jetzt nicht unter Mithilfe Katars, sondern man hat halt mit Katar da verhandelt.
Also man lügt sich schon wieder in die Tasche, um irgendwie Sachen zu erklären,
die einfach der Realität einer realistischen Beobachtung der Verhältnisse nicht standhalten.
Und diese ganze Diskussion über Geiseln gehen zurück und dafür kriegen aber
die 2,2 Millionen Palästinenser so gönnerhaft einen Waffenstillstand.
Nachdem da innerhalb von einem Monat so viel Material abgeworfen wurde,
also in Form von Munition, wie in drei Jahren Afghanistan Krieg,
aber auf einer Fläche von halb Köln, wie wir immer hören, statt irgendwie zweimal Deutschland.
Dass man dann also so gönnerhaft, ja okay, wir gestehen euch jetzt mal zu.
Wir haben alle gehört, alle hungern dort, aber okay, wir gestehen euch das jetzt mal zu.
Aber wir sehen natürlich, dass sich die Hamas wieder organisiert und wir dann
umso mehr draufhauen müssen.
Also dann haben wir es wirklich mit so einem unendlichen Krieg zu tun.
Und in der Diskussion hatten wir ja, also wir haben es schon,
ich will es ausdrücklich sagen, scherzhaft so ein bisschen, weil wir machen
ja nur einen Podcast, wir reden ja auch nur über Sachen.
Wir überlegen uns also so Worte, dass man nach Zero Covid, dem absoluten Wahnsinn,
Zero Putin zu lange argumentiert hat.
Zum Sinne von, nee, der Krieg muss so lange gehen, bis Putin weg ist.
Man denkt dann gar nicht weiter drüber nach. Putin muss weg.
Also Zero Putin. Und jetzt haben wir plötzlich Zero Hamas.
Und es ist das dritte Mal hintereinander der gleiche Blödsinn, den man bekommt.
Meistens von den gleichen Leuten, ja.
Wir haben das Buch von Precht und Welzer, das wir als aussagekräftig,
aber nicht besonders klug, sondern eher auf Augenhöhe mit dem Blödsinn der Debatte halt.
Nee, wir haben es ein bisschen relativiert anfangs. Haben wir es relativierend
gelobt und dann haben wir nach drei Monaten festgestellt, naja doch,
die haben ja mit allem recht.
Ja, also man kann sich dieses Buch, gerade weil es auch so instruktiv verständlich
ist, wiedernehmen und einfach ein Thema gegen das andere austauschen,
alle Argumentationen bleiben bestehen.
Wir haben es mit diesem monothematischen, monologisierenden Journalismus zu
tun, der sich wieder nur eine Meinung zutraut insgesamt.
Aber irgendwann ändert sich es dann. Gestern kaufe ich mir die FAZ, 29.
November, oben rechts der Kommentar und ich glaube in all den Jahren ist das
immer der Kommentar Nikolaus Busse.
Und ich, wann immer ich in den letzten anderthalb Jahren die FAZ gekauft habe,
war oben rechts der Kommentar, jetzt aber nochmal liefern, bloß nicht nachgeben etc.
Jetzt lese ich da, denn Stoltenberg ist da aufgetreten, empfängt ja da gerade
die Länder, die NATO-Mitglieder und plötzlich ist der Ton ganz anderer.
Da heißt es dann, der NATO-Generalsekretär hat Recht, wenn er daran erinnert,
dass es der Ukraine gelungen ist, die Hälfte der Gebiete zurück zu erobern,
die Russland besetzt hatte.
Und dann kommen so die Sachen, die er aufgezählt hat. Aber Stoltenberg sagt
ja auch, eigentlich bewegt sich da seit vielen Monaten gar nichts mehr und das
ist jetzt so ein Stellungskrieg.
Und dann heißt es hier plötzlich, entsprechend schraubt die NATO ihre Ziele herunter.
Halten ist Gewinnen, lautet nun die Parole und das ist deutlich weniger ambitioniert,
als das, was der Westen sich von der jüngsten ukrainischen Offensive erhofft hatte.
Dass Kiew nämlich mit westlichen Waffen einen Durchbruch erkämpfen kann,
der Putin dann an den Verhandlungstisch zwingt.
Das wird auf absehbare Zeit nicht geschehen. Hinzu kommt die veränderte Weltlage,
dann natürlich der Nahostkonflikt und hier heißt es also schon ganz klar, klappt gar nicht so.
Dann gibt es einen großen Artikel darüber auf der Seite zwei,
dass man zwar so Lobeshymnen abgibt, aber dass es eigentlich nur so Durchhalteparolen für Kiew sind.
Und tatsächlich habe ich mir diese Konferenzen da von Stoltenberg angesehen
und auch von Blinken und die können eigentlich nichts sagen.
Man hofft, dass Trump nicht noch mal Präsident wird, dann ist sowieso alles
ganz schnell aus, so wie du es auch schon skizziert hast im letzten Podcast.
Und dann ist noch ein großer Artikel hier über die ukrainischen Generäle,
die mit Zelensky unzufrieden sind, vor allem Saluschny und seine Äußerungen da,
wo es überall hapert, wo das Problem ist, wo man sich versteift hat und Illusionen nachhängt.
Also da jetzt ein anderer Ton und ich finde es immer wieder erstaunlich,
wie wenig in den Medien der Blick, wie du es eben auch sagst,
realistischer ist. Es war doch ganz erstaunlich.
Dass es diese UN-Resolution gegen die militärischen Interventionen von Israel gab.
Also diese Interventionen wurden verurteilt. Wie hat Deutschland darauf reagiert?
Deutschland hat sich bei der Abstimmung enthalten.
Daraufhin hat die Bild-Zeitung geschrieben, Wischiwaschi, Baerbock,
wie kann sie das nur tun, etc.
Warum kann sie das tun? Warum tut sie das? Sie tut das, weil wir ganz viele
Handelspartner haben, die nicht erfreut wären, wenn wir dagegen stimmen würden,
gegen diese Resolution.
Und zwar ist da Jordanien zu nennen, Saudi-Arabien.
Ägypten ist das Land, das die meisten Waffen von uns nimmt und weiteres.
Ja, das heißt also man hat natürlich zum einen Baerbock im Ohr,
die von unbedingter Solidarität und all dem spricht, dann aber,
wenn es darauf ankommt, Wirtschaftsinteressen aufvertritt als Außenministerin
und das dann nicht tut und deswegen sich so enthält und damit versucht man so
ein bisschen als deutsche Regierung aus dem Schneider zu sein.
Habeck wiederum nutzt dann die Gunst der Stunde, nachdem diese Abstimmung war
und dreht ein Video nach dem anderen, hält eine Rede nach dem anderen zum Thema
Antisemitismus, muslimischer Antisemitismus, Solidarität mit Israel und alles.
Woraufhin die deutsche Presse nichts anderes zu tun weiß, als darauf zu reagieren mit, er kann Kanzler.
Das hat er jetzt mit diesen Reden bewiesen, wo ich dann auch mich frage,
seit wann werden in Deutschland Menschen, die gute Reden halten, Kanzler?
Bitte Beispiele nennen, bitte Beispiele aus den letzten 30 Jahren nennen. Ich bin gespannt.
Und dann kommt hinzu, dass Habeck so frei agieren kann, weil er jetzt gerade
nicht die Interessen von Deutschland im Ausland vertreten muss.
Deswegen kann er jetzt hier den Journalisten und seiner Gemeinde sagen, was er will.
Aber dass Baerbock anders da reagieren muss als Habeck, ist ja völlig klar,
er nutzt aber die Gunst der Stunde, um sich tatsächlich dann als Spitzenkandidat
schon zu positionieren und um auch Springer zu zeigen,
seht her, ich bin eigentlich der, der viel solidarischer ist als Baerbock,
obwohl ihr das ihr immer unterstellt habt.
Und diese Dinge sind doch sehr klar durchschaubar.
Also ich will nicht sagen, dass das bei Habeck alle Strategie ist.
Also ich nehme ihm schon ab, dass er sehr besorgt ist über den wachsenden Antisemitismus
und das kann man ja auch sein.
Aber der Rest ist doch wieder ein großes Ränkespiel und da muss man doch jetzt nicht so tun,
als würde jetzt mit einer Rede entschieden werden, wer Kanzler wird oder als
sei das, was in irgendwelchen YouTube-Formaten geäußert wird,
gleichzusetzen mit dem,
was eine Außenministerin auf dem internationalen Parkett zu tun hat.
Also Habecks Kommunikation oder die der Grünen allgemein.
Ich habe ja mit Mick einen dreistündigen Fernsehpodcast gemacht,
wo mal wieder klar wurde, dass die Grünen, wenn sie schon so viel kommunizieren
wollen, dann auch einen Populismusbeauftragten brauchen,
weil sie sich jetzt für eine Linie entschieden haben, die,
also man weiß einfach gar nicht, was sie wollen. Das kann niemand erklären.
Und zwar weder aus so einer, okay Habeck hat echte Verantwortung für echte Unternehmen,
er ist jetzt gerade der verantwortliche Wirtschaftsminister,
eine Schiene, oder die andere, er möchte wirklich Kanzler werden,
er muss also Oma Erna überzeugen.
Auf keiner dieser beiden Ebenen kommuniziert er gerade verständlich.
Also es ist ganz erstaunlich, wie man das so schlecht machen kann.
Aber dazu vielleicht später mehr. Wir wollen diesen, das kleine Kriegskapitel
hier zum Anfang beenden.
Du hast jetzt Busse mit die NATO, wie war die Überschrift, orientiert sich neu
oder hat neue Ziele und so.
Das klang gestern zeitgleich im Deutschlandfunk ganz ähnlich.
Man redet im Politik-Podcast über den Ukraine-Krieg und wenn man das so hört.
Klar, können wir jetzt wieder kritisieren, dass irgendwie die Maßstäbe verloren
gehen und so, aber auch auf so einer inhaltlichen Ebene, also nicht nur wie,
sondern auch was hier gesagt wird, ist wirklich merkwürdig für,
wo wir mal denken, ach, 2023,
also eigentlich sind wir tausend Jahre nach dem dunklen Mittelalter,
eigentlich sind wir hundert Jahre nach dem Weltkrieg und so,
aber irgendwie vielleicht doch nicht, denn Kriege sind mittlerweile wieder nicht
nur Politik mit anderen Mitteln, sondern auch einfach eine betriebswirtschaftliche Herausforderung.
Die Leute sind erschöpft und sehr entschlossen gleichzeitig,
aber dieses Problem, was sie da angesprochen hat, ist tatsächlich ein weit verbreitetes Problem.
Und es hat nicht damit zu tun, dass dem Land sozusagen die Männer ausgehen physisch,
sondern mit systematischen Problemen in der Ausbildung von Reserven,
im Training und in der Einberufung.
Man versucht das gerade anzugehen, da gibt es verschiedenste Ansätze von Seiten der Regierung.
Man versucht ja auch mit Headhunting-Agenturen zu arbeiten, um die Menschen
zu motivieren an die Front zu gehen.
Aber es ist natürlich wirklich eine schwierige Situation. Bisher ist es so gewesen,
dass viele, viele Einheiten keinen Urlaub haben, keine Rotation.
Also einige Soldaten oder viele Soldaten sind fast seit zwei Jahren an der Front
Und haben in dieser Zeit, wenn überhaupt, ihre Frauen und Familien nur ein paar Mal gesehen.
Russische Gefangene besucht, die also die Ukraine gefangen hält,
in der Hoffnung, dass man Russland ein Angebot machen kann des Gefangenenaustausches.
Kennt man ja aus Kriegen und Lanz war so ein bisschen hin und her gerissen.
Zum einen, klar, ist es absolut verlockend journalistisch, sich das mal anzuschauen.
Aber man wird natürlich auch instrumentalisiert, denn die Ukrainer wollen einem
ja zeigen, oder der Öffentlichkeit zeigen, also der russischen Öffentlichkeit,
seht mal zu, eure Leute sind am Leben, aber ihnen geht es nicht sehr gut,
wollt ihr sie nicht zurückhaben.
Sodass in Russland Druck entsteht auf die Regierung zu sagen,
ja was sollen wir mit diesen ukrainischen Gefangenen, tauscht die doch mal aus,
ich will meinen Familienmitglied zurückhaben.
Und dabei schreibt Lanz aus Gesprächen mit diesen russischen Soldaten,
wie das Recruiting in Russland funktioniert.
Man wird also irgendwo auf dem Dorf einfach abgeholt, also wirklich eingesammelt,
Tür auf, zack rein, und dann wird man an die Front gefahren.
Man weiß überhaupt nicht, wo man ist, und dann wird einem gesagt,
okay, da vorne ist die Front.
Wenn du nur drei Schritte rückwärts laufst, erschießen wir dich.
So. Und da denkt man irgendwie, okay, das ist eine sehr drastische Erklärung,
aber sie ist absolut schlüssig. Ja, also wir verstehen, so funktioniert es in Russland.
Putin hat den Befehl ausgegeben, da wird so und so viel, dann muss da abgerechnet
werden und dann, ja, wie wir das aus dem Untergang, es bleiben im Raum Steiner
und so weiter, wieso habt ihr denn das Volk nicht so weit gequält,
dass es zu allem bereit ist.
Also in Russland hartes Regime, die Leute werden entweder an der Front erschossen
oder von den eigenen Leuten.
Beim Gespräch über die Ukraine klafft das so ein bisschen auseinander,
die Semantik, also wie wir darüber reden und das, was wahrscheinlich strukturell
auf dem Boden passiert, denn, dass hier einfach gesagt wird.
Die wollen alle oder müssen noch ein bisschen motiviert werden.
Genau, also die Headhunter haben die ukrainischen Soldaten nicht so richtig
in den Mindset versetzt oder ihnen zu wenig Urlaub versprochen,
um an der Front zu dienen.
Und dort zu sterben oder andere zu töten. Also man muss sich auch mal vorstellen, was die da reden.
Also die meisten Leute sind nicht in der Lage, inklusive mir,
ein Kaninchen zu töten für einen Braten.
Aber auf Menschen schießen sollte für die Leute, wenn sie ein bisschen Motivation
erfahren, kein Problem sein.
Und dabei noch das eigene Leben aufs Spiel zu setzen.
Und wir wissen um diese hohen Verluste. Es gibt ja dann doch immer wieder so
Leaks, dass man sagt, naja, also es sieht auf der ukrainischen Seite offenbar
auch nicht viel besser aus, als auf der russischen.
Warum auch sollte es da besser aussehen, fragt man sich bei einem Stellungskrieg, ja.
Ist also die Wahrscheinlichkeit, wenn man dort hingeht an die Front zu sterben, sehr hoch.
Und die sitzen alle da bequem im Studio und sagen, jetzt müssen wir mal ein
bisschen wieder motiviert werden.
Ich finde das, also ich kriege diese Gleichzeitigkeit nicht zusammen.
Wir haben zum einen das Phänomen hier, wir müssen mal Leute dafür motivieren,
zu töten oder getötet zu werden.
Und zum anderen haben wir einen hypersensiblen Diskurs über Mental Health,
wo wirklich jeder Podcaster, jeder Buchautor die ganze Zeit Innenschau gibt
und sagt und da fühle ich mich schlecht und da habe ich ein Burnout und da habe
ich dies und das. Ich kriege das nicht zusammen.
Da müsste man ja schon überlegen, gut, wenn ihr schon überfordert seid,
damit das ein Sachbuch geschrieben habt, ja, oder alle zwei Wochen einen Podcast aufnehmt.
Wie würdet ihr dann im Krieg agieren?
Ja, genau. Es passt einfach nicht zusammen. Also diese Erklärung,
wie Russland Krieg macht, verstehe ich sofort. Das ist plausibel.
Das kenne ich aus Filmen. Das verstehe ich.
Diese Podcasts hier, wo mir stundenlang erklärt wird, wie die Ukraine und wo es da hakt und so weiter.
Das mag sein, dass das auf so einer grammatikalischen, kennen wir von Chechnya-Tibetan,
wenn die Grammatik stimmt, ist schon mal die Hälfte erreicht.
Aber es arbeitet doch irgendwie so im Hinterkopf, ja.
Und man hört das so und denkt, nee, Leute, irgendwas, ihr passt.
Die Realitätstreue ist einfach nicht sehr hoch, sondern man hat so ein semantisches
In-sich-verfangen von irgendwelchen Floskeln.
Ich würde nicht mal Ideologie oder so sagen, sondern wirklich nur so auf so einer Floskel Ebene,
dass man einfach so Sachen sagt, halt nicht nachgedacht, aber die einfach nicht
passen und deren Sicht diesen, diesen journalistischen Betrieb zum Thema Ukraine
Krieg kann man auch einfach sein lassen.
Es ändert an der Lage vor Ort gar nichts.
Diese Selbstgespräche von Leuten, die und das ist ja auch so ein Ding.
Du hast jetzt die typischen Probleme, die so besprochen werden in der Öffentlichkeit
benannt, da schwingt der auch immer mit, methodisch, dass das so ein,
ah, jetzt haben wir aber drüber gesprochen, jetzt ist schon so ein bisschen besser.
Und wenn man einfach nur sagt, in der Ukraine ist voll krass Krieg,
da müssen wir aber heute was zu machen und dann macht man halt eine halbe Stunde
Podcast dazu, ist nichts besser. Man hat dann genau gar nichts erreicht,
nichts geleistet und so weiter.
Und man braucht dann auch nicht abends zu Hause sitzen und rumjammern,
ich hab heute schon wieder so viel, die Nachrichtenlage war so krass,
ich hab so viel zu Ukraine geredet.
Ja, spaß dir einfach. Redet einfach nicht mehr darüber oder redet richtig darüber.
Aber so führt es einfach nicht weiter.
Und damit kommen wir mal zu unserem großen Thema.
Erst bevor wir zum großen Thema kommen, weisen wir noch hin auf den Salon.
Wir werden als nächstes Extremly Online lesen.
Das Buch einer der wichtigen Tech-Journalistinnen, Taylor Lawrence hat es geschrieben
und wir sind sehr gespannt darauf.
Also hier erfahren wir einmal so ein bisschen die Geschichte des Internets,
unseres Online-Verhaltens und bekommen hoffentlich analysiert,
was wir da eigentlich die ganze Zeit tun, wenn wir vier, fünf Stunden am Tag
mit dem Smartphone oder mit dem Laptop unterwegs sind.
Es ist für uns ein ganz hochinteressantes Buch. Ich habe schon die Hälfte gelesen
aus Time-Management-Gründen,
weil,
ich mich die Woche jetzt wieder ganz viel mit anderem Kram befassen muss,
wie zum Beispiel, warum fährt mein Uber nicht und was ist bei Rewe los und so weiter.
Also ich will ja auch einen Podcast erleben, um mich mal so darüber lustig zu machen.
Das Buch ist für uns besonders interessant, weil wir haben ja in unserer kleinen
Ankündigung schon gesagt, es ist eine, wie sie sagt, Sozialgeschichte des Social Media.
Was uns natürlich triggert aus vielerlei Hinsicht, denn Sozialgeschichte ist
eine besondere Art der Geschichtsschreibung und Social Media ist sozusagen das
bislang ausgeblendete, ja was machen wir eigentlich den ganzen Tag?
Was wird nirgendwo reflektiert, dass die Leute zehn Stunden TikTok-Videos gucken?
Bedeutet das vielleicht irgendwas? Und so.
Und während wir auf der einen Seite schon E-Mails bekommen von Leuten,
die uns dann warnen vor Taylor Lawrence, weil sie ja alles, was sie an Kritik
dem Internet gegenüber aufschreibt, auch selber handhabt oder Täterin ist oder wie auch immer,
bekommen wir, und ich hab dann sehr schnippisch auf diese eine E-Mail geantwortet,
dass wir natürlich keine CDF-Redakteure sind, die das Morgenmagazin vorbereiten,
also Gamergate-artigen Hate anders verarbeiten als wahrscheinlich so eine hochsensible
Redaktion, die da irgendwie morgens Stress macht.
Sondern wir bekommen ein Buch, das meiner Ansicht nach sogar zu viel Geschichte
und zu wenig Sozialgeschichte, also noch mal so die soziale Frage gleich reinmengen ist.
Aber wir bekommen eben ein wirklich hervorragendes Geschichtsbuch.
Alle Namen, alle Daten, alle Zeitverläufe und so weiter. Es wird noch mal richtig
aufgedröselt, wie das so war, als wir ja auch selbst dabei waren.
Also Blockosphäre und so weiter. Ich weiß nicht, ob du damals so einen Blog
hattest oder sowas, aber das ging ja drunter und drüber.
Mein Leben im Internet beginnt 2011. Genau.
Aber wir kriegen diese Grundlage und müssen doch relativ viele Analysen,
was bedeutet das und so weiter selber machen.
Was heißt, dieses Buch ist besonders dafür geeignet, im Salon besprochen zu
werden. Das hatten wir, glaube ich, bei bisher bei noch keinem Buch.
Selbst Anfänge wuchs natürlich jetzt auf 1000 Seiten oder so,
weil ja da immer die Situationsbeschreibung, so weit sie halt anhand der Quellenlage gelang,
und die hat man dann auch unberührt gelassen von Kommentierung.
Und dann kam aber der große Kommentartext. Und dann schlug das Buch wieder um
auf die nächste ethnografische Beschreibung von irgendwas und so.
Und dieser Kommentarteil fehlt sogar erstaunlicherweise viel mehr als diejenigen,
die Taylor Lawrence immer kritisieren, weil sie sich selbst so viel einmischt,
aber man nimmt halt nun mal teil am Internet, wenn man so alt ist wie sie und wir.
Also in der Sicht ist es ein Buch, das besonders einlädt zur Diskussion.
Was die Sachen so bedeuten, die wir erlebt haben und sie schließt,
schlüsselt uns nochmal auf, was wir erlebt haben. Also in deren Sicht freue ich mich besonders.
Gerade mit dir als Influencer-Autor, dass man da nochmal ein Update sozusagen, zwei Jahre danach.
Denn das ist ja das Interessante, nur weil man in der Zeit gelebt hat,
hat man sie nicht bewusst erlebt.
Genau, absolut.
Also es gibt Leute, die haben in den 70er Jahren gelebt, die haben nichts von
Studentenrevolt oder irgendwas mitbekommen in dem Sinne.
Wir lesen in dem Buch was über Mummy-Blogs, das wusste ich auch nicht.
Aber das ist stilprägend, grundsteinlegend für alles, was wir auch heute noch
im Internet erleben und so weiter.
Was vor 10 Jahren bei den Mummys, die immer nur ideologisch überwirft und so weiter.
Ich habe noch keine Zeile gelesen, wir werden es dann diskutieren.
Und den Salon, den gibt es zu besuchen via Steady, Patreon, Apple.
Wir empfehlen Steady, dort kann man sich einen Account machen,
das ist ganz einfach und dort kann man sich das monatlich oder jährlich abbuchen
lassen. Ab 2 Uhr 50 ist man dabei.
Man kann aber auch höhere Pakete gerne auswählen. Dann gibt es Patreon für die,
die schon dort sind, können das dort auch besuchen.
Und dann gibt es die Möglichkeit für Apple-Kunden, die sagen wir zu faul sind,
rüber zu gehen zu Steady und das lieber einfach so im InShop gerade kaufen,
die das dann auf diesem Wege machen können.
Und die, die uns über Spotify hören,
die können auch von dort direkt zu Steadicom, da gibt es einen Button.
Und wir werden dann im nächsten Salon auch bekannt geben, wann unser Sommer-Event,
stattfindet und wie man dort an Karten kommt.
So ist es. Also, der Schuldenstreit.
Der Schuldenstreit.
Ich habe Clips mitgebracht, die du noch nicht kennst.
Mhm.
Bevor wir dir aber gucken…,
Was würden wir erstmal grundsätzlich in Kürze dazu sagen, was da passiert ist und was es bedeutet?
Denn mein Eindruck ist so ein bisschen, und das Ding ist ja an einem Mittwoch gab es dieses Urteil.
Ich saß an einem Sonntag darauf im Presseclub mit drei anderen Kollegen aus
der journalistischen Branche und hab so festgestellt, crazy.
Die wollen gar nicht wahrhaben, was passiert ist.
Ist die Debatte, als ich auch den Presseclub mir ansah und mir andere kurze
Talkshow-Schnipsel auf Twitter ansah, ist die Debatte vielleicht so,
wie wir sie aus einem Loriot-Film kennen?
Ich habe hier einen kleinen Clip uns mitgebracht.
Wir müssen jetzt immer nur überlegen, was setzen wir stattdessen ein?
Und zwar, ganz unten findest du ihn, gibt es die Debatte in Papa-Ante-Portas,
über ein Gericht, einen Nachtisch. Und wir hören uns jetzt mal diese drei Szenen
an, zu genau diesem Thema.
Also Loriot mit seiner Frau.
Also die Geschichte ist glaube ich jedem klar. Der Mann eigentlich erfolgreich
im Einkaufswesen für einen Konzern tätig, hat sogar einen Chauffeur, wird aber dann,
als er Briefpapier und Radiergummis für die nächsten 80 Jahre bestellt,
vorzeitig in den Ruhestand geschickt,
tobt sich jetzt zu Hause aus.
Seine Frau ist ganz entnervt und dann sieht man, wie diese Ehe dann doch irgendwie funktioniert.
Aber es gibt Ehe-Streitigkeiten, zum Beispiel über die Birne Helene.
Was ist denn das? Birne Helene. Das ist aber ein Apfel. Mit Schokoladensauce.
Dann ist es keine Birne Helene, sondern ein Apfel Helene. Das gibt's überhaupt nicht.
Ein Apfel ist ein Apfel oder eine Birne ist eine Birne? Lass es stehen,
wenn es dir nicht schmeckt.
Es schmeckt mir ja. Dann iss es doch.
Ich ess es ja, aber nicht unter falschem Namen. Das ist Elisabeth.
Was ist los? Sie meinen? Haben Sie Birne-Helene?
Heinrich, das ist unsere Spezialität. Wir servieren ein naturbelassenes Birnenmark
mit Vanillesauce. Birne-Helene ist eine gekochte Birne mit Vanille-Eis und heißer Schokoladensauce.
Unsere Birne-Helene ist mit Vanillesauce und wird immer gerne genommen.
Ihre Birne ist eben keine Birne-Helene. Wir nehmen Sie ein Stück Apfelkuchen,
der ist mit Schokoladensauce. Nein, nein, vielen Dank.
Also ein Jägerspieß. Wenn ich jetzt noch einmal Birne Helene höre,
werfe ich mich hier auf den Boden und beiße in die Auslegeware.
Ach, nein. Du bist das Schärfste, was mir jemals zwischen Heringen ...
Soll ich schon mal die Birne Helene servieren?
Was ist denn das? Kein Reis.
Das ist ein Apfelkompott mit Sahne. Zweimal.
Was ist die Birne Helene also? Schwierig zu sagen. Jedenfalls am Ende ist die Ehe gerettet.
Man akzeptiert, egal, was der Kellner bringt, jetzt plötzlich als Birne-Helene.
Wir haben im Falle des Sondervermögens und des Urteils von Karlsruhe die Frage, ist das rechtmäßig,
dass die Bundesregierung dieses Geld, das aufgenommen wurde,
eigentlich zur Corona-Kompensation,
ist.
Es rechtmäßig zu sagen … Also ist die Birne eigentlich ein Apfel?
Ja, ist die Birne ein Apfel, wenn man dieses Geld plötzlich in einen Klimafonds
stecken will und dieser Klimafonds dann zudem auch noch Schip-Firmen finanzieren soll,
bei denen man sich fragt, was hat das so direkt mit dem Klima zu tun?
Das heißt, wir haben hier ein Urteil aus Karlsruhe bekommen,
das uns sagt, nee, das ist wirklich keine Birne Helene.
Das eine hat mit dem anderen nichts zu tun.
Und dann kommen ja noch die Fragen der Jährlichkeit und der Jährigkeit hinzu.
Also wann muss etwas beschlossen werden, damit es gültig ist?
Wann darf man etwas nachträglich tun?
Und da hat Karlsruhe jetzt ganz klar gesagt, dass die Bundesregierung da großen
Bock Mist gebaut hat Und dass es auf diese Weise nicht geht,
die Verfassung sieht nicht vor,
dass man in dieser Weise das Geld umparkt.
Man kann es hier auch nochmal auf den privaten Haushalt vielleicht rückbeziehen.
Man kann auf die Bank gehen und einen Hauskredit aufnehmen.
Der ist dann zweckgebunden. Da kann man nicht sagen, schön, dass ich die 100.000,
bekommen habe, ich mache aber doch lieber eine Weltreise damit.
Ja, es gibt so, also meine Birne und Helene, wenn wir da anfangen,
also man geht ins Restaurant und sagt, ich hätte gerne eine Birne und dann sagen
die, ich habe aber nur Apfel.
Schafft man es dann, den Bogen zu schlagen und zu sagen, naja,
ist mir eigentlich egal, ich habe ja Hunger.
Also mir geht es ja primär darum, Hunger, Birne, Apfel war ja dann nur sozusagen.
Das würde man ja schaffen, wenn man beispielsweise keine Schuldenbremse hätte.
Dann könnte man sagen, also es ist aber sinnvoll, dass wir jetzt gerade Geld
für die Klimatransformation ausgeben.
Ist doch egal, jetzt machen wir es so.
Genau, in Lehmann kann man dann sagen, ja du hast doch gesagt,
wir gehen Birne essen, jetzt gibt es hier aber nur Apfel und dann kommen die
Widerwörter, ja aber heißt das, dass wir jetzt hier nichts essen?
Ja genau, das heißt es jetzt, aber ich habe doch Hunger. Ja das ist egal,
das müssen wir ausblenden, weil wir hatten vorher gesagt, nur Birne,
kein Apfel und so weiter und so fort.
So, dann die Frage, wie bezahlen wir denn die Birne?
Darf man einen Kredit aufnehmen. Wir haben ja häufiger, diese Clips spielen
wir alle gar nicht, fast jeder CDU-Politiker hat jetzt noch mal die schwäbische
Hausfrau, der private Haushalt und so weiter und so fort.
Auch hier würde ich sagen, relativ viele Kritik, auch aus unserer Babbel,
dass ja der Staat nicht wie ein Haushalt zu Hause funktioniert und so weiter.
Alles schön und gut. Und ich bin wirklich der Meinung, wir müssen hier mal eine
Abstraktionsstufe drüber.
Es geht hier nicht um die Frage, wer kriegt einen Kredit, unter welchen Gesichtspunkten
für was, wann darf man das wie verwenden und so weiter, sondern es geht jetzt
gerade um wirklich um diese Frage,
was ist überhaupt ein Kredit, was ist Geld, wie funktioniert es überhaupt,
welche Wünsche darf man wann wie formulieren, wie darf man die befriedigen,
wann ist was gerechtfertigt und so weiter und so fort.
Und ich will nur, bevor wir Clips spielen und so weiter, unsere Hörerschaft
jetzt dazu bringen, nochmal grob, ganz grob anders zu denken.
Alles, was wir bisher gehört haben, gerade im Presseclub, das war ja so herrlich,
man kann ja auch nicht so richtig ausbrechen da, ne?
Aber ich saß halt schon da und dachte mir, ah ja, die Journalisten glauben gerade,
also alle drei, die mir da gegenüber saßen, Schönborn war so ein bisschen aufgeschlossener,
Aber der stellt natürlich nur Fragen in dem Moment.
Aber der war auch im Nachgespräch, da hab ich gesagt, oh ja,
Schönborn, der denkt irgendwie anders über die Sachen.
Aber die anderen drei waren ja wirklich, die eine war so FDP-Lager,
der andere CDU-Lager und es ging ja drunter und drüber.
Und deren Frage vier, fünf Tage nach dem Urteil war ja so, hält das jetzt die Ampel aus oder nicht?
Und ich dachte mir so, wie hält das die Ampel aus und nicht.
Das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat gerade gesagt, es ist egal, wer regiert.
Ja.
So man hat halt Pflichtausgaben, die macht man halt und darüber ist nichts möglich.
Das ist doch egal, ob jetzt die CDU regiert oder nicht.
Das finde ich sowieso super interessant, gerade auch im Familienkontext.
Die Chinesen machen den ganz großen Schwenk und sagen, die Ein-Kind-Politik ist abgeschafft.
Zack, noch nie so wenig Geburten wie heute. Die Republikaner setzen in Amerika
durch, dass der Supreme Court sagt, ab jetzt gibt es doch nicht mehr die Freiheit
für Schwangerschaftsabbrüche.
Dann hört man ein Jahr später The Daily, die sagen, ja Schwangerschaftsabbrüche
sind nach oben gegangen.
So, also inwieweit hat sowieso ein Gericht oder eine Regierung Handhabe über
das, was eine Bevölkerung macht.
So, ja in Berlin sitzen halt tausend Leute, machen irgendwie Regierung,
aber es leben hier 80 Millionen Leute. So, jetzt stellen wir schon fest,
naja, das Bundesverfassungsgericht macht auch nur eine Ansage,
da fährt jetzt nicht wirklich eine Polizei vor oder so.
Hat sich mal jemand gefragt, was die 80 Millionen Deutsche eigentlich so,
wie die damit umgehen, was irgendwie in Berlin entschieden wird.
Das ist doch auch vielen Leuten einfach egal.
Also ich will mal dieses eine Bild, Haushalte, Staatshaushalt, Privathaushalt.
Wenn wir jetzt wirklich dieses Bild übernehmen, um sagen, okay,
ich gehe zur Rewe und kaufe das aber nur, was ich mir leisten kann.
Was kann ich mir leisten? Na ich hab 10 Euro in der Tasche. Was kann ich mir dafür kaufen?
Ich kriege halt 3 Äpfel und 4 Birnen. Aber warum kriege ich für 10 Euro 3 Äpfel und 4 Birnen?
Klar, könnte ich jetzt sagen, ich könnte ja einen Kredit aufnehmen und dann
kann ich mir 20 Äpfel kaufen.
Da bin ich aber 10 Euro im Minus, kann also morgens dann nichts kaufen,
sondern müsste dann morgen das Geld nachträglich nochmal hinbringen oder so.
Aber schon allein, dass ich jetzt in den Supermarkt gehe und dort mir einfach
Obst kaufe. Dieses Obst ist aus so viel Kreuz- und Querrichtung subventioniert.
Wir haben damals besprochen, beim Lieferkettengesetz, wie die Bundesregierung
uns Bürgern sagt, für jeden von uns arbeiten weltweit 50 Sklaven.
Ich gehe nicht zu Rewe und kaufe mir, was ich mir leisten kann,
sondern ich vertraue darauf, dass der deutsche Staat mit seiner militärischen
und wirtschaftlichen Macht dafür sorgt, dass andere Leute sich dafür verschulden.
Beispielsweise ihr Leben nicht so lang ist, wie es sein könnte,
weil wir denen, und das war ja die Rechnung damals bei der Jeanshose,
die kostet 7 Euro in der Produktion, wenn sie 8 Euro kosten würde,
könnten wir europäische Sozialstandards in der Arbeitswelt von Bangladesch rechtfertigen.
Also irgendwer geht hier ins Minus dafür, dass wir am Ende die 10 Euro,
die wir haben, zu den 10 ausgebrüteten Äpfeln, die wir da kaufen,
so, ja, und dieses Gesamtgefüge, was dahinter ist, das steht jetzt gerade zur Disposition.
Also nicht nur, was kann ich für die 10 Euro gerade kaufen oder ist jetzt die
Ampel K.O. und dann regiert halt die CDU. Nein, das Gefüge dahinter.
Wie finanziert sich eigentlich der Staat? Wo kommt eigentlich dieses ganze subventionierte
Zeug oder auch dieser materielle Druck, der auf die Welt ausgeübt wird,
her, damit ich mir meine Jeans für das Geld, für das ich sie mir leisten kann, ja?
Ich gebe meiner Tochter 10 Euro und die geht dafür zu irgendeinem Billigklamottenladen
einkaufen und dann kommt sie
nach Hause und sagt, ich habe für 10 Euro genau die zwei Teile gekauft.
Und ich sag dann, cool, jetzt hast du eine, die Lehre ist, du hast genau im
Kreditrahmen, den du hast, nämlich null, dich nicht verschuldet und bist da einkaufen gegangen.
Gleichzeitig liegt aber die Welt in Trümmern, ja. In Bangladesch fällt einfach
so ein Haus zusammen und so weiter.
Das hat ja alles mit diesen 10 Euro zu tun, wo sich hier ganz viele Rentner,
also muss man echt sagen, die Älteren, die gerade Fernsehen schauen und auf
dieses Bild anspringen, der Staat, der Haushalt, Personenhaushalt,
die dann sagen, puh, zum Glück bin ich ein ehrlicher Kaufmann.
Ich hab mich nicht verschuldet, als ich zu Rewe gegangen bin.
Und gleichzeitig haben wir Klimakrise und alles, was...
An ex, äh, äh, also nicht inkorporierten Kosten da drin steckt.
Luft kann man einfach so verschleudern. Kostet halt nichts, wird nicht verbucht.
Also kann Oma Erna sich den Schweiß von der Stirn, zum Glück hab ich mich nicht verschuldet.
Auf der Ebene sind wir angekommen, dass wir grundsätzlich Fragen stellen, wie wir es regeln.
Und da will ich jetzt sozusagen bleiben auf dieser Ebene und wie folgt sagen.
Als die Amerikaner Trump gewählt haben und sich die Briten für Brexit entschieden
haben, war für alle sofort klar, das ist jetzt die Zäsur.
Wir können uns nicht weiter als Universitätsprofessoren, Institutsleiter,
private Familien irgendwie das Schönreden, sondern nee, jetzt regiert Trump.
Der schickt die Polizei los, dann werden die Hispanics abgeholt,
die vor 20 Jahren illegal eingereist sind. Scheißegal, ob die seit 20 Jahren
hier sozialversicherungspflichtig arbeiten, die werden jetzt rausgeholt.
Uns war für alle klar, das passiert jetzt.
Wir sperren jetzt Kinder an der Grenze ein und dann und so weiter.
Bei den Briten war völlig klar von jetzt auf gleich, das ist der Brexit.
Auch wenn sie sich nicht eingestehen im Fernsehen und immer noch diskutieren,
wo liegt denn das jetzt das Problem, dass wir hier so einen großen Abbau haben von allem möglichen.
Ist es immer noch Covid? Nee, es ist Brexit. Die wollen es nicht wahrhaben so.
Aber irgendwie wissen dann doch alle, ja, das ist einfach diese Brexit-Zäsur.
Man fällt halt mal raus aus der Weltgemeinschaft und das kostet etwas.
Und wir in Deutschland haben jetzt auf dieser Ebene, Trump-Wahl,
Brexit-Entscheid, ne Zäsur in Deutschland.
Nur, das wird nicht so ernst genommen.
Wir führen eine Birne-Helene-Diskussion. Ja, können wir das dann und was will
Merz und wo können wir an den Sozialausgaben sparen etc.
Genau, man sitzt jetzt so da und redet über Sozialausgaben.
Du hast es ja im Presseclub ganz gut auf den Punkt gebracht.
Die Welt entwickelt sich weiter.
China und USA stehen sich als Rivalen gegenüber. Ich hoffe wir kommen da heute
auch noch zu. Ich habe da was mitgebracht.
Und die Frage ist, wo bleibt jetzt Europa, wo bleibt Deutschland insbesondere?
Und dann ist die Frage, macht man da bei manchen Dingen mit oder nicht?
Und man sieht jetzt bei den Grünen wird ja mitunter in diese Richtung argumentiert,
dass man von der Schuldenbremse sich lösen könne im Sinne des nationalen Interesses.
Aber was man vielleicht auch mal jenseits dieses nationalen Interesses sagen
kann, ist, dass wir diesen Umgang, den wir jetzt mit Geld 2009 festgeschrieben haben.
Dass wir den jetzt schon so stark als Ideologie verinnerlicht haben,
dass alle Diskussionen sich nur noch in dem Rahmen, den man 2009 gesetzt hat,
feststellen kann, dass die in diesem Rahmen stattfinden.
Dass kaum jemand aus diesem Rahmen mit Werbe einmal heraus will.
Und man sieht das dann besonders an so einem irren Tweet wie dem von Marco Buschmann,
der schreibt, einige meinen, die Schuldenbremse sei ein handwerklich schlecht gemachtes Gesetz.
Ich rate von dieser Formulierung ab, die Schuldenbremse ist Verfassung.
Und vor der Verfassung sollten alle Demokraten Respekt haben,
Denn sie ist die gemeinsame Grundlage unserer Demokratie.
Heißt also, wer gegen die Schuldenbremse ist, ist eigentlich ein Feind der Demokratie.
Und was 2009...
Festgelegt wurde ist sobald es festgelegt
ist es wurde ja von menschen festgelegt so etwas
wie göttlicher wille wir sind also hier eigentlich in
einer debatte wie du sie uns mal gezeigt hast in bezug auf josh hawley ja die
die amerikanische verfassung als hoch und heilig die originalisten die originalisten
die ja auch mitunter glauben dass die gründer väter auf einen engel getroffen
sind die waren fehlbar beraten hat.
Und so muss es auch mit unseren Politikern 2009 gewesen sein,
dass sie plötzlich ein Erweckungserlebnis hatten und diese Schuldenbremse konstruierten.
Und jetzt diese zu hinterfragen, das bedeutet keinen Respekt gegenüber der Demokratie mehr zu haben.
Marco Buschmann hatte ja auch noch einen Tweet, ich glaube ich finde den nicht
so schnell, aber da hat er noch mal auf die japanische Lebensweise des Gaman
hingewiesen, die gewisse Geruhsamkeit,
der wir uns doch auch mal anhängen sollten und das fand ich besonders lustig, denn,
ah hier, Marco Buschmann, im japanischen gibt es den Begriff des Gaman,
er bedeutet so viel wie Ernsthaftigkeit, sein Bestes zu geben und dabei viel
Selbstdisziplin aufzubringen.
Was wir jetzt brauchen können ist ein bisschen mehr German Garman statt Lautstärke und Aufgeregtheit.
So, die Japaner sind wie wir wissen mit 260 Prozent ihrer Wirtschaftskraft verschuldet.
Das ist ein bisschen mehr als wir.
Die sind im Grunde mit uns auf Augenhöhe was die Wirtschaftskraft angeht.
Also wir können es eins zu eins vergleichen fast.
Wir sind bei 60 Prozent und das sind 2,5 Billionen Euro.
Und wenn wir jetzt japanisches Gaman, also die Ernsthaftigkeit und Geruhsamkeit
vernünftige, trotz demografischer Wandel, da sind wir ja mit denen ziemlich gleich,
eine volkswirtschaftliche Kalkulation machen und wir würden uns jetzt von 60
auf 260 Prozent verschulden, dann hieße das, Deutschland hätte plötzlich einen
Spielraum von 8 Billionen Euro.
Und das schreibt er uns im Grunde. Wir sollen uns mal die japanische Germanen
Ernsthaftigkeit und Geruhsamkeit.
Ja müsste man ihm eigentlich nahe legen.
Mittlerweile ist zwischen politischem Gespräch und wirtschaftlicher Notwendigkeit
liegt mittlerweile ein Gap von acht Billionen Euro.
So muss man es glaube ich sagen. Also es ist wirklich Wahnsinn was hier gerade
passiert. Insbesondere.
Ja wir sollten über Billionen reden.
Ich habe das schon mal gesagt. Wir hören auch gleich eine Billion. Und es ist ...
Ich will nicht zu viel auf diese Unterscheidung von Semantik und Struktur rumreiten,
aber wir haben es mit einer ...
Es ist ja nicht mal Verlogenheit, sondern es ist so diese Realitätsuntreue.
Man weiß es eigentlich besser, aber man will es nicht zugestehen,
weil das eigene Gerede sonst darunter litt.
Also sollten lieber strukturell alle darunter leiden. Insbesondere,
wenn wir jetzt eine Haushaltsdiskussion zum Thema 2023, 2024 führen.
Friedrich Merz von Christian Sievers gefragt wird, wo würden sie denn sparen?
Und Merz erst so rumdruckt, natürlich nichts konkretes sagen will,
und dann sagt die Kindergrundsicherung.
Die Kindergrundsicherung ist ein Gesetz, das gilt ab 2025 und ist nur zwei Milliarden stark.
So für die Jahre 2023 und 2024 ist das also gar nichts. Das ist sozusagen strukturell...
Gar nicht vorhanden. Aber semantisch ist das das Top-Thema und es kann einfach
gar nicht sein irgendwie. Also es ist wirklich verrückt.
Ich gehe fest davon aus, dass wir jetzt gerade diese Zäsur erleben,
wie du sie skizziert hast, aber diese Zäsur wird uns erst in 10, 15 Jahren auffallen.
Nämlich wird man noch lange weiter so machen und es gibt weder von Seiten der
Mainstream-Journalisten noch von Seiten der Mainstream-Politik irgendwelche.
Anstalten.
Das radikal alles mal in Frage zu stellen. Sodass wir jetzt erleben werden,
dass die Infrastruktur beispielsweise und vieles weitere so kaputt gespart werden
wird, dass wir ein sehr desaströses Land haben.
Und man wird sich immer fragen, warum, würde immer irgendwelche Verantwortlichen
finden, am Ende werden es die Kinder sein, die ihre Kindergrundsicherung kassieren.
Irgendwas findet man immer. Margaret Thatcher hat damals alleinerziehende Mütter
als das große Unheil des Landes ausgesucht.
Also das ist sehr variabel.
Wir haben ja auch die Möglichkeit, das immer auf Migranten abzuschieben,
auch da probt man ja gerade schon verschiedene Diskurse. Und man wird damit
tatsächlich dieses Land in einen ziemlich ruinösen Zustand treiben.
Und ich finde, man sollte da auch das in aller Deutlichkeit so sagen,
weil ich fand das erstaunlich, dass du beim Presseclub dann gleich so eingefangen
wurdest, wenn du gesagt hast, ja, das bedeutet einfach, wenn man das Geld jetzt
sparen will, diese 60 Millionen, dass man die Renten um 20 Prozent kürzen muss.
Und dann alle gleich so, nein, also das wollen wir ja gar nicht so,
also man glaubt, dass man mit irgendwelchen merkwürdigen Verschiebungen und
vielleicht kann man noch mal in drei Theatern die Tanzsparte einsparen oder
so, dass man damit aus irgendetwas rauskommt, ja.
Das ist eine völlige Fehlannahme, wir haben ein Billionenproblem und dieses
ist nicht mit Millionen zu lösen.
So groß ich jetzt das Problem aufgemacht habe, also das ist unser Trump- und Brexit-Moment,
ich will, dass unsere Hörer die nächsten Wochen, Tage, Wochen und Monate grusamer
an dieses Thema rangehen, denn wir haben es jetzt mit einem,
wie ich es nochmal sage, Moment of Surrender zu tun.
Alle müssen jetzt mit offenem Visier und die Waffen gestreift oder gestrichen
oder wie auch immer, also niemand ist gerade mehr bewaffnet, will ich damit sagen.
Die Diskussion, wie sie bisher geführt haben, wir sehen ja noch,
okay, wenn die CDU gefragt wird, was sie will, sagt sie irgendwie das Bürgergeld streichen.
Ja, das ist fast antike Geschichte in der politischen Diskussion.
Die wird sich sehr schnell ändern.
Wir haben das die Woche schon gesehen, aber wie gesagt, das sind alles diese
Clips, die wir aus Basalität, Banalitätsgründ nicht spielen.
Christian Sievers hat Hubert Aiwanger im Gespräch, der als Vorsitzender der
Landeswirtschaftsminister und so weiter da irgendwie im Namen aller Wirtschaftsminister
spricht und sagt, die Projekte müssen kommen.
Und dann wird er gefragt, ja welche Projekte denn? Und dann zählt da Habecks
Wunschliste auf und dann fragt ihn Christian Sievers, da sind sie jetzt der
grüne Wirtschaftsminister, die Projekte müssen kommen, ja, und dann in seinem
Bayerischen, das muss alles und so weiter und so fort.
Und es ist auch, und das will ich wieder, da will ich wirklich drauf Wert legen,
es ist, man sollte es jetzt auch mit ganz großem Amüsement sehen,
welchen Kampf Friedrich Merz gerade führt.
Denn Friedrich Merz kann es strukturell egal sein. Der ist, der führt semantischen
Wahlkampf, der hat ja nirgendwo für irgendwas Verantwortung.
Der führt halt einfach seinen Berliner Fraktionsladen.
Gleichzeitig gibt es aber ganz viele CDUler, die echte Verantwortung haben.
Wie?
Und da klingelt natürlich gerade das Telefon, weil der ganze Mittelstand gerade
bei der Regierung anruft und fragt, wir haben von euch diese Zusage,
aber wir haben den Bescheid noch nicht bekommen.
Was heißt denn das jetzt? Und dann müssen die leider sagen, das heißt,
dass wir es noch nicht genau wissen mit ihrem Projekt. Und das geht von wenigen
Millionen für irgendwen bis hin zu diesen 20 Milliarden für Intel und so weiter.
Die haben alle noch keine Bescheide bekommen.
Also das ist gerade alles nichtig. Und das lassen die natürlich nicht auf sich sitzen.
Insbesondere weil diese verantwortlichen Politiker und diese Unternehmenskapitäne,
die gleichen Interessen haben. Die wollen, dass dieses Geld fließt,
dass es in ihren Wahlkreisen gut geht, dass die Menschen Arbeit haben und so weiter und so fort.
Und der Einzige, dem das egal ist gerade, ist Friedrich Merz.
Also der führt gerade einen ganz
einsamen Kampf und versucht dann noch als Zampano nach der Aussprache,
oder nach der Ansprache in der Aussprache von Scholz, Regierungserklärung oder
so, so einen Spruch zu machen, wie wir entscheiden hier, wie die Schuldenbremse
funktioniert und nicht Kai Wegner.
Drei Türen weiter, wo wirklich regiert wird.
Ein Bürgermeister in Berlin.
Anders als die Fraktionsleitung der CDU. Die hat gerade nichts zu sagen in Berlin.
Die gibt nur Interviews.
Es wird ja sehr dankbar angenommen und das ist für mich auch nicht verständlich,
dass man die ganze Zeit diesen Friedrich Merz interviewt.
Dann sollte man doch mal diese ganzen Hauptstadtjournalisten in die Länder verschicken.
Und dann können sie ja nochmal mit Landräten beispielsweise sprechen.
Die freuen sich auch riesig darüber.
Also derzeit ist es jetzt so viel Geld auf der Kippe, dass es gerade egal ist,
von welcher Partei man ist.
Wenn man ein Wirtschaftsminister ist, Freiwähler, CDU, Grüne,
Linke, falls es irgendwo welche gibt, SPD, die haben gerade alle dieselbe Meinung,
dieselbe Forderung, die sind gerade alle auf Linie.
Nur Friedrich Merz nicht. Und Carsten Linnemann war Vorsitzender dieser Mittelstandsunion.
Also wenn einer gerade durchgerüttelt wurde, ja, dann ist das dieser Mittelstand.
Und ich bin sehr gespannt, wie lange Carsten Linnemann das noch durchhält,
eine Sozialstaatsdiskussion zu führen.
Während ihm sein alter Laden, diese Mittelstandsunion, gerade...
Hast du den Eindruck, dass diese Mittelstandsleute jetzt schon sich positionieren
gegen die Schuldenbremse?
Also intern mag da manches laufen, das weiß ich nicht.
Aber ich finde es erstaunlich, wie wenig die sich zu Wort melden.
Die Diskussion führen wir gleich, ob das jetzt, ob es der Schuldenbremse ankragen
geht oder anderes passiert.
Jaja, eben.
Denn die Gefahren sind ja durchaus groß. Wir steigen ein.
Ich erschätze nie die Dummheit.
Genau. Und Dummheit beginnt schon, wenn man sich zugesteht, ich hab grad keinen Überblick.
Mir fehlt das Panorama, ich bin zu nah dran.
Wir hören, wir beginnen einfach mal so wild bei Jens Südekum,
der versucht die Zäsur in der Hard-or-Fair-Sendung, die besonders interessant
ist, weil sie dann am Montag ... Das ist sozusagen ich im Presseclub.
Ich reibe mich einfach mal ein. Dann an dem Abend sonntags Clemens Fuest bei Anne Will.
Ja, Montag dann Südekum.
Bei Hard Aber Fair.
Ich war schon sehr überrascht, denn dass das Urteil so ausfällt,
es ist im Prinzip fast das maximal strengste Urteil, was da gefällt werden konnte,
das habe nicht nur ich nicht erwartet nach der neunstündigen Verhandlung,
die sehr konstruktiv, sehr freundlich war.
Das haben ehrlicherweise auch die Kläger gar nicht erwartet.
Also eigentlich sind wir davon ausgegangen, es wird Richtlinien in die Zukunft
geben, wie zukünftig in so einer Krisensituation vorgegangen werden muss.
Denn man muss ja eben sehen, es war ein Präzedenzfall. Es ist ja das erste Mal,
dass der sogenannte Ausnahmetatbestand der Schuldenbremse gezogen wurde.
Und von daher gab es keine Rechtsprechung und auch keine Erfahrungswerte,
was in solchen Situationen erlaubt ist und was nicht.
Und ich denke, die Regierung hat im guten Glauben gehandelt,
dass das richtig war und recht ist, was sie getan hat.
Und ich finde, es gibt auch gute ökonomische Gründe, die dafür sprechen.
Die habe ich damals in Karlsruhe auch dargelegt.
Das sieht das Bundesverfassungsgericht jetzt anders. Das muss sich anerkennen.
Das müssen alle anerkennen.
Aber es wird die Finanzpolitik in Zukunft, auch gerade zu Krisenzeiten,
nun wahrlich nicht einfacher machen.
So, Moment of Surrender. Wir haben einen Investitionsbedarf.
Die Unternehmen melden das an, die Minister geben das weiter,
der Bund muss irgendwas machen.
Dieses Geld steht also zur Verfügung im Klima- und Transformationsfonds,
der ja so eine 15-jährige Erfolgsgeschichte ist. Wir haben einfach ganz viele
thematisch gleiche Anliegen da reingetan und haben gesagt, wir managen das jetzt
mal wie ein Unternehmen und so weiter. Und das ist so ein Nebenhaushalt.
Jetzt hat man eben die Finanzierungsgrundlage genommen, wegen,
ja, in der Verfassung von 2009 steht halt irgendeine Formulierung drin.
Jetzt muss man schon mal feststellen, die Ökonomen waren als Sachverständige
an der Anhörung des Bundesverfassungsgerichts vorstellig und haben dort die
ökonomischen Einwände vorgebracht.
Silkom sagt, die haben uns auch gut verstanden.
Über die politischen Zwänge haben wir gerade schon gesprochen,
also die Landesminister, das ist gerade egal, aus welcher Partei man ist,
man will jetzt, dass die Gelder fließen.
Das Verfassungsgericht blendet allerdings politische und ökonomische Wahrheiten aus.
Sie kennt nun mal nur juristische Wahrheiten und die Schuldenbremse ist nun
mal, das habe ich ja im Presseklub auch gesagt, das versteht jeder.
Also das ist einfach glasklar, das steht da drin, geht nicht.
Also geht das dann nicht. Wie vorhin bei Birne und Apfel.
Du gehst nicht ins Restaurant, um deinen Hunger zu stillen, sondern um eine
Birne zu essen. Und wenn es da keine gibt, musst du halt hungern.
Auf der Ebene wird halt entschieden. Das ist schon mal interessant,
weil das jetzt wirklich eine ganz moderne Herausforderung ist.
Wir haben zwei Funktionssysteme mit konkurrierender Rationalität.
Und nicht nur das, sondern auch ganz unterschiedlichen Arbeitsmodi.
Die einen sagen halt, wir lernen
einfach, wie wir Geld verdienen und dann gehen wir in diese Richtung.
Und wenn es morgen eine andere Richtung ist, gehen wir einfach in die Richtung.
Und wenn es übermorgen eine andere ist, einfach eine andere.
Das nennt man dann kognitives Lernen.
Man nimmt keine Rücksicht auf nichts, sondern man will einfach Profit machen.
Das Verfassungsgericht geht nicht kognitiv ran, sondern normativ.
2009 wurde das geschrieben, das gilt. Egal was jetzt ist.
Die Welt könnte untergegangen sein, ein Komet kommt, was auch immer.
2009 wurde geschrieben, das sind die normativen Grenzen, also sind das die normativen
Grenzen, egal welche kognitiven Lernerfolge vorliegen.
Deshalb darf man ja ein solches Gesetz niemals machen.
Wir haben über Longtermism gesprochen und haben dann gelacht,
haha, wie will man sich ausdenken, was in 30, 50 oder 250 Jahren ist.
Hier haben wir ein Gesetz, bei dem Leute sich 2009 hinsetzen und sich anmaßen
zu wissen, was im Jahr 2023 Sache ist.
Wir haben es bei den Neoliberalen, wann immer man mit irgendwelchen Plänen kommt,
sofort immer wieder zu hören bekommen, das ist Anmaßung von Wissen.
Nur der Markt kann es wissen. Was machst du dir als Einzelner an zu wissen,
wie du industriepolitische Maßnahmen im nächsten Jahr umsetzt?
Da ist man gegen alles was mit Plan zu tun hat.
Aber hier plant man auf Ewigkeit und sagt, ja wir können das hier schon mal
festlegen wie viel Geld gebraucht wird. Kann immer nur so viel sein, egal was es ist.
Ja, also diese, das ist wirklich wahnsinnig interessant. Die Vorgabe 2009 Schuldenbremse,
Paragraf 115 im Grundgesetz sagt ja,
Man darf keine Schulden machen, also Null und dann kleiner Spielraum,
0,35 Prozent Konjunkturkomponente.
Diese Konjunkturkomponente, da wird ja so ein Potenzial ermittelt und dann wird
eine Prognose gemacht und wenn die Wirtschaft unter ihrem Potenzial liegt,
dann darf man da rein investieren.
Also das Potenzial wird dann so ein bisschen aufgeteilt, irgendwie ein Drittel
darf dann öffentlich investiert werden, um zwei Drittel private Investitionen
hinten anzuschieben und so weiter und so fort.
Diese Potenzialanalyse 2009 und da habe ich jetzt wirklich bei diesen Ökonomen,
die wir hier auch hören im Fernsehen, vorher nochmal nachgefragt,
als ich auch im Presseclub wusste, ich bin da und so, wie ist das zu verstehen.
Und die meinten dann, ja, man macht halt diese Potenzialanalyse,
man guckt sich also die Vergangenheit an und sagt,
ja, unter diesen, denjenigen Bedingungen sollten wir eigentlich so und so viel
Wirtschaftsplus haben, Wirtschaftswachstum, aber es sind gerade nur so und so
viel, also darf der Staat jetzt irgendwie 8 Milliarden verschulden machen und so.
Diese Potenzialanalyse wird ermittelt anhand der Vergangenheit und dann spielt
der Arbeitsmarkt eine ganz große Rolle.
Sehr viele Leute sind arbeitslos. Die Wirtschaft könnte also eigentlich mehr,
aber die Politik hat es versäumt, die Leute arbeitsfähig zu machen.
Also darf sie jetzt rein investieren, um die Leute arbeitsfähig zu machen oder
damit irgendwelche Lohnersatzzahlungen oder wie auch immer, damit so Belegschaften wachsen.
Dieses Phänomen, was wir jetzt gerade haben, dass wir keine Arbeitslosen haben,
also klar, wir haben Arbeitslose, aber wir klagen über Fachkräftemangel.
Also man könnte schon davon ausgehen, dass gerade jeder so ein bisschen weggefischt wurde vom Markt.
Also die, die jetzt gerade nicht arbeiten, sind nur mit so hohen Anstrengungen
in den Job zu bringen, dass es sich nicht lohnt volkswirtschaftlich.
Also wir haben keine freien Arbeitskräfte und trotzdem eine Rezession.
Und da fragt man, er konnte 2000, nee das war undenkbar 2009.
Also es war einfach für alle Beteiligten, Wirtschaftsberater,
Juristen, Politiker undenkbar, dass diese Situation überhaupt entsteht.
Dass wir einen Wirtschaftsabschwung haben und gleichzeitig aber gar keine Arbeitnehmerschaft.
Also dass nicht Arbeitslosigkeit das Problem ist. In der Hinsicht ist das gerade für alle neu.
Also wir haben eine normative Schranke reingelegt, die hardcore planwirtschaftlich vorgibt.
Dass kognitive Lernerfolge nicht nachgegangen werden darf.
Und diejenigen, die das besonders erkämpfen gerade, ist die FDP.
Die ansonsten immer den Profiten hinterher rennt.
Die jetzt den Unternehmen verbietet, ihr dürft gerade keine Profite machen,
ihr dürft jetzt kognitiv nicht lernen.
Egal wie gut eure Idee ist, egal wie gut der Plan ist, darf nicht sein,
weil normative Beschränkungen.
Und das ist ein rein menschmachtes Problem. Und wir haben ja jetzt sogar schon
den Fall, dass die Kapitalmärkte nervös darauf reagieren, dass unsere Regierung
sich an diese Schuldenbremse halten will.
Das Argument der FDP war immer, wir müssen die Schuldenbremse einhalten,
damit wir die Kapitalmärkte zufriedenstellen.
Sonst entziehen die uns das Vertrauen und glauben, dass in Deutschland das Geld
zum Fenster rausgeworfen wird. Das Gegenteil ist der Fall.
Die Kapitalmärkte werden nervös und stufen Deutschland dann vielleicht in Zukunft
nicht mehr als so ein interessantes Land ein.
Die FDP möchte gerade, dass wir bei unserem planwirtschaftlichen Plan bleiben.
Ja.
Also auf der Ebene muss man das jetzt immer durchdenken. Es geht jetzt nicht
gerade um der Sozialstaat und so weiter. Dazu kommen wir gleich.
Gut. In der Politik. Also jetzt haben wir die Ökonomen gehört,
die sagen, wir haben die jetzt gerade mitberaten.
Wir haben denen gesagt, das ist ganz anders als jetzt 2009, das so und so weiter.
Das passt einfach gar nicht. Aber jetzt gilt, was gilt.
Reinhard Hauben ist der wirtschaftspolitische Sprecher der FDP.
Da wird also angerufen und gefragt, was machen Sie jetzt?
Reinhard Huben ist jetzt am Telefon, der wirtschaftspolitische Sprecher der
FDP-Fraktion im Bundestag.
Schönen guten Morgen, Herr Huben. Guten Morgen. Wir haben ihn gerade noch mal
gehört, den Bundesfinanzminister, der noch vor einer Woche gesagt hat,
dass die Beratungen über den Bundeshaushalt jetzt von dem Urteil nicht betroffen sein werden.
Wie konnte er so daneben liegen? Ja, das Problem ist,
dass erst peu à peu allen klar wird, welche Ergebnisse das Karlsruher Gerichtsurteil
nicht nur für die Haushalte des Bundes,
sondern auch der Länder gegebenenfalls sogar der Kommunen haben wird.
Das Thema ist, dass ja auch gestern bei der Anhörung der Fachleute noch gar
nicht klar egal ist, welche Ausweitungen wir tatsächlich in den Haushalten haben werden.
Üblicherweise ruft man den Karlsruher an und sagt, wir haben hier ein Problem,
widerstrebende Aussagen, es müsste
jetzt mal letztinstantlich entschieden werden, wir brauchen Klarheit.
Also ruft die CDU und Karlsruhe an und sagt, wir brauchen mal Klarheit und was
sie bekommen ist, also die zwei Zeilen im Grundgesetz kennen sie ja,
das sagen wir dazu, der Rest ist uns egal,
also niemand hat ihr gerade irgendeine Klarheit, das war sozusagen ein sehr Kontra.
Selten hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht, das für Klarheit sorgen soll,
so viel Unklarheit produziert wie jetzt.
Und sehr schön ist, dass er sagt, den Leuten wird erst peu a peu klar, dass.
Ihm selbst wird es im Reden gerade erst so klar, was das bedeutet.
Gregor Kirchhoff hat die Klage geführt, also er war der Anwalt,
der für die CDU-Fraktion und für jeden Einzelnen der Abgeordneten,
das ist ja die ganze Fraktion gewesen, nicht nur so Thomas Heilmann macht mal
irgendwas und so, hat die Klage in Karlsruhe geführt.
Er wird dann von der FAZ, das fand ich auch witzig, mir saß ja Reinhard Müller
gegenüber, also Jurist, FAZ und verantwortlich für Einspruch,
also dieses Magazin war sie halt für die Juristen.
Die haben auch einen Podcast, der Einspruch-Podcast, der kam auch am 15.
Nach dem Urteil, hat aber das Urteil nicht thematisiert. Ich frage ihn so,
haben sie da keinen Notfall-Podcast gemacht oder so? Also sie müssen doch in dem und so.
Nee, ja, das haben wir, keine Ahnung, überschätzt und so.
Eine Woche später kam dann ein Podcast, in dem sie den Kläger,
also der Anwalt, der für die CDU das macht, Gregor Kirchhoff, eingeladen haben.
Von Reinhard Müller weiterhin kein Wort, sondern nur so, was er halt im Presseclub
gesagt hat, sondern er dachte sich so, ich lass mal den Gregor Kirchhoff reden,
bevor ich mich noch im Kopf und Kragen rede. Also hören wir Gregor Kirchhoff zu.
Und wir sagen hinzu, du hast mir es zugesendet und hast gesagt,
hör dir das mal an, ich habe es mir angehört.
Du musstest das unbedingt vorher hören.
Und habt ihr dann geschrieben, das ist ja der reine Wahnsinn.
Das ist wirklich der reine Wahnsinn, wir hören das auch gleich etwas länger.
Hier nur ein kleiner Ausschnitt zur Frage, hat denn er jetzt wenigstens Klarheit?
Er hat ja immerhin einen kompletten Sieg.
Der Thiel, Verfassungsrichtsprofessor, wie heißt der mit dem Vornamen?
Alexander Thiele.
Alexander Thiele hat ja auch, oder der...
Wie heißt er? Der Professor in Bielefeld. Also relativ viele Juristenprofessoren
haben sich jetzt auf Twitter so ein paar Fragen gestellt, wie zum Beispiel,
wo ist denn das Gericht mal über die Anträge der Kläger hinausgegangen und so
weiter. Also haben die einfach nur gesagt, ja, ihr habt Recht und so.
Und wir wissen ja, der CDU sollte man nicht einfach so Recht geben.
Da sollte man auch eigenen Gehirnschmalzkotz mit reinbacken.
Also Gregor Kirchhoff jetzt zur Reichweite des Urteils, dass er da selbst erkämpft hat.
Es gibt aber insgesamt auf Bundesebene 29 Sondervermögen mit einem Gesamtvolumen
von 869 Milliarden Euro.
Einige dieser Sondervermögen sind sehr alt, sie lassen sich zurückverfolgen
bis in die 50er Jahre. Stehen die jetzt alle zur Debatte?
Nicht alle, denn es gibt ein Übergangsrecht, wann die...
Also es steht nicht eine ganze Billion zur Debatte, sagt er so, oder?
Die neue Schuldenbremse aus dem Jahr 2009 greift und die greift erst ab dem Jahr 2011.
Das heißt also, die Sondervermögen, die davor aufgesetzt wurden,
unterliegen nicht der Schuldenbremse und auch damit nicht der Konkretisierung
durch das Bundesverfassungsgericht, die wir gerade erlebt haben.
Es gibt dann im Übergangsrecht eine Sollensvorgabe des Grundgesetzes,
dass danach 2011 die Defizite im Sinne des materiellen Haushaltsausgleichs und
der Schuldenbremse abzubauen sind.
Also wir könnten dann diese alten Sondervermögen hieran prüfen.
Da müssen wir schauen, das ist eine Sollens-Vorgabe. Der Punkt ist aber der,
dass alle Sondervermögen ab dem Jahr 2011 unter die Schuldenbremse in der Konkretisierung
des Bundesverfassungsgerichts aus der aktuellen Entscheidung fallen und dass
wir diesen Dominoeffekt noch gar nicht genau abschätzen können.
So, ich höre raus. Ja, es stehen tatsächlich die ganzen Billionen zur Debatte,
denn die neueren Sondervermögen müssen hart geprüft werden.
Also klar, Corona, da scheint es wahrscheinlich noch so am klarsten zu sein.
Das war legitim, sich da zu verschulden, denn es kam wirklich unverhofft und war halt riesig.
Aber die alten, vor 2011 unterschriebenen Sondervermögen, die müssen halt auch
als wieder abgebaut werden gelten.
Also die sind ja noch da als Schuldenberg. Der muss abgebaut werden.
Also wenn er von einer Billion spricht.
Wir haben im Staatshaushalt, wo wahrscheinlich viele verbucht sind,
irgendwie so 2,5 Billionen Verschuldung, Dann über diese Vehikel,
über die wir jetzt sprechen, also geht schon um so einiges.
Lass mich eine Frage stellen. Wieso hat man es geschafft, bei dem Sondervermögen
für die Bundeswehr, das so gleich zu manifestieren, indem man es auch glaube
ich in die Verfassung reingeschrieben hat, dass man es jetzt nicht mehr antasten kann.
Also dieses ist ja ein Sondervermögen, das, wenn man den Experten glauben darf,
nicht angetastet werden kann.
Also dagegen kann in dem Sinne nicht erfolgreich geklagt werden.
Das bedeutet aber doch für mich, dass man offenbar schon auch in der Bundesregierung
wusste, dass man ein solches Sondervermögen doch noch mal irgendwie besser absichern
muss als all die anderen.
Warum hat man das bei den anderen dann nicht auch getan?
Die Erklärung ist, glaube ich, ganz einfach.
Es war von Anfang an so ein Kalkül mit drinnen. Wir machen mal so Kernhaushalt.
Man sagt jetzt immer Kernhaushalt zum Kernhaushalt und der Rest ist halt so KTF.
Ich habe es ja im Beißerklub auch so kurz als Bad Bank beschrieben.
Man wusste halt, das ist auf wackeligen Füßen. Aber es ist halt auch nur ein grünes Projekt.
Sollen doch die Grünen halt ohne ihre Koalitionsvertragsziele da rauskommen?
So im Sinne von Ja, das ist ja dann deren Problem. Das ist so ein bisschen wie
diese Androhung vorher, dass man sagt, Also wenn Putin wirklich die Ukraine
angreift, dann ist aber die Pipeline Geschichte.
Dann greift Putin an und man stellt fest, ey, die Pipeline war echt das kleinste
Problem. Wir haben sehr viel größere Probleme.
Und so ist das hier auch. Man dachte so, ja, wir bauen das mal in diesen KTF,
das wird schon gut gehen irgendwie.
Es sind nicht alle überzeugt, dass man das machen kann. Die ganze CDU klagt dagegen.
Aber eigentlich hat man schon so im Hinterkopf gehabt, naja,
gut, dann müssen halt die Grünen auf ihre Sachen verzichten.
Aber wenn der Scholz sagt, wir machen jetzt hier ein Sondervermögen Bundeswehr,
dann machen wir lieber mal so, dass man da nie wieder drüber spricht.
Und das ist halt letztinstanzlich im Grundgesetz zwei Drittel Mehrheit.
Ihr habt ja auch in Wohlstand für alle mal darauf hingewiesen,
dass eine zwei Drittel Mehrheit wahrscheinlich relativ kompliziert wird,
wenn erst mal Sarah Warnknecht und die AfD im Bundestag sitzen.
Also dann wirst du wahrscheinlich nie wieder die Verfassung ändern können.
Das läuft dann auch historisch einfach ab.
So im Sinne von, was ist denn überhaupt möglich. Ah ja, ich hatte übrigens die Tweets hier gefunden.
Also Professor Meier, auch einer der etwas renommierteren in Bielefeld,
Krieg in Europa und Nahost, Klima-Migrationskrise.
Egal, fragt sich mittlerweile, ob die, Klammer auf, alle Richter die Folgen
des Urteils abgesehen haben, von Ahrtal bis Länderfinanzen.
Und Alexander Thiele hatte auf diesen Tweet von Marco Buschmann,
den du vorgelesen hast, zur Schuldenbremse sein, Handwerker,
die schlecht gemacht sind. Nee, ist nicht.
Schreiben, eine solche Sakralisierung der Verfassung hilft wahrlich nicht weiter.
Also wir haben es nicht nur mit Orthodoxien und so zu tun, sondern wirklich
mit religiösen Verfehlungen, die wir hier.
Da finde ich übrigens auch dieses Zitat von...
Norbert Lammert, damals Bundestagspräsident, der sagte, die Schuldenbremse,
wie wir sie jetzt gerade abschließen, ist verfassungspolitisch verfehlt,
weil sie zu viel Misstrauen gegenüber den freigewählten Abgeordneten hat.
Ja, es ist ein Antidemokratie-Gesetz.
Es ist ein planwirtschaftliches Gesetz, das wir echt nicht brauchen.
So, Michael Hüther, beschreibt mal, dass auch der Bundesrechnungshof sich gerade Gedanken macht.
Der Bundesrechnungshof hatte eine Vorlage gemacht, der ist ein Vertreter,
der auf der einen Seite ermittelt hat, was an Unterdeckung oder,
sagen wir mal, Überschreitung, sagen wir es so rum, der Schuldengrenze mit 0,35,
entstehen würde, allein durch den Klimatransformationsfonds.
Dann sind das im nächsten Jahr 35 Milliarden.
Und käme noch der Wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds hinzu, sind's nächstes Jahr
noch mal knapp 50 Milliarden.
Und dieses Jahr wären's noch knapp 140. Und das macht die Sache außerordentlich unübersichtlich.
Die erste Einschätzung, es beträfe nur die 60 Milliarden, die quasi annulliert
sind im Klima- und Transformationsfonds, ist zu revidieren. Es geht deutlich darüber hinaus.
So, Jens Südelkomm sagt, das ist eine Zäsur, weil sie auch unerwarteterweise
gegen politische und wirtschaftliche Vernunft spricht,
obwohl das Verfassungsgericht doch eigentlich nie so orthodox,
Sonst hat der immer, was weiß ich,
der Bundestag darf nicht so groß wachsen, wir brauchen ein neues Wahlrecht.
Dann sagt das Verfassungsgericht, ja, das stimmt, ihr braucht echt ein neues
Wahlrecht, aber ihr habt zehn Jahre Zeit. So, ne?
Eigentlich hat man da immer so Fristen drin und sagt dann, ja,
ab dann und dann, der KTF bis 2027 ist erstmal, ne, das geschriebene Geschichte,
weil Deutschland hat ja die Zahlungsverpflichtung auch eingegangen,
also es muss ja bezahlt werden,
aber danach könnt ihr sowas nicht nochmal machen oder wie auch immer.
Oder wir hatten ja 2020...
Als Peter Gauweiler klagte gegen die EU-Kredite und so weiter,
wo er sagt, nee, es muss jetzt niemand eine Billion zurückzahlen und es sind
auch nicht die Steuergelder von Peter Gauweiler, die jetzt irgendwie da sind.
So haben wir den Podcast begonnen, wenn ich mich erinnere.
Ja, das war Mai 2020. Kann man nochmal nachhören. Da hatten wir auch so ein
ganz irres Anliegen ans Bundesverfassungsgericht.
So und jetzt haben wir hier, also Süde kommende sagt, die Zäsur ist zu groß,
weil sie auch sozusagen, Rainer Hauben sagt ja, also wir im politischen Betrieb,
ich als wirtschaftspolitischer Sprecher der Fraktion, die den Finanzminister
stellt, der hat gar keine Ahnung, peu a peu kommen hier so Sachen raus.
Dann sagt Gregor Kirchhoff, ja, es hat schon so ein bisschen Einfluss auf alle,
also auf die eine Billion, die sie da glatt genannt haben, Herr Journalist.
Hüther sagt, naja, es geht ja nicht nur um die 60 Milliarden,
sondern das und dann allein nächstes Jahr schon da 35 Milliarden und so weiter.
Wenn ihr also heute diese Nachrichtenlage hört, also damit meine ich jetzt den 30.
November, das Finanzministerium hat irgendwie eine Finanzlücke von 17 Milliarden für den Haushalt 2014.
Also diese 17 Milliarden kommen überhaupt nur zustande, wenn man alles,
was die Grünen im KTF hatten, so als Bad Bank der Geschichte überlässt und so
weiter. Wenn es nur noch um die Reste geht.
Wie reagiert nun Christian Lindner als verantwortlicher Politiker?
Er ist im Deutschlandfunk-Interview,
der Woche eingeladen und sagt Folgendes.
Ich mach mir jetzt momentan nicht überwiegend parteipolitische Gedanken,
sondern es ist jetzt eine Aufgabe Und letztlich auch eine Frage der Ehre,
dass wir jetzt zu verfassungsrechtlich gesicherten Verhältnissen zurückkehren.
Klimapolitik schon abgeräumt, Sozialstaat zur Disposition gestellt. Warum?
Das wissen wir auch nicht so genau. Meine Fraktion sagt mir auch,
dass es kommt so peu a peu Sachen raus. Es ist jetzt einfach eine Frage der Ehre.
Toll!
Das ist wirklich Trumpesk. Also wir sind ja wirklich auf dem 2016er angelsächsischen
Niveau angekommen. Wir schlagen uns einfach selbst k.o.
Wir machen hier einen finanzpolitischen Suizid quasi.
Das ist ein sehr guter Punkt, denn wir erleben das ja immer wieder,
dass eigentlich relativ gut funktionierende Länder sich ohne Not in die Bredouille bringen,
weil sie dann irgendetwas beschließen und das dann durchführen oder irgendjemanden
wählen, der dann völlig wirr ist.
Also man kann ja auch nicht davon ausgeben, dass es in den Niederlanden besser
wird jetzt mit Gerd Wilders in irgendeiner Richtung.
Da hat wenigstens das Volk entschieden.
Da hat wenigstens noch das Volk entschieden.
Hier machen einfach ein paar Richter so eine Orthodoxie.
Na ja gut, die Richter reagieren darauf, was da mal 2009 festgelegt wurde.
Also ich würde den Richtern gar keinen Vorwurf in dem Sinne machen wollen.
Sondern das haben die Politiker und die meisten von ihnen sind ja immer noch
dabei, sich selbst eingeprockt.
Und wir haben jetzt aber hier einen Finanzminister, der tatsächlich ein absoluter
Ideologe zu sein scheint.
Ich wurde im Wohlstand für alle Podcast gefragt von einem Hörer, ob ich glaube, dass.
Christian Lindner tatsächlich daran glaubt, ich kann nicht in den Kopf reingucken,
aber jetzt so langsam habe ich tatsächlich den Eindruck, es ist die einzige Ideologie, die er hat.
Denn um das mal ganz klar zu machen, also wir reden ja jetzt gleich über Ausgaben,
die zu tätigen werden und dergleichen.
Und du hast schon angedeutet, der Mittelstand wird auch nervös werden.
Ich bin ja kein Keynesianer in dem Sinne, dass ich glaube, wenn man nur investiert,
dann wird es allen super gehen.
Ich sehe schon noch einen Grundwiderspruch am Kapitalismus, der sich mit Keynesianismus
nicht lösen lassen kann.
Aber wo ich mir doch ganz sicher bin, ist, dass mit so einem keynesianischen
Ansatz zu investieren, da wo es nötig ist, um die Konjunktur anzukurbeln,
um die Infrastruktur aufzubauen etc., dass dies tatsächlich dafür sorgt,
dass es sowohl der Privatwirtschaft besser geht, als auch den Menschen im Lande.
Also ich bin schon der Auffassung, dass man von Seiten des Staates eine Wirtschaftspolitik
und Finanzpolitik machen kann, die dafür sorgt, dass es allen etwas besser gehen kann.
Was aber noch nicht dazu führt, dass damit die Klassenwidersprüche aufgehoben
sind oder sonst etwas und das hat auch irgendwo Grenzen.
Also auch die Investitionen haben selbstredend Grenzen und irgendwann können
auch Kapitalmärkte einem böse mitspielen, wenn die dann gar nicht mehr einverstanden sind.
Nur du hast es jetzt schon an diesem extremen Beispiel gezeigt,
Japan, es ginge deutlich mehr und selbst wenn man sich nicht an Japan orientiert,
sondern zum Beispiel an den USA, dann würde man auch erkennen,
dass deutlich mehr möglich ist.
Nun erleben wir aber eine Politik und auch, ich will das noch mal hinzufügen,
sehr viele in den Medien,
die ganz aggressiv gegen eine solche Maßnahme wie das Loslösen der Schuldenbremse,
ein Verabschieden der Schuldenbremse, anschreiben, agitieren.
Und ich frage mich, aus welchem Grunde, Und ich finde in dem Sinne keinen materiellen Grund.
Also ich kann dir sagen, warum gewisse Politiker extrem Werbung für die Aufrüstung machen.
Weil sie mit auf der Payroll stehen, weil das zu ihrem Wahlkreis gehört etc.
Das kann ich dir sehr klar erklären. Und dann gibt es da noch mal eine eigene
ideologische Verblendung.
Aber es gibt diese partikularen Interessen ganz deutlich.
Ich sehe sie bei der Schuldenbremse nicht mehr. Ich sehe hier tatsächlich das
Trampeske dabei, dass man nur noch auf einer solchen Ebene diskutiert.
Dann alles zur Show verkommt, während es dann de facto überall im Land immer
brüchiger wird, Infrastruktur und so weiter zusammenbrechen.
Und das ist etwas, was wir jetzt strukturell in Deutschland,
glaube ich, auf Dauer erleben werden, dass wir diese reinen Scheingefechte in der Politik haben.
Und es sich aber tatsächlich dann extrem auswirkt vor der Haustür,
aber die meisten nicht das in Verbindung setzen können mit dem,
was bundespolitisch falsch läuft, sondern sie suchen sich dann irgendeinen Verantwortlichen,
der gerade zur Verfügung steht.
Genau und das ist ja ein Megaproblem. Wir haben es mit dieser im Grunde ja Showpolitik zu tun.
Also Lindner macht halt was aus Frage der Ehre, dass ich natürlich hier besser
als Theo Weigel Finanzminister bin und so weiter.
Das wurde aber bisher nur geklärt zwischen dem Bundestag, der 2009 etwas macht
und jetzt holt es ihn wieder ein, dass solche Show-Politik tatsächlich strukturelle Folgen hat.
Nur zwischen 2009 und heute liegt ja auch eine ideologische Aufladung.
Schuldenbremse, oh ja, das ist halt so unser kralles Ding jetzt irgendwie.
Wir sind genervt, aber Oma Erne findet das halt richtig. Das heißt,
wenn wir jetzt sagen, naja, Trump, Brexit, in den Niederlanden,
das haben wenigstens die Bevölkerung selbst entschieden.
Wir sind ja klüger. Also wir haben jetzt gesehen, die Schuldenbremse ist irgendwie
dumm, wenn wir jetzt fragen und so weiter.
Wir kennen alle die Umfragewerte, soll die Schuldenbremse eingehalten werden? Die Mehrheit sagt ja.
Aus welchen Gründen? Ja, das ist eine Frage der Ehre. Ich bin als Ehrenmann,
bezahle ich mein Auto natürlich bar und nicht auf Kredit und so.
Und weil sie ja nichts verstehen. Also die meisten Menschen in Deutschland haben
keine Ahnung von nichts.
Genau. Angenommen wir fragen jetzt aber alle. Ich würde sagen wir sollten Angst haben.
Also das Verständnis ist nicht sehr groß. Ich will nur so einen illustrativen Clip spielen.
Micky Beisenherz ist auf der Bühne mit seinem Apokalypse und Filter Kaffee Podcast.
Sie verstricken sich dort auch in so Gespräche zum Thema halt.
Irgendwas ist mit diesen 70 Milliarden und den Chipfabriken.
Das ist ein wunderschönes Stichwort, ich habe neulich mit Ingmar Stadlmann darüber
gesprochen und seine Oma hatte das mitgekriegt, 15 Milliarden für Chipfabriken.
Ist das Ihre Chipfabrik?
Nee, und dann sagte sie so, ist komisch, wer sollen die alle essen?
Tschüss!
Das ist das Niveau. Und wir sind eine Altenrepublik. Wir können nicht erwarten,
dass die Leute von den Tagesthemen oder dem heutigen Halt irgendwie aufgeklärt
wurden in den letzten 10, 20 Jahren, wie das hier so alles funktioniert, was es bedeutet und so.
Also in der Hinsicht Vorsicht bei...
Du sagst jetzt wieder, es ist ein Altenproblem. Zugleich haben wir Äußerungen
von jungen Liberalen, von der jungen Union, die noch deutlich das übertreffen, was die Alten sagen.
Livia Gerster hat gestern im FAZ-Podcast mit zwei jüngeren Abgeordneten von,
den Grünen und von der FDP gesprochen und da habe ich auch gedacht,
Leute, das ist einfach Nachplapperei,
was ihr von euren Obersten aus der Fraktion so hört, also von Gerhard Huben
oder wen auch immer. Reinhard Huben heißt er.
Fratscher zum Thema, was ist jetzt eigentlich die Aufgabenstellung?
Der Staat, und das ist nicht nur ein Thema der Ampel, sondern auch der Vorgängerregierung,
hat in den letzten Krisen viel Geld verteilt.
Mit vollen Händen ausgegeben, per Gießkantriss. Es gibt kaum ein Land in der
Welt, wo die Regierung so großzügig Hilfen ausgegeben hat.
Jetzt realisiert man mit dem Urteil aus Karlsruhe, man kann nicht mehr das Geld
mit beiden Händen ausgeben, über Sonderhaushalte, letztlich Schulden aufnehmen,
an der Schuldenbremse vorbei und gleichzeitig versprechen keine Steuererhöhung.
Also dieser Spagat geht nicht mehr auf. Und die Bundesregierung muss sich ehrlich machen.
Klar, man wird wahrscheinlich jetzt einen pragmatischen Weg finden für 2024.
Irgendwie hoffentlich vorbei, sodass es vom Bundesverfassungsgericht nicht nochmal
moniert werden kann. Aber das löst das grundlegende Problem nicht.
So, das grundlegende Problem, das ist, glaube ich, auch für unsere Hörerschaft
wichtig, ist ja nicht zu wenig Geld, sondern zum Teil auch zu viel.
Also, dass man nach der Corona-Pandemie plötzlich Kreditermächtigung noch offen
hat, ist zum einen Problem, weil man hat wahrscheinlich vorher so ein bisschen
über die Stränge geschlagen.
Nicht nur bei der Frage, wie finanzieren wir das, sondern auch,
wie grenzen wir denn Corona ein.
Also man lag einfach so 60 Milliarden drüber und dann hat man keinen Modus,
wie man mit diesem Geld umgeht.
Man hätte auch sagen können, naja, wir machen mal ein Budget.
Das ist aber nicht an der Jährlichkeit gebunden, sondern wenn nächstes Jahr
das Problem nur noch besteht, beschließen wir einfach noch mal.
Es ist noch aktuell und so weiter und so fort. Es muss aber nicht alles ausgegeben
werden. Untertitel im Auftrag des ZDF für funk, 2017,
Der Bundestag könnte ja auch einfach, hätte ja damals schon sagen können,
cool 60 Milliarden nicht gebraucht, wird wieder sozusagen, es muss ja nicht
mal umgebucht werden, die Drittermächtigung wird gelöscht, wie Lindner dann sagt.
Was uns aber bei der Verschuldungsfrage wieder Spielraum gibt für andere Probleme,
die wir so haben, wie zum Beispiel Klimawandel.
Dass man den Klimawandel dann nicht als ad hoces, plötzliches und so weiter,
das ist halt als Schuldenbremsen-Definitionsproblem.
Dass man da einfach nicht mit rumgeht. Also Fratzscher sagt das schon zu Recht
auch, ja, das ist eben auch zu viel Geld irgendwie.
Das schwirrte so kreuz und quer und dann war es einmal ermächtigt und dann wusste
man nicht wohin und dann hat man irgendwie gedacht, ja, dann machen wir doch
das und das, statt einfach mal eine ordentliche Haushaltsführung.
Da würde ich dann schon sagen, der Staat kommt einem, also er hat zwar andere
Finanzierungsquellen, aber was die Haushaltsführung angeht, lohnt es sich schon,
es zu machen, wie man es privat auch machen.
Ja, dass man nämlich einfach den Kindern sagt, hier hast du 10 Euro,
bring mir aber das Restgeld zurück.
Keiner würde akzeptieren, dass das Kind nach Hause kommt und sagt,
ich habe ein bisschen weniger Milch gekauft und noch mit Wasser auf und deswegen
habe ich jetzt noch 3 Euro extra übrig, die behalte ich aber für mich.
Ich entscheide dann morgen, was ich damit mache, ich sage dir einfach nur Bescheid.
Das ist doch dumm. Also niemand macht sowas.
Und das muss man weder in Unternehmen, wo es dann auch Veruntreuung wäre,
noch im Privaten, noch beim Staat denen das so durchgehen lassen.
Also das hat alles mit dieser Schuldengrenze scheiße zu tun.
Aber das passiert doch beim Sondervermögen der Bundeswehr wird das doch genauso
laufen. Das ist doch ein schwarzes Loch, das man sich geschaufelt hat.
Absolut, absolut. Das ist ganz schlimm. Also Fratsche erklärt jetzt,
welche drei Wege wären zu gehen, um dieses ganze Finanzierungsgefüge mal wieder
ordentlich hinzukriegen.
Und die Abwägung ist, wo soll die Priorität liegen?
Bei Investitionen in Bildung, in Klimaschutz, in digitale Transformation soll
es daran liegen, die Schuldenbremse einzuhalten, so wie sie jetzt ist,
im engen Sinne. Das erfordert...
Das wird keine zusätzlichen Investitionen ermöglichen. Oder muss man auch über
das Steuerthema nachhinehen.
Das sehe ich auch als etwas Gutes. Das Bundesverfassungsgericht sagt der Politik
auf Bund und Ländern, so könnt ihr nicht weitermachen, ihr müsst Prioritäten setzen.
Und aus ökonomischer Sicht ist es dringend notwendig, dass man jetzt eine klare
Ansage macht, wie man sich den Weg bei der Transformation Klimaschutz,
digitales, Technologie in den nächsten zehn, 15 Jahren vorstellt.
So, im Presseclub hat ja Harald Lesch angerufen und gesagt, was ist eigentlich
mit den 60 Milliarden CO2 Subventionen, die das Umweltbundesamt ausflagt als und so weiter.
Und so kann man nämlich das Bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteil auch lesen,
wenn die nämlich wirklich sagen, ihr dürft natürlich Klimapolitik machen,
aber keine extra Verschuldung.
Dann könnte man auch einfach abverlangen, dass das Klima- und Wirtschaftsministerium,
sagt, ja, wenn wir uns nicht verschulden dürfen, also wenn wir keine positiven,
Anreize hinsichtlich einer Subvention, einer finanziellen Unterstützung,
dann haben wir eine zweite Möglichkeit, wir nehmen es zurück.
Also in dem Maße, wie man jetzt neue Technologien fördert, kann man natürlich
auch die Förderung der alten einfach rausnehmen.
Wäre genauso klimawirksam. Man müsste nur sehr vielen Leuten auf den Füßen treten plötzlich.
So das wollte man halt vermeiden. Und in der Hinsicht ist das schon eine Trickserei,
die wenn die Politik sich Ziele setzt, wie die Schuldenbremse einhalten,
ja dann ist Klimapolitik halt das, was das Klima schädigt, rauszunehmen.
Also und da haben wir ja genug für die Kerosin, für die Flugzeuge besteuern,
die ganzen Autosubventionen rausnehmen und so weiter und so fort.
Gut, dieser Weg wird nicht gegangen.
Also Kürzen, Schulden, Steuererhöhung. Ich würde sagen, es bleibt immer noch,
dass man eine Notlage ausruft.
Nur wie begründen? Sie muss ja plötzlich sein. Das Klima kann man nicht ausrufen,
weil das ist ja selbst gemacht und nicht plötzlich.
Dieser Reinhard Houben macht hier mal eine besondere Beobachtung.
Welche Notlagen-Argumentation könnte man eigentlich machen?
Also es waren sich bisher alle einig, dass die Rahmenbedingungen für eine Schuldenbremse
aus der aktuellen Situation heraus nicht haltbar ist.
Also wir haben einen gewissen Rückgang der Wirtschaft, aber das ist nach Artikel
115 sicherlich nicht eine Notlage, wo man auf die Schuldenbremse zurückgreifen könnte.
Die Notlage entsteht jetzt durch das Verfassungsgerichtsurteil,
weil eben geübte Praxis nicht mehr akzeptiert wird.
Das wäre doch genial, oder?
Dann hat man jetzt die Notlage in Halsruhe geschaffen.
Durch das Notlagenurteil.
Ja. Ja, ja, klar.
Und er ist nicht der Einzige. Der Hüter führt das auch kurz,
also meins witzig, aber es ist ja natürlich schon ausgesprochen.
Das Urteil...
Bezogen auf eine Notlagendeklaration früherer Jahre führt ja jetzt faktisch
zu einer Notlage des Steuer- und Finanzstaates. Steuer- und Finanzstaates.
Das wäre doch witzig eigentlich, oder? Wenn der Bundestag jetzt kommt und sagt,
wir müssen den Notlageparagrafen für 2024 ziehen, weil im November 2023 und
das Bundesverfassungsgericht ganz plötzlich eine nicht von uns hervorge-
also nicht von uns gemachte, sondern es war ein Unfall.
Wir sind jetzt in der Notlage, weil es keine Notlagen mehr geben darf.
Also das ist schon sehr verrückt. Gut, Gregor Kirchhoff.
Über die Entscheidung des Bundesverfassungsgerichts
spreche ich jetzt mit Professor Gregor Kirchhoff.
Er ist Inhaber des Lehrstuhls für öffentliches Recht, Finanzrecht und Steuerrecht
an der Universität Augsburg und Direktor des dortigen Instituts für Wirtschafts- und Steuerrecht.
Guten Morgen, Herr Professor Kirchhoff. Guten Morgen, Herr Klenner.
Ich freue mich auf unser Gespräch.
In der Abwägung, was ist jetzt zukunftsgenerationengerecht?
Keine Infrastruktur oder keine Schulden?
Kann man sagen, vielleicht gibt es auch einen Mittelweg irgendwie. Bei ihm nicht.
Wenn der Domino-Effekt so groß ist, wie wir erwarten, wir wissen das ja nicht
genau, der ist nicht genau abschätzbar, aber wenn das Bundesfinanzministerium,
das jetzt ermisst und sieht, das ist die Größe des Domino-Effekts,
dann braucht man auch Zeit, um darauf zu reagieren.
Und nochmal, das ist der richtige Weg, jetzt nach weiteren Ausnahmen zu suchen,
die dann natürlich wieder angegriffen würden und dann wahrscheinlich wieder
kassiert werden, wenn sie zweifelhaft sind.
Das wäre genau falsch. Es geht jetzt darum, das Grundgesetz und den Rechtsstaat
und damit auch die Generationengerechtigkeit zu stärken.
So, Generationengerechtigkeit heißt der unverzehrte Rechtsstaat und das ist
tatsächlich ein Fetisch. Ja, das kennen wir alle.
Vielleicht nicht aus eigener Anschauung, aber dem Gefühl nach.
Menschen bekommen irgendwas geliefert, und sie schauen es sich noch in der Verpackung
an, weil sie wissen, wenn sie die Verpackung aufgemacht haben,
ist es schon weniger wert.
Oder ein Auto wird geliefert. Wenn man die Tür aufmacht und sich reinsetzt,
sind schon ein Drittel des Wertes weg.
Ja, nicht ganz.
Beim iPhone, ich hab das mit Mic, war so überschlagen, da noch mal nachgeguckt,
ja, man kann noch originalverpackte iPhones von damals kaufen, 2007, 20.000 Dollar.
Also man hat Wertsteigerungen durch Nichtbenutzung eines Nutzungsgegenstandes.
Ja, das ist doch die große Challenge bei Twitch, da werden die uralten Pokémonkarten geöffnet.
Sowas zum Beispiel, genau.
Die 50.000 Wert.
Genau, der Thrill liegt dann da drin, dass man sie dann geöffnet hat in dem
Moment und diese Idee steckt auch in diesen Köpfen drin. Wenn der Rechtsstaat
nichts rausgibt, bleibt er rein.
Wenn er sich mit dem Gesocks und dem Taugenichts nicht befassen muss,
dann hat er so eine reine Güte. Dann ist er mehr wert.
Wir dürfen ihn nicht verzehren. Er muss sozusagen, wir dürfen nichts rausnehmen.
Das schwingt da einfach mit. Das ist immer so ein Fetisch.
Dabei immer bedenken, dass es ja ein menschengemachtes Gesetz ist.
Aber wir haben hier auch wieder einen sakralen Diskurs darüber.
Absolut, absolut. Mega sakral. Das Gericht stärkt den Bundestag.
Hier würde ich sagen, das stimmt.
Also am Ende hat das Gericht nur gesagt, wenn der Bundestag entscheidet,
ist es eine Schuldenbremse. Es ist halt Schuldenbremse. Es kommt darauf an,
was der Bundestag entscheidet.
Was das Gericht fordert ist, dass sich der Bundestag in Vergewisserung,
ob die Ausnahmesituation noch besteht und ob sie finanzwirksam ist weiterhin,
ob sie sich weiterhin der Kontrolle des Staates entzieht. Das sind die Voraussetzungen.
Der Bundestag muss sich also vergewissern jedes Jahr, ob das noch so ist.
Er kann langfristig planen und er kann auch sozusagen langfristig auf eine Notsituation reagieren.
Er muss aber immer wieder diese Vergewisserung zwischenschalten,
sonst werden, und das ist ja passiert, sonst gibt es Umgehungsstrategien,
was die Schuldenbremse angeht.
Und diese Vergewisserung behindert jetzt nicht eine langfristige Replik auf
eine Notsituation, sondern ist einfach eine Befassung des Bundestages.
So und das ist ja wahnsinnig irre. In Amerika fanden wir es ja immer komisch,
und Esther Klein hat es ja zu Recht, als die dümmste und gefährlichste Regierungspraxis beschrieben,
dass der Kongress zwar einen Haushalt beschließt und wenn dann Verschuldung
drin ist, muss danach noch eine zweite Entscheidung stattfinden,
ob man die Verschuldungsgrenze auch anhebt.
Da sagt er, das ist dumm. Der Kongress hat doch schon entschieden, was er will.
Warum soll er nochmal darüber entscheiden, dass man dann auch die Schuldenbremse
anhebt? Das sehen die doch vorher, um welchen Maß sie sich verschuldet haben.
In Deutschland haben wir diese zweite Entscheidung einfach rausgenommen und
als normative Grenze ins Grundgesetz geschrieben.
Das ist noch dümmer als die amerikanische Regierungspraxis.
Denn da würde vermutlich jetzt schon aufgrund des Drucks der Länder,
auch der CDU-Länderchefs, eine Mehrheit gefunden werden dafür,
dass man sagt, naja, aber jetzt genehmigen wir uns doch nochmal ein bisschen
mehr Geld, denn wir brauchen es ja für all die Investitionen.
Genau, da werden auch noch mal kleine Zuverständnisse gehandelt oder sowas, wie auch immer.
Aber am Ende kommt man, die Regierung hat noch nie, also das Parlament hat noch
nie dagegen entschieden, weil dann kommt es ja immer zu diesen Shutdowns und so weiter.
Das hält dann für drei Wochen und dann sagt man, okay, dann gehen wir jetzt
on the floor und entscheiden halt, Schuldenbremse wird angehoben, die Schuldenbremse.
In Deutschland gibt es diesen Weg einfach gar nicht. Weil man könnte ja auch
sagen, wenn das Jährigkeitsprinzip jetzt so hart gilt, müsste eigentlich auch
der Bundestag jedes Jahr entscheiden, ob die Schuldenbremse gilt und nicht einfach
Paradigma im Grundgesetz.
Also das sind ja diese Freiheitsdiskussionen, die dann geführt werden.
Jetzt kommt ein Argument, das ist so irre, du darfst es gleich kommentieren.
Ich weiß nicht, du hast es ja schon. Also das ist eigentlich ein typisches Wohlstands-für-alle-Thema.
Wir können ausgehen von so einer, ja, es gibt so laufende Ausgaben und die kann
man unter Konsum und dann gibt es welche, die laufen unter Investition und wie auch immer.
Sie müssen auch sehen, dass die Schuldenbremse aus dem Jahr 2009 auf eine Schuldenpraxis
reagiert, die wir lange erlebt haben.
Wir haben seit den 1970er Jahren die Expizitenstaatsschulden,
die Expiziten sind noch viel höher, von damals ungefähr 60, 70 Milliarden Euro umgerechnet,
auf jetzt 2.500 Milliarden Euro erhöht.
Und Sie müssen dabei sehen, dass sich Schulden eigentlich für die öffentliche Hand kaum lohnen.
Denn wenn ein Unternehmer mit Schulden zum Beispiel eine neue Produktionsanlage
finanziert, dann gewinnt der Geldmittel, wenn die Produktionsanlage läuft und
kann so die Schulden tilgen.
Aber der Staat ist steuerfinanziert und dann stellt sich die Frage,
welche Steuereinnahmen denn durch Schulden unmittelbar erhöht werden,
das gelingt meistens nicht.
Vielleicht, wenn man gut investiert, würde man ja mehr Gewerbesteuer einnehmen,
man würde mehr Umsatzsteuer einnehmen.
Man hätte aber auch einen Vermögensberg insofern geschaffen,
als man eine gut funktionierende Infrastruktur hat.
Grüne Wälder, gute Bewässerung, was auch immer.
Also ist das nichts. Also ist generell ist so, wenn der Staat Schulden aufnimmt,
dass er einfach nur Schulden mehr hat und sonst nichts.
Und dann, was ist das für eine Überlegung? Also er sagt, Jetzt haben wir 2500
Milliarden Euro Schulden und er bringt dann die 70er Jahre ins Spiel und da
fing eigentlich das ganze Elend an.
So sagt er es eigentlich hier. Nun.
Was ist das große Problem im Kapitalismus
bei einem sehr fortschrittlich entwickelten Land wie Deutschland?
Naja, wir haben seit den 70er Jahren eigentlich kein richtiges Wirtschaftswachstum mehr.
Das heißt, der Kapitalismus ist in einer Dauerkrise, deswegen spricht ja auch
Wolfgang Streeck von der gekauften Zeit. Also man nimmt Schulden auf,
kauft sich dann noch mal Zeit.
Man kann also überhaupt nur den Kapitalismus so weiter am Leben halten,
wie er ist, indem man auch entsprechende Investitionen tätigt,
indem man auch billiges Geld zur Verfügung stellt,
damit auch auf der privaten Seite Investitionen getätigt werden und dass das
in den 70er Jahren begann mit dem hohen Schulden machen, liegt auch daran,
dass der Kapitalismus schon so weit entwickelt ist.
Und jetzt kommt noch was hinzu, wenn er jetzt sagt, ja wir haben mehr Schulden,
aber wie würde man dann mehr Einnahmen bekommen, weil der Unternehmer bekommt
ja mehr Einnahmen, wenn er was Neues gebaut hat, aber der Staat nicht.
Aber der Staat profitiert doch in, also als Steuereinnehmer profitiert doch
ganz, ganz entscheidend davon, dass die Wirtschaft brummt.
Ich will es mal, ich will ihn mit seinen eigenen Waffen schlagen.
Zum einen, er macht hier ein ökonomisches Argument.
Zudem ein historisches. Er könnte also einfach nachgucken oder GPT fragen.
Haben wir durch höhere öffentliche Investitionen schon mal höhere Steuern eingenommen in den Jahren darauf?
Und er hat ja die Zahlen gerade genannt. Wir sind derzeit mit 2,5 Billionen Euro verschuldet.
Diese Verschuldung ist aufgelaufen zwischen Staatsgründung 1949 und 2023.
Das sind also 74 Jahre.
In diesen 74 Jahren haben wir uns mit 2,5 Billionen Euro verschuldet.
Allein nächstes Jahr wird erwartet, dass wir eine Billion Steuereinnahmen machen.
Wahrscheinlich haben wir dieses
Jahr auch so ungefähr eine Billion und wahrscheinlich letztes Jahr auch.
Dann war ein bisschen Corona-Klick, aber ich würde mal sagen,
wir haben in den letzten 74 Jahren.
Sagen wir mal pro Jahr so, gehen wir mal von einer halben Billion im Durchschnitt
aus, also heute liegen wir weit drüber, damals weit drunter,
das hieße ja 75, 74 mal eine halbe Billion.
Also wir sind ja irgendwo bei 35, 36 Billionen Steuereinnahmen.
Diese 36 Billionen Steuereinnahmen haben uns 2,5 Billionen Verschuldung gekostet. Ist das eine...
Profitable Kalkulation, wo wir alle sagen können, das hat Sinn gemacht. Ich würde sagen, ja.
Ich wüsste keine andere bessere Investitionsmöglichkeit.
Ja, also eine Einnahme, die Faktor 10 bis 20 über den Ausgaben liegt.
Dann kann man noch ein bisschen Zinsen einrechnen, aber da kommen wir längst
nicht auf Faktor 10 über dem Schuldenstand, sondern schlagen wir noch mal,
keine Ahnung, 100 Prozent Zinsen drauf.
Also, sagen wir mal, Faktor 10 hat sich das ausgezahlt in die Verschuldung zu
gehen, weil Steuereinnahmen.
So. Oder andersrum gerechnet.
Wenn wir jetzt sagen, okay, der Bundeshaushalt ist 445 Milliarden,
687 Millionen, 863 und so weiter.
Wenn wir jetzt das Gesundheitsministerium mit 16 Milliarden rausstreichen,
Weil wir müssen ja sparen, wir wollen ja Kredite vermeiden, wir belassen also
alles wie es ist, aber das Gesundheitsministerium nehmen wir raus.
Was würden die Volkswirtschaftler prognostizieren, wie sich unsere Steuereinnahmen
entwickeln die nächsten Jahre?
Sollten wir die 16 Milliarden lieber notfalls schuldenfinanziert im Bundeshaushalt
lassen und damit das Erwerbspersonenpotential in einem gesunden Zustand?
Oder glauben wir, wir können darauf verzichten?
Wir können auch deinen Vorschlag nochmal aufgreifen. Was glaubt ihr denn würde
passieren, wenn man tatsächlich die Renten um 20% kürzen würde?
Könnte das vielleicht für den Einzelhandel zu einem kleinen oder größeren Problem werden?
Genau, würde das zu Turbulenzen im Nahverkehr? Würde Harald Schmidt dann fragen.
Klar kann man jetzt Juristen vorwerfen, sie legen Verfassungstexte sakral aus,
aber dass Juristen so über ökonomische und historisch belegbare Zusammenhänge
reden, finde ich geht einfach gar nicht.
Und die Sakralität beginnt da, wo er glaubt, dass das ein heiliges Gesetz ist,
insofern als es die absolute Vernunft gebietet, ein solches Gesetz zu installieren.
Was die in Karlsruhe gemacht haben, ist ja sich nur anzusehen,
was ist jetzt gerade Gesetz und stimmt die Politik mit dem Gesetz überein.
Aber hier wird ja das Normativ so aufgeladen, dass man sagt,
dies ist der einzig richtige Weg, der zu gehen ist.
Alles andere wäre unrein und deshalb müssen wir daran festhalten.
Jetzt hören wir mal, wie orthodox man es auslegen kann.
Also um ein Beispiel aus dem Steuerrecht zu bringen. Das Bundesverfassungsgericht
hat in der Erbschaftsteuerentscheidung 3 gesagt, dass ein Gesetz von vornherein
verfassungswidrig ist, ein Steuergesetz, wenn es zu viele Umgehungen zulässt,
die dem Gesetzeszweck widersprechen.
Das ist ein ganz bekannter Gedanke und er war präsent.
Also zu sagen, dass die Schuldenbremse jetzt überinterpretiert wird,
da würde ich dann schon sagen, das ist so nicht.
Denn, das begründet das Verfassungsgericht, der Gedanke war präsent,
er ist sogar in das Grundgesetz eingeflossen.
Und nochmal, es wäre ja zu einfach, sie gründen einfach ein Sondervermögen und
nehmen dann Schulden auf.
Das ist eine ganz einfache Umgebungsstrategie, die kann so, sollte so nicht
funktionieren und kann auch nicht funktionieren.
Sondervermögen nach dieser Diktion sind jetzt immer verboten,
weil sie ja auch durch Kürzungen im Haushalt aus dem laufenden Betrieb finanziert
werden können, selbst bei einer Notlage.
Aber man kann sagen, ja klar ist jetzt Corona passiert oder das Ahrtal-Hochwasser,
oder wie auch immer, dann müssen halt die Rentner jetzt mal solidarisch sich
zeigen und auf ihre 100 Milliarden Zuschuss aus dem Bundeshaushalt verzichten.
Weil wenn wir jetzt sagen, wir machen eine extra Verschuldung wegen dem Ahrtal-Hochwasser,
dann machen wir die ja nur, weil es eine Schuldenbremse gibt.
Und damit ist sie automatisch verfassungswidrig, also das Sondervermögen.
Das ist seine Argumentation.
Das heißt, er hat jetzt schon die letzten 29 oder 19 Sondervermögen in Höhe
von 900 irgendwas Milliarden rausgestrichen aus der Geschichte und sagt,
künftig sind gar keine mehr möglich.
Weil wir immer einen laufenden Betrieb haben, aus dem wir es auch bezahlen können
und jedes Sondervermögen, das wir anstreben, egal wie gut begründet, ist immer eine bewusste,
Abseits der Schuldenbremse aufgebaute Sache.
Lass mich die Frage stellen, die ich eben schon skizziert habe.
Cui Bono, wem nützt jetzt dieses Gesetz? Wem nützt die Schuldenbremse?
Haben wir es hier mit wirklich reiner Ideologie zu tun?
Ich meine, diese Austeritätspolitik ist ja etwas, was die Neoliberalen seit
Jahrzehnten predigen und auch umsetzen. Wenngleich sie dann immer schon ihre
Sondervermögen hatten oder ihre Sonderausgaben.
Beispielsweise Ronald Reagan hat den Militäretat unglaublich aufgeblasen.
Aber wem ist jetzt damit geholfen, dass man genau so agiert?
Ich verstehe ja die FDP- und CDU-Logik, dass man konsumtive Ausgaben möglichst
gering halten will, damit Leute möglichst wenig Geld bekommen.
Zum Beispiel Kindergrundsicherung, Bürgergeld etc., damit sie zur Arbeit gezwungen werden.
Das ist ja ein ganz klares Interesse des Kapitals.
Deswegen will man möglichst hart die Leute auftreffen lassen,
damit sie gezwungen sind zu arbeiten.
Aber hier haben wir es ja mit ganz anderen Investitionen noch zu tun.
Also die auch ganz explizit nicht konsumtive Ausgaben sind, sondern es geht
um Investitionen. Und da sehe ich tatsächlich nicht den Vorteil mehr.
Ich zeige dir einen.
Ja, bitte.
Die Vermieter in Deutschland, damit meine ich nicht die Baubranche,
sondern nur die Vermieter, also diejenigen, die,
Initial das Geld geben, damit jemand in der Baubranche ihnen ein Haus baut.
Wenn die hören, es ist ein Bedarf von 400.000 Wohnungen, sagen die sich,
400.000 Wohnungen, dann wäre der Markt gesättigt, dann bauen wir nur 250.000.
Weil wenn noch 150.000 Leute drängen, in meine Mietwohnung einzuziehen,
kann ich die Mietpreise nach oben setzen.
Denen ist natürlich total wichtig, dass der Staat zwar das Ziel ausgibt,
400.000 Wohnungen, aber keinen einzigen Euro aus öffentlicher Investition in
diese Projekte fließen.
Also das beispielsweise wie in Wien der Staat selbst die Wohnung baut und dann
vermietet, weil das wäre ja Konkurrenz auf dem Mietmarkt.
Plötzlich hätten alle eine Wohnung, die eine brauchen und der Staat würde auch
noch sagen, naja, wir wollen ja keinen Profit machen, uns ist ja nur wichtig, dass du wohnst.
Deswegen sagen die, ne Schuldenbremse, es darf hier gar kein öffentlicher Euro
investiert werden auf unserem Markt.
Und genau den Zustand haben wir jetzt. Also die Regierung sagte,
wir wollen 2023 400.000 Wohnung bauen, weil das der Bedarf ist.
Wir investieren aber öffentlich gar nichts. Die Baubranche baut 250.000 und
die Vermieter denken sich, cool, alle Renditen bleiben bei uns.
Plus wir haben überhaupt Renditen, weil die Mieten entsprechend hoch sind,
weil wir jedem Vermieter sagen können, jedem Mieter, du musst hier nicht wohnen.
Es gibt noch zehn andere Interessenten, aber wenn du hier wohnst, ist das der Mietpreis.
So, und dann hast du einfach die Hälfte der Stadt Frankfurt,
die 50 Prozent ihres verfügbaren Monatseinkommens ausgibt und es stehen trotzdem
noch die Leute Schlange und sind bereit noch mehr zu bezahlen, nur um zu wohnen.
Also da haben wir so einen glasklaren Fall, würde ich sagen.
Okay, in dem Fall kann ich das total verstehen, aber darüber hinaus ist das schon schwierig.
Also du weißt ja, dass Mieten in Deutschland da irgendwie in Großstädten wie
Berlin 80 Prozent Mieter sind.
Was jetzt heißt, du nimmst die ganze volkswirtschaftliche Größe oder die ganzen
Lohnzahlungen, die in Berlin geleistet werden.
3 Millionen Menschen gehen arbeiten, Berlin brummt, alles ist ausgelastet,
3 Millionen Menschen verdienen, sagen wir mal im Schnitt, diese 2.500 Euro im Monat,
das kann man ja mal aufsummieren und die Hälfte davon fließt an die Vermieter.
Das reicht als partikulares Interesse, um bundesweit eine Schuldenbremse durchzupauken.
Man denkt dann nur ist ja nur der Wohnmarkt oder so weiter, aber das ist groß genug.
Also die Kräfte, die da walten, um das so zu lassen, sind groß genug.
Und die sagen dann auch, was interessieren mich die anderen Branchen.
Gut, wir können das ja weiterspielen. Wir wissen ganz genau,
würden wir jetzt eine Billionenfrage daraus machen, wie wir es hier vorschlagen,
dann sähe die Bahn völlig anders aus und würde so gut funktionieren,
dass man überhaupt nicht mehr auf die Idee käme, ein Uber zu buchen oder ein Auto zu kaufen.
Und damit hat man selbstverständlich auch wieder viele Partikularinteressen bös gemacht.
In der Hinsicht finde ich es schon.
So kann man es sich rechtfertigen, ja.
Also derzeit kämpfen die einen Branchen gegen die anderen.
Ja, denn das ist das Interessante. Diese Widersprüchlichkeit ist ja eine Binnenwidersprüchlichkeit.
Das ist ja jetzt nicht nur extern. Also du hast ja jetzt gerade eine externe geschildert.
Also es gibt die Mieter und die Vermieter, ja, und die stehen sich feindlich
gegenüber. Und dann gibt es private Unternehmen, die davon profitieren,
dass nicht in Infrastruktur investiert wird.
Und dann gibt es aber selbstverständlich in der privaten Unternehmerschaft ganz
viele, die wahnsinnig davon profitieren würden, wenn der Staat investieren würde.
Auch übrigens ja Unternehmen auf dem Lande, die hoffen, dass da irgendwann einmal
ein gutes Schienennetz wäre, damit überhaupt Leute dort arbeiten wollen.
Weil die sagen, naja, wenn ich hier zwei Stunden Anfahrt habe,
werde ich da nie jemanden beschäftigen können. Was soll ich dem zahlen,
dass er das auf sich nimmt?
Ja. Und wir können es an einem weiteren Fall festmachen.
Nicht nur in der Baubranche will man keine neuen Akteure, um die alten Vermögen zu schützen.
Natürlich auch in der ganzen Energie und Industrie.
Könnte man dann nicht einfach sagen, wir rufen jetzt jedes Jahr die Notlage
aus wegen der Klimakrise? Also die Klimakrise ist eine ganz drängende Aufgabe
unserer Zeit und da müssen wir entschlossen und auch sehr geschickt handeln.
Da bedarf es vor allem auch der internationalen Kooperation, die besser geht.
Geschlossen und geschickt und auch nur international, das kriegen wir alleine nie hin.
Weil es ein weltweites Ereignis ist, auf das wir weltweite Antworten finden müssen.
Die Klimakrise bewirkt keine außergewöhnliche Notsituation und auch keine Naturkatastrophe
im Sinne der Schuldenbremse.
Also sie gibt nicht die Möglichkeit, die Schuldenbremse zu ziehen.
Die Zahl der Naturkatastrophen nimmt aber erkennbar zu.
Ja, das stimmt. Aber genau das ist der Punkt. Denn das Grundgesetz geht hier
von plötzlichen Ereignissen aus, auf die sich der Haushaltsgesetzgeber nicht
einstellen konnte. Und deshalb darf er Schulden ziehen.
Aber die Klimakrise ist eine Krise, von der wissen wir schon sehr lange und
wir können erahnen, was die Folgen sein werden.
Sie ist deshalb kein so plötzliches Ereignis und zudem ist sie in weiten Teilen menschengemacht.
Und ein menschengemachtes Ereignis, da kann man da nicht mit Schulden drauf
reagieren, weil dann könnten wir ja den Schuldennotstand selbst kreieren.
So und das finde ich jetzt mal das Beispiel.
Der Bundeshaushalt ist ein Budget, in das werden keine Abgaben eingezahlt,
die zweckgebunden sind, sondern Steuern, die stehen allgemein zur Verfügung.
Das heißt, wir wissen gar nicht insgesamt, wenn wir jetzt das Klima einpreisen in den Kernhaushalt,
wissen wir gar nicht, werden eigentlich gerade die 20, 30 Milliarden Klimasubventionen
aus dem Schuldenteil bezahlt oder die Renten.
Und wenn man jetzt vor das Bundesverfassungsgericht geht und sagt,
ich verstehe das nicht genau, wieso bezahlen wir denn die Renten über Schulden?
Das wussten wir doch, dieses Problem, das ist doch von uns gemacht.
Es kommt weder plötzlich noch sonst irgendwas.
Also die demografischen Grundlagen sind ja wohl mal gegeben.
Das hätte doch Deutschland sehen müssen, dass man das einpreisen muss.
Wieso haben sie denn den Staatshaushalt immer größer gemacht?
Also man kann genauso gut einfach, das hat die Monika Schnitzer,
die Wirtschaftsweise, Vorsitzende der Wirtschaftsweise, auch so angemerkt.
Naja, bei den neuen politischen Vorhaben kann man ja davon ausgehen,
die sind gut durchdacht und gut begründet.
Diejenigen, die das wollen, sitzen aktuell noch im Bundestag.
Um diese Mehrheiten muss man sich nicht sorgen.
So, die Klimapolitik ist ja
verabschiedet. Wann haben wir eigentlich die Rentenpolitik verabschiedet?
Wann haben wir eigentlich entschieden, dass wir den Rentenanteil einfach auf
den Bundeshaushalt zahlen? Das sind ja Leute, die sind heute gar nicht mehr im Bundestag.
Können wir denn wirklich davon ausgehen, dass diese Mehrheiten noch so da sind?
Sollten wir das nicht auch noch mal zum richtigen Thema machen und dann noch
mal die Mehrheiten abfragen, wie die eigentlich sind?
121 Milliarden aus dem Bundeshaushalt für die Rente.
Also kann man genauso gut zur Disposition stellen.
Was ist das überhaupt für ein Kriterium Menschen gemacht? Ist der Krieg in der
Ukraine nicht Menschen gemacht?
Also hier haben wir es glaube ich schon mit so einer Marktschließungslogik zu tun.
Denn diese neuen Technologien, insbesondere der Energiegewinnung,
also du hast einen Solarpark und der wirft irgendwie, also der gibt dir Strom
für vier Cent pro Kilowattstunde, da kommen die Alten gar nicht mit.
Also wir haben die Atomkraftwerke auch abgeschaltet, weil sie selbst,
nachdem sie amortisiert sind, nicht mithalten können mit diesen Preisen.
Das muss man mal durchdenken. Also wie viel hier jetzt gerade sozusagen alter
Wohlstand geschützt wird, indem
man einfach neue Technologien als nicht förderungswürdig durchschulden,
weil keine Notlage und nicht plötzlich.
Und dann werden die einfach rausgestrichen. Und das gilt aber für die Rente
genauso, die wir aus dem Bundeshaushalt zahlen. Nun gut, künftige Generation,
das Klima, Demografie, Infrastruktur.
Also die Staatsverschuldung, die so gestiegen ist, war immer wieder verbunden
mit dem Versprechen, dass die nächste Generation dann von Ernten profitieren wird.
Doch in der Vergangenheit sind diese Ernten oft ausgeblieben.
Die Ernten sind oft ausgeblieben. Also wir hatten zum Beispiel diese großen Ausgaben für,
in jeder Stadt muss jetzt eine Universität stehen, Wir wollen ein hyperakademisches Land,
weil wir nur die Köpfe haben und so weiter und wir sind jetzt die drittgrößte
Volkswirtschaft der Welt mit einem erheblichen Weltmarktanteil an Industriegütern,
Maschinenbau und so weiter und so fort.
Aber die sind immer ausgeblieben. Diese Investitionen in Infrastruktur sind immer ausgeblieben.
Leider historisch nirgendwo auffindbar, wo Deutschland profitiert hat davon Geld auszugeben.
Ja das ist die Ideologie dahinter, dass man versucht die Schuldenbremse zu etablieren,
um eigentlich das Land vor der Demokratie zu schützen.
Das ist die Absicht hier und was ja auch nochmal so schön hier so erklingt ist,
dass er eigentlich so einen dysfunktionalen Staat herauf beschwört,
der so schlimm bürokratisch ist, dass das gut gemeint war, man hat diese Schulden
damals nicht dann genehmigt, aber man hat nix daraus gemacht.
Genau, er sagt in diesem Clip noch, ich will hier nicht so lange spielen,
oder wir hören uns das mal an, weil das Demografiethema spielt nochmal eine besondere Rolle.
Wenn die Mittel von Next Generation EU ausgegeben werden, dann hat man Zweifel,
dass es zu hervorragenden Ernten kommen wird.
Es ist der grundlegende Gedanke der Generationengerechtigkeit.
Und was jetzt hier ausgemacht wird, ist so eine Bilanz, wir investieren jetzt
und dann profitiert die nächste Generation davon, also muss sie jetzt auch die
finanziellen Folgen tragen.
Aber wissen Sie, wir können in diese Bilanz nicht nur die möglichen positiven
Folgen, die möglichen Ernten einstellen, sondern wir müssen auch die Lasten einstellen.
Und wir haben gegenwärtig schon viele Lasten auf die nächste Generation verschoben.
Da geht es um den Kampf gegen den Klimawandel, da geht es um die Demografie
mit den Folgen für die Sozialsysteme und den Fachkräftemangel,
da geht es um die Infrastrukturentscheidungen, die nicht hinreichend entschlossen
getroffen wurden, Digitalisierung, Bahn und so weiter.
Da geht es auch um die drängende Frage der Sicherheit. Also in dieser Situation
der nächsten Generation, die schon viel zu tragen hat, weitere Lasten aufzubürden,
das ist mir einfach nicht plausibel.
Erzählt die Probleme auf.
Und sagt dann, jetzt können wir nicht auch noch ein Schuldenberg daneben stellen.
Das ist doch, also das ist doch so eine Quälerei irgendwie, so eine intellektuelle Quälerei mit...
Er ist ja der Auffassung, dass der Staat nur Schulden aufnimmt,
aber keine Vermögensberge schafft.
Denn wenn er diese Verbindung herstellen würde, wäre ihm ja klar,
dass genau diese Probleme kleiner werden, je größer der Schuldenberg wird.
Ja.
Aber lasst mich noch einmal gerade den Advokatus Diaboli spielen,
denn es ist ja so, dass wir uns jetzt total einig sind darüber,
wie schlimm die Schuldenbremse ist und wir alle haben tausend Projekte im Kopf,
die gefördert werden müssten.
Jetzt nehmen wir aber doch mal an, wir hätten eine andere Regierung als diese
und ich will gar nicht eine konkrete ausmachen.
Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, stellt euch vor die AfD wäre an der Macht,
sondern ich sage einfach mal, wir haben eine andere Regierung und die hätte
andere Investitionsziele, zum Beispiel Deutschland zur führenden Weltraumnation zu machen.
Jetzt bin ich nicht ganz dagegen, dass man auch in diese Forschung investiert.
Aber nehmen wir mal an, das wäre jetzt wirklich das große Herzensprojekt.
Also man würde immenses Budget dafür aufbringen, um hier der NASA Konkurrenz zu machen.
Und man könnte davon ausgehen, da wir ja auch die Bundeswehr nicht mehr mit
Uniformen ausstatten können,
dass dieses Projekt am Ende sehr scheitert und dass es auch völlig unrentabel
sein wird für eine zukünftige Generation,
wenn wir die Weltraumnation Nummer 1 sind.
Heißt also, es gibt ja durchaus Ausgaben, die man tätigen könnte im,
großen Ausmaß, die nicht sinnvoll sind. Dann hätten wir diesen Schuldenberg.
Der Schuldenberg bedeutet für die künftige Generation, dass sie den auch hat,
den abtragen muss. Man kann sich dann wieder neu verschulden etc.
Aber mit Zinsen, die zu zahlen sind, wäre man tatsächlich dann ein Geengter
in seinem Handlungsradius.
Wir denken ja jetzt gerade über die Schuldenbremse als eine Bremse von Investitionen,
die nötig sind, um zukunftsfähig zu sein, aber man könnte ja auch sagen,
die Schuldenbremse ist dazu da,
damit tatsächlich jetzt die heutigen nicht so verantwortungslos agieren und
die anderen haben das in 10, 20 Jahren zu tragen.
Also eigentlich das, was wir ja jetzt gerade, also wir nicht,
aber was gerade der Boomer-Generation vorgeworfen wird, ihr habt drei Autos,
gehabt, ihr seid hundertmal in Urlaub gefahren und wir haben jetzt das Klimadesaster.
Sodass man ja auch sich fragen kann, ob so eine gewisse Regel auch sinnvoll
sein kann, wenn man mal nicht so eine vernünftige Regierung hat.
Der Advokatus Diamoli ist gut, aber die Schuldenbremse 2009 ist eine Reform
der Schuldenregel, die es vorher gab.
Wir haben die Idee der goldenen Regel, dass wir also ganz klar definieren,
was ist eine Investition.
Ich würde sagen, was der KTF abdeckt, ist eine Investition.
Also da geht es nur um investieren in, dass es in die richtige Richtung läuft
in diesem Sinne, im Sinne der Klimapolitik.
Und selbst wenn wir in Deutschland alles abschaffen, haben wir ja immer noch
die 60-3-Regel über den Maastrichter Vertrag.
Also wir sind ja eingebunden in eine Europäische Union, in der es auch Verschuldungsregeln gibt.
Es gibt also kluge und nicht so kluge Verschuldungsregeln. Und wir haben es
hier mit einer Hardcore Orthodoxen zu tun. Und das hören wir insbesondere.
Ich will auch da gar nicht widersprechen, sondern ich will auch damit auch nicht
die Schuldenbremse verteidigen.
Ich will nur sagen, dass also generell auch es ein Argument sein kann,
mal nicht Schulden aufzunehmen, weil diese Schulden für die nächste Generation da sind.
Also ich glaube, dass man jetzt nicht es als einen Freibrief verstehen soll,
dass man einfach sagt, egal was auch kommt, wir werfen Geld drauf.
Aber davon sind wir auch andererseits sehr, sehr weit entfernt.
Das hat ja Fratzscher vorhin kritisiert,
bei Corona und so, dass man es da einfach zu leicht gemacht hat.
Und ich würde auch nochmal hinzufügen wollen, du hast jetzt gerade schon Maastricht
angesprochen, es gibt ja noch was anderes, nämlich die Kapitalmärkte.
Haben die Kapitalmärkte quasi als nicht berufene Kontrollinstanz,
die aber selbstredend, wir haben das bei List Trust genau gemerkt in Großbritannien,
wütend werden, wenn da ein Staat irgendwelche Investitionen oder Ausgaben waren
es ja in diesem Sinne, nämlich Steuersenkungen für die Reichen tätigt,
die wenig sinnvoll sind für das Wirtschaftswachstum.
Und deshalb ist eigentlich, noch einmal hier zu sagen,
die Schuldenbremse ein Misstrauensvotum gegenüber den eigentlich von den Neoliberalen
so gut gefundenen Kapitalmärkten.
Denn diese hätten ja in neoliberaler Denkweise die Kontrollfunktion eigentlich,
die brauchen nicht nochmal eine Bremse, sondern die bremsen selbst.
Also wenn man mal bei dieser neoliberalen Denkweise bleibt, wir wissen auch,
man könnte ein bisschen unabhängiger von den Kapitalmärkten werden,
man kann anders souveräner über Geld verfügen als in einer Stadt,
aber bleiben wir mal dabei, dann kann man hier nochmal diese ganze Idiotie der
Schuldenbremse und der neoliberalen Ideologie erkennen.
So sehr wir es kritisiert haben, 2013, 14, 15, dass Griechenland immer mit einem
Abrutschen im Credit Rating, das ist dann nicht mehr AAA, sondern B-, oder was auch immer so,
muss man doch an sagen zugestehen, ja, aber damals war wenigstens eine ökonomische
Logik noch drin in der politischen Argumentation.
Richtig.
Jetzt nicht mehr.
Wir würden ja jetzt nicht, wenn Karlsruhe anders entschieden hätte oder man
das einfach überhören könnte, also wenn man diese Investitionen tätigen würde,
würde man ja nicht schlechter geratet werden. Also niemand kann davon ausgehen, dass die...
Ja umgedreht vielleicht.
Ganz genau. Das wäre jetzt darauf, das wäre eigentlich hier super drauf.
Wenn ihr die Schuldenbremse einhaltet, rutscht ihr ab auf B-.
Ich habe schon gesagt, die Kapitalmärkte sind nicht glücklich.
Jetzt wäre es schön, wenn Modi es mal reagiert.
Aber all die Logik gilt nicht, denn es gilt nicht nur 2009, sondern wenn wir
irgendwas begründen, dann gehen wir noch weiter zurück.
Ein letzter Gedanke, ist es
nicht so, dass jede Generation für sich versucht, das Beste zu erreichen?
Und dass wir das, was wir jetzt tun, auch jetzt finanzieren,
damit die nächste Generation darauf aufbauen kann?
Ja, also ich würde gerne nie auf die Idee, dass meine Kinder Miete zahlen müssen,
wenn sie im Elternhaus wohnen.
Und müssen wir diesen Gedanken nicht viel mehr stärken und sagen,
wir finanzieren die Probleme, die wir jetzt haben im Jetzt und das macht dann
auch die nächste Generation und wir geben keine weiteren Lasten weiter.
Das bedeutet, Sie würden die Schuldenbremse wieder genau so konzipieren,
wie sie 2009 in die Verfassung geschrieben ist.
Ja, ich fand das einen Glücksfall. Es hat ja auch eine breite Mehrheit gefunden, mit guten Gründen.
Wir haben aus den Erfahrungen der Staatsverschuldung, die wir davor erlebt haben,
gelernt und dann diese Schuldenbremse ins Grundgesetz geschrieben.
Sie merken, ich gebe Ihnen recht, ich bin ein Freund dieser Schuldenbremse Und
ich freue mich auch, dass das Bundesverfassungsgericht diese Schuldenbremse
nun gestärkt hat im Sinne der Mütter und Väter des Grundgesetzes.
Da kann man eigentlich nur noch Amen sagen. Es ist wie ein Gebet.
Und sehr schön ist doch hier nochmal diese Bemerkung, dass es doch auch nicht
angehe, dass wenn die Kinder noch zu Hause bei den Eltern wohnen,
sie dann Miete zahlen müssen.
Und wir sind aber in Wahrheit hier genau mit dem Phänomen zu tun haben,
das Stefan uns beschrieben hat, nämlich,
dass die Leute ihre Mieten zahlen müssen an die Vermieter, gerade weil diese
Austeritätspolitik vorherrscht.
Das ist der Originalismus, mit dem wir zu tun haben.
Gut, wir haben ja noch ganz viele Clips, aber wir hören nur ein paar.
Zum einen Klimafon, das ist ganz wichtig.
Ein Klimasondervermögen, was jetzt immer diskutiert wird im Sinne von die Regierung
ruft man Klimanotstand aus und so weiter. Ich rate davon ab.
Denn das wäre die ultimative Bad Bank. Wir könnten dann, wir kriegen dann eine
CDU-Regierung, die ins Amt kommt 2025 und sagt, Klimapolitik müssen wir nicht
machen, weil dafür haben wir das Sondervermögen.
Also man hat es dann einfach abgefrühstückt. Von daher hier, Clemens Fuest.
Wir brauchen also meines Erachtens tatsächlich, wenn wir Ausgabenkürzungspotenzial
überprüft haben, auch so etwas wie ein neues Sondervermögen.
Stellen Sie sich vor, jetzt geht der Wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds auch noch
den Bach runter. Dann ist das vollkommen klar.
Entweder wir kommen in große Schwierigkeiten, oder die Ampel wird gemeinsam
mit der Union ein neues Sondervermögen errichten nach dem Vorbild der Bundeswehr.
Ich sehe einfach keinen anderen Weg. Aber das setzt voraus, dass man grundlegend
neu darüber nachdenkt, wie man die Wirtschaft in der Tat in diesem Land auf
die Transformation vorbereitet.
No, no, no, no, no. Da müssen wir immer wieder sprechen. Bei Hüther auch.
Und insofern gibt es da keine einfache Antwort für das praktische politische Handeln.
Aus der Sicht der Sachlage würde ich sagen, die einfachste Lösung wäre,
den Klima- und Transformationsfonds Analog Bundeswehr Sondervermögen ins Grundgesetz zu packen.
Man kann man auch gut argumentieren, denn letztlich gibt es dazu auch ein Verfassungsgerichtsurteil,
dass er die Schärfung des Klimaschutzgesetzes 2021 zur Folge hatte und sagen,
das ist eine Ü-Generationen-Aufgabe,
das nehmen wir aus der Schuldenbremse raus, da wird dies und das für definiert.
Aber setzt die Zustimmung der Union voraus.
Halt ich für ganz gefährlich. Also wirklich ein ganz großes Problem, wenn das so käme.
Du glaubst, dass dann eigentlich keine Bundesklimapolitik mehr gemacht werden
muss, weil das da geparkt ist?
Wenn die Ampel jetzt den Vorschlag macht, Klimafonds und die Union sagt jetzt
noch zu, während die Ampel regiert, dann beerdigt die Ampel die Klimapolitik.
Dann wird auf Jahre hin das überhaupt nicht mehr diskutierbar sein,
weil es einfach heißt, ist doch im Grundgesetz festgeschrieben.
Und wir können nicht immer alles ins Grundgesetz schreiben, weil wir dann wieder
feststellen, ach so, 2027 zum Beispiel, ach so, das ist jetzt die Lage,
mit der wir es zu tun haben.
Hätten wir das mal 2023 gewusst.
Wir haben gar nicht gedacht, dass es im Oktober schneiden kann,
irgendwas wird dann kommen.
Absolut, genau. Also es ging drunter und drüber. Dass man dann,
wenn man jetzt schon nicht weiß, was ist eigentlich eine konsumtive und was
ist eine investierende Ausgabe, dass man dann erst recht durcheinander kommt.
Und ist das eigentlich noch Klimaschutz oder schon Klimaanpassung?
Also irgendwer will einen Damm bauen gegen irgendwas. Das ist Klimapolitik.
Das kommt mal mit in den Vorsorge.
Also haben wir dann plötzlich riesenhohe Kosten, Nothilfesachen.
Das Ahrtal-Hochwasser passiert.
Und dann heißt es, der hat mit Klimapolitik zu tun. Das ist Klimawandel,
was wir da gesehen haben. Kommt in den KTF.
Und dann ist er leer gelaufen irgendwann. Und dann war es das aber auch.
Also das halte ich für nicht. Außer, ein Vorschlag, Sydecom umreißt den mal.
Außer wir schreiben wirklich echte hohe Zahlen rein.
Also, erst mal, es geht ja nicht nur um diese 60 Milliarden,
die müssen wir irgendwo zusammenkratzen. Tatsächlich geht's vielleicht um mehr.
Und wenn man mal ehrlich ist, auch schon, als diese 60 Milliarden noch da waren
und nicht gesperrt waren, hatten wir im Prinzip das Problem,
dass der ganze Bereich Investitionen, Zukunftsausgaben, gerade im Hinblick auf
Klimatransformation dramatisch unterfinanziert war.
Es gibt Studien, die sagen, dass wir bis 2030, wenn wir realistischerweise die
Klimaziele erreichen wollen und dabei den Wohlstand in diesem Land erhalten
wollen, dass wir mehr Investitionen in der Größenordnung von weit über einer
Billion Euro bis 2030 brauchen.
Weit über einer Billion bis 2030. Das hieße, wenn Sondervermögen,
dann 1,5 Billionen bis 2030.
Also jedes Jahr mehr als 150 Milliarden.
Ja.
Wenn sie das ins Grundgesetz schreiben, bin ich zufrieden. Darunter würde ich
es nicht machen. Also es ist gefährlich.
Und davon wird knapp die Hälfte auch
beim Staat auflaufen. Für Infrastrukturinvestitionen, für Förderprogramme.
Also die Hälfte beim Staat, sagen wir mal mit Puffer gerundet,
100 Milliarden im Jahr für 13 Jahre ins Grundgesetz, oder bis 2030,
also 17 Jahre ins Grundgesetz schreiben.
1,7 Billionen Euro. Aber ich sage, das ist wirklich gut.
Das heißt, das Problem ist wesentlich größer. Und diese 60 Milliarden haben
überhaupt nicht ausgereicht, um realistischerweise die Klimaziele zu erreichen.
Und die fallen jetzt auch noch weg. Das heißt, wenn wir ehrlich sind,
müssen wir sagen, dass wir dieses grundsätzliche große Problem einfach nicht
dadurch gelöst bekommen, indem wir jetzt sagen, wir kürzen ein bisschen was
beim Bürgergeld, bei der Kindergrundsicherung oder wo auch immer.
Dadurch haben wir im Prinzip bloß erreicht, dass diese ganze Transformation
dann auch noch an soziale Akzeptanz verliert.
Wir müssen eine langfristige und nachhaltige Finanzierung für diese große Investitionsagenda
auch finden und das tut mir leid, das geht nicht, wenn wir nicht auch über Kreditaufnahmen
und über vernünftige rechtlich saubere Formen von Sondervermögen und letztendlich
über die Schuldenbremse reden.
Ja, das finde ich eine sehr gute Idee, das so zu argumentieren und ich würde
dir aber auch zustimmen, dass ich es für falsch halte, wenn man alles in die
Verfassung schreiben will.
Alexander Thiele warnte davor schon vor Jahren, dass das so Usus geworden ist,
wann immer man irgendeine halbe gute Idee hat, sagt man, das müssen wir unbedingt
mal in die Verfassung schreiben.
Nein, sagt er, das muss immer wieder demokratisch ausgehandelt werden und da
muss nicht irgendwas immer fixiert werden. So jetzt haben wir noch gerade die
Möglichkeit, wir schreiben es schnell rein.
Das ist so ein Spiel unter den Parteien geworden. Jetzt gerade die Gelegenheit
nutzen, das Momentum ergreifen und dann ist es so.
Das ist völliger Unsinn und das zeigt eigentlich, dass man dem demokratischen
Prozess wahnsinnig misstraut.
Absolut. Wo Geld herholen? Sozialstaat zusammenkürzen. Wir haben es gehört,
Lindner, wir brauchen jetzt strukturelle Entscheidungen.
Wir müssen irgendwie, und man denkt sich so, okay, wenn die CDU jetzt die Kindergrundsicherung
nennt, also ein Gesetz, das in zwei Jahren kommt und dann noch nur zwei Milliarden
bringt, wie käme man dann auf dieses ganze Zeug?
Ah ja, wir nehmen noch ein bisschen Bürgergeld dazu und so weiter.
Aber beim Bürgergeld 30 Milliarden, da hast du auch schon zur Hälfte Aufstockerei.
Also das sind eigentlich Subventionen an die Unternehmen, damit sie nicht so
viel Lohn zahlen müssen.
Der Sozialstaat ist doch relativ klein, wenn man es sich mal anschaut.
Also 120 Milliarden in die Rente, 60 Milliarden oder so für Panzer.
Das ist schon der halbe Haushalt.
Also da bleibt gar nicht viel übrig. Wir hatten das ja gesehen,
als diese Kindergeld-Diskussion war, sollten auch Leute, die mehr als 150.000,
Haushaltseinkommen im Jahr ist, ein Kindergeld kassieren. Und dann war ganz schnell, nee, nee.
Und dann plötzlich die größte Petition aller Zeiten. Also die Leute wehren sich dann auch.
Und man ist aber relativ schnell bei den Ausgaben des Bundesheids bei diesen
Leuten, also die dann sofort Alarm machen und so.
Aber die FDP will sich noch nicht davon abbringen lassen, einfach die Kleckerbeiträge
bei denen, die sich nicht wehren können, zusammen zu kratzen.
Nochmal die Frage, dieses Sparen und Kürzen und dann wieder noch bei Sozialprojekten,
ist das wirklich der richtige Weg, mit dem man dieses Problem in dieser Dimension
jetzt in den Griff bekommt?
Und wir hören hier nicht Opa Enno, Vertreter der alten Republik,
dessen Enkel schon seit 30 Jahren nicht mehr in der Schule sind,
sondern diesen Reinhard Hauben, den wirtschaftspolitischen Sprecher der FDP-Fraktion.
Ja, Frau Zerberg, diese Argumentationen erinnern mich immer daran,
wenn jemand zum Arzt kommt und der Arzt sagt, hören Sie doch mit dem Rauchen auf.
Und er sagt, am ersten Tag habe ich noch nichts gemerkt, das bringt doch nichts.
Also Wunder der Addition.
Natürlich müssen wir Wunder der Addition, der Einzelmaßnahmen prüfen und das
Geld, ich nenne das mal Zusammenkratzen.
Wir reden natürlich auch für den Haushalt nicht von 60 Milliarden,
sondern nur von etwa 20 Milliarden.
Bei einem Gesamthaushalt von ungefähr 450 Milliarden Euro bin ich der Meinung,
dass man durchaus Möglichkeiten finden könnte,
einen größeren Teilbetrag aus dem vorhandenen Haushalt des Bundes herausziehen zu können.
Ja, geht nur bei der Rente. Also es gibt keine anderen so großen Posten,
die man da nehmen könnte.
Vor allem wenn sie zum Arzt gehen und so weiter, dass er ausgerechnet ein Beispiel,
wo Vorsorge so eine immense Rolle spielt, um die Kosten zu senken,
wählt, um dann beim Sozialstaat, also Bildung,
Erwerbspersonenpotenzial für die aktuelle Rentnergeneration und so weiter.
Das verstehe ich einfach nicht.
Also das ist Wunder der Addition, aber er kann selber eins plus eins nicht zusammenzählen
und einfach sich mal eingestehen, dass das zwei ist.
Wir können natürlich einfach fleißiger sein.
Also erlauben Sie mir in dem Zusammenhang eine Bemerkung.
Ich glaube nicht, dass wir die Probleme der Zukunft dadurch lösen,
dass wir mehr Schulden machen und weniger arbeiten, sondern vielleicht wäre es ja umgekehrt besser.
Wir würden weniger Schulden machen und mehr arbeiten.
Ich glaube, so kommt man eher aus einer Krise raus. Also manche Debatten sind
vielleicht auch aktuell nicht angemessen.
Ja, wir haben Probleme, Aber die werden wir nur dadurch lösen,
dass wir entweder einen schuldengerechten Haushalt nach den bestehenden Regeln
aufstellen und ansonsten müssen wir meiner Meinung nach in Deutschland eine
Debatte darüber führen,
wie wir durch größeren Fleiß wieder Spielräume erlangen.
Größerer Fleiß, das ist die Lösung. Aber hier haben wir ja noch ein Argument
dann geliefert bekommen, warum so viele Liberale und Konservative an der Schuldenbremse
hängen, weil man genau solche Diskurse damit verbinden kann.
Das kombiniert, ja.
Wenn man erst einmal Geld sparen muss, dann werden sich doch alle mal wieder
dran gewöhnen, dass auch 45 Stunden die Woche arbeiten eigentlich großen Spaß machen kann.
Ja, wir hören uns nicht an wie Rainer Holznagel vom Bund der Steuerzahler sagt,
wir können überall kürzen, das sind wir schon immer dafür. Jetzt wacht auch die CDU langsam auf.
CDU sitzt dann in Form von Rainer Hasselhoff bei Anne Will und sagt,
wir müssen den Sozialstaat Zitat durchforsten um die Zitat Sahnehäubchen.
Rauszunehmen. Ja, wir hören das mal bei Christian Lindner da im Interview der Woche.
Ich halte es für möglich, dass wir die Ziele, die wir uns gesetzt haben und
die Vorhaben, die gewünscht werden, dass wir die tatsächlich finanziell abbilden bis 2027.
Um den Zeitraum geht es ja. Das halte ich für möglich.
Das setzt aber voraus, dass wir die Kraft finden, unsere Etats der nächsten
Jahre anders zu konzipieren.
Kurz gesagt, wer für diese Investitionsvorhaben, wer dafür Mittel gewinnen will,
wer Finanzhilfen zahlen will an Industrieunternehmen,
der muss auf der anderen Seite mitwirken dabei, andere Aufgaben zu reduzieren.
Die Treffsicherheit unseres Staates zu erhöhen, die Effektivität der Staatsausgaben
zu verbessern, sodass man mit weniger Geld an anderer Stelle trotzdem wirksamer
arbeiten kann. Zum Beispiel?
Zum Beispiel haben wir wachsende Sozialausgaben.
Da wäre ich gar nicht drauf gekommen, dass er das als Erstes nennt.
Ich muss mich daran erinnern, in seiner Bemerkenswertenschlichtheit hatte auch
Micky Beisenherz vor Jahren getwittert, als es diese Lastenraddiskussion gab.
Und es da so eine Förderung geben sollte, was von den Grünen vorgeschlagen wurde.
Er will nicht, dass er dort als privilegiert, also der schon gut verdient,
dann noch ein Lastenrad gefördert bekommt, das sei falsch.
Und dann denkt man so, ja, hast du mal darüber nachgedacht, wo alle Leute,
die mehr Geld verdienen,
immer mehr Steuergeschenke gemacht bekommen in Form von allen möglichen Steuererleichterungen,
Dass man einfach so sehen kann, dass die Steuersparnisse zunehmen mit steigendem Einkommen.
Dass mit Selbstständigkeit Formen der Absetzung möglich sind von irgendwelchen
Artikeln, an die normale Leute überhaupt nicht denken können.
Da müssen wir gar nicht nur über die Dienstwagenprivilegien und so ein Kram
sprechen, sondern da gibt es tausende Möglichkeiten. Auch möchte ich gar nicht
wissen, wie viele Leute hier in Frankfurt irgendwelche Wohnungen doch als Büro
und weiß ich nicht was, ja.
Also da gibt es alle denkbaren Modelle für.
Das heißt, die Leute, die von diesen enormen Steuererleichterungen profitieren,
die sind diejenigen, die Sozialabgaben bekommen.
Also wir reden bei Sozialabgaben immer jetzt nur über die Leute,
die 500 oder 800 Euro im Monat bekommen vom Staat.
Aber das sind eigentlich Sozialabgaben, wenn ich plötzlich noch meinen Zweitwagen
als Dienstwagen anmelden kann und wenn ich was weiß ich alles absetzen kann.
Das sind Sozialabgaben, die der Staat den Reichen zur Verfügung stellt und über
die könnte man natürlich mal diskutieren.
Das Bürgergeld ist verfassungs...
Rechtlich über ein Urteil abgesichert. Also vom Bürgergeld können sie eh nicht abholen.
Das ist ja Existenzminimum.
Genau. Und deswegen würde ich auch sagen, lasst die CDU mal den Sozialstaat kürzen.
Weil dann haben wir nämlich genau das, dass dann die Leute so,
ihr Bescheid für den Dienstwagen und so weiter geht doch nicht.
Mhm.
So. Weißt du? Und dann geht nämlich die, ihr Kindergeld wird jetzt doch nicht ausgezahlt.
Ja.
So. Das Lastenrad wird jetzt doch nicht finanziert. Weil klar,
Micky Beisensatz würde sich sein Lastenrad entweder kaufen oder nicht.
Aber wenn er es kauft und es gibt die, dann nimmt er die halt noch mit.
Und dann fällt das einfach raus. Das ändert seinen Lebenswandel ja gar nicht.
Ja und das hat er dann getwittert. Irgendwie beim Lastenrad war es ihm dann ein Dorn im Auge.
So als sei das jetzt so ganz verrückt sowas einzufordern.
Dann würde ich sagen, naja beim Lastenfahrrad geht es ja dann noch um so eine
Mobilitätswende, die dann mit hergebracht werden soll.
Aber sonst wissen wir ja, dass man, wenn man viel verdient, alles umweltschädliche
absetzen kann, was geht.
Jetzt hören wir mal in vier Clips, wie die Ökonomen darüber reden,
wie die den Sozialstaat zusammenkürzen wollen. Wir fangen an bei Hüther.
Wie kommen wir raus aus dieser Kiste? Tja, das ist die Frage,
ob die Größe der Herausforderung von allen gleichermaßen erkannt wird.
Wer glaubt, er kann das mit ein paar Sozialausgabenkürzungen hinbekommen,
der wird nicht bereit sein zu einer staatspolitischen Lösung.
Und wenn man aber erkennt, dass es hier eigentlich am Ende um das Risiko einer Staatskrise geht.
Ich meine, wenn wir in weitem Maße nicht handlungsfähig sind,
dann ist das eine Krise des Staates und der Staatlichkeit.
Wenn der Verteidigungsminister nach Kiew fährt und solche Zusagen macht,
ist das Ausdruck unserer internationalen Verantwortung.
Wenn wir das Geld aber gar nicht haben, nicht ausreichen können,
dann stehen wir ja vor Fragen, wir machen uns ja auch international in einer Weise lächerlich.
Bin ich also bereit, diese Dimension zu erkennen? Dann meine ich,
müsste es eine auch gesamtstaatliche Perspektive geben, Also eine staatspolitische
geben und das muss Regierung und Opposition zusammenführen.
Dann muss man nach richtigen Lösungen suchen.
Kürzungen gibt's einfach faktisch nicht, weil das, wo die CDU glaubt,
das tut ja niemandem weh, weil sich da keiner beschwert. Das sind so geringe Gelder.
Spielt keine Rolle. Südekom.
Wenn man jetzt ernsthaft auf die Idee kommen würde, jetzt als Konsequenz aus
dem Verfassungsgerichtsurteil jetzt praktisch den Sozialstaat aufzuschnüren
und jetzt überall kleine Beträge zusammenzukratzen, dann wird das eine Katastrophe
werden und wird auch kurzfristig keine Lösung bringen.
Ich glaube, wir müssen mal grundsätzlich unterscheiden zwischen konsumtiven
und investiven Staatsausgaben.
Was eben der KTF ist, langfristige Investitionen für Klimaschutz, für neue Technologien.
Das sind also Dinge, die werden heute gemacht. Die werden sich aber auch in
den nächsten 10, 20, 30 Jahren auszahlen.
Dann kommen die Rendite für diese Investitionen.
Was anderes sind eben Sozialstaatsausgaben im Hier und Jetzt.
Und da würde ich auch sagen, ist ist es vollkommen richtig, dass all das durch
aktuelle Steuereinnahmen gedeckt sein muss.
Also da muss die Schuldenbremse absolut gelten, wenn es um konsumtive Staatsausgaben
und Transferzahlungen usw. geht.
Aber bei Investitionen, da ist eine völlig andere Logik. Warum sollen Dinge,
die für die nächsten 30 bis 50 Jahre Rediten erwirtschaften,
warum sollen die zu 100 Prozent aus den Steuereinnahmen des Jahres 2023 bezahlt werden?
So agiert kein Unternehmen. Das macht ökonomisch keinen Sinn. Und deswegen...
Aus meiner Sicht die nachhaltige Lösung für all das, dass man eben sagt,
Investitionen dürfen selbstverständlich gewietfinanziert werden und wir müssen
die Schuldenbremse in diese Richtung eben auch reformieren.
Und bei den konsumtiven Staatsausgaben, den Transferzahlungen,
da gilt weiterhin die Schuldenbremse und wahrscheinlich auch in der verschärften
Form jetzt nach dem Urteil des Verfassungsgerichts.
Weil, wenn wir in Deutschland nicht so hohe Mietzahlungen hätten,
hätten wir ganz schön viele Probleme nicht.
Wie zum Beispiel Binnennachfrage nach allem möglichen innerstädtisches Leben und so weiter.
Wenn im Bundeshaushalt nicht 120 Milliarden für die Rente drinnen stünden,
weil die Unternehmen vergessen hatten, ach so, wir haben auch eine gesellschaftliche
Verantwortung, nicht nur für die Belegschaft jetzt, sondern dann auch im Rentenalter.
Wir führen also mehr an die Sozialkassen ab.
Hätten wir auch kein Problem. Dann hätten wir jedes Jahr 100 Milliarden mehr,
die wir einfach ohne irgendeine Schuldenbremse-Diskussion ausgeben könnten.
Wenn man dann aber doch an den Sozialstaat rangeht, also wenn man einfach das
Gesamtgefüge ist zertrümmert, wie wir vorhin besprochen haben und dann will
man es einfach nur über Sozialkürzung machen.
Dann führt das, wie Südenkomm sagt, in die Katastrophe.
Hüther hat nochmal ein schöneres Bild.
Und das muss ich sagen, finde ich so ein bisschen seltsam in einigen auch Kommentaren,
wenn du einige, die rechtgläubigen ordnungspolitischen Blätter dieses Landes
mal liest, dann steht dann so, ja jetzt ist mal endlich hier auch Zeitenwende.
Als hätten einige darauf gewartet, dass jetzt mal das große Messer rausgeholt
wird, hier wird das Staatshaushalt zurecht geschnitten.
Aber in der Situation sind wir doch nicht.
Wir können ja nicht jetzt sagen, es ist schön, es ist, aber am lebenden Objekt
schneide ich dem jetzt mal die halbe Leber raus, ein Viertel der Niere und das
wird schon dann trotzdem, reicht ja auch mit den anderen.
Also das ist, finde ich, so eine Perspektive, die mich ehrlich gesagt, die mich sehr sorgt.
Ja. Zustimmung.
Sehr gut. Und das war noch der Arbeitgeber Nahe. Jetzt sind wir bei Marcel Fratscher.
Er dreht es so ein bisschen um. Er kriegt für alle wieder so diese Frage,
ja, wie sind mit den Kürzungen und so weiter und so fort.
Er hat ja vorhin schon angemerkt, das Problem ist, wir haben zu viel Geld ausgegeben.
Wenn man feststellt, man macht bei einer Corona Notlage irgendwie 60 Milliarden
über dem Bedarf, dann muss man das halt regulär wieder verrechnen und dann hat
man noch Spielräume für anderes und so weiter.
Lass mich gerade mal eine Anmerkung machen. Wir haben jetzt hier viele Stimmen
gehört, die sich vernünftig äußern.
Das ist nicht repräsentativ für den medialen Diskurs.
Stefan hat hier die Rosinen uns rausgepickt und mitgebracht.
Ich habe ganz andere Clips gesehen.
Schlimmstes, gerade in diesen schon genannten Talkshows.
Um die Clips zusammenzustellen, ich habe immer alles in einer Datei,
waren 35 Stunden Rohmaterial.
Ja, ja.
Und wir hören jetzt sozusagen die 17 Minuten daraus.
Ja.
Aber die lohnen sich, also hier Marcel Fratscher. Nochmal, der verweist auf.
Ich will ja nur sagen, wie marginal diese Position dann im Diskurs ist.
Ja. Das Problem ist nicht zu wenig Geld, das Problem ist zu viel Geld.
Und das, was ich mit großer Sorge sehe, ist, dass jetzt so getan wird,
als wäre die Lösung für die Finanzierungsprobleme darin, dass man Menschen mit
wenig, ob es jetzt ein Bürgergeld ist, ob es Rentnerinnen und Rentner ist,
ob es Kinder sind, die in Armut leben, dass das die Lösung ist.
Es ist nicht die Lösung, es wird nicht die Lösung sein. Könnte es ein Baustein sein?
Beim Bürgergeld nein. Da hat Klaas Klüngwald
zu Recht die Entscheidung vom Bundesverfassungsgericht angesprochen.
Es ist Aufgabe des Staates, das sozioökonomische Existenzminimum zu gewährleisten.
Da hat auch die CDU bei der Berechnung des Schlüssels zugestimmt.
Da gibt es nichts dran zu rütteln.
Der größte Posten im Sozialbereich ist die Rente. Er macht ein Viertel des Bundeshaushalts aus.
Aber dann sagen Sie bitte den Rentnerinnen und Rentnern jetzt,
ihr kriegt noch weniger.
Sagen Sie das mal den Rentnern. Herr Merz, Herr Lindner, Herr Lars Feld.
Wir sehen jetzt schon, die Altersarmut steigt massiv und wird zunehmend in den kommenden Jahren.
Und das als Signal, wir kürzen jetzt die Zuschüsse bei der Rente,
hätte eben das als Resultat, dass die soziale Schieflage nochmal zunimmt.
Also ich glaube das größte Potenzial liegt nicht bei den Sozialausgaben,
es liegt darin, dass man Privilegien im Steuersystem abschafft.
Bei der Erbschaftssteuer, bei Besteuerung von Immobilien, vor allem vom Immobiliengewinn,
in vielen anderen Bereichen, bei der Mehrwertsteuer, dort ist extrem viel Potenzial.
Ohne Steuererhöhung geht es nicht um Steuererhöhung, sondern um Steuergerechtigkeit.
Und das wäre auch aus ökonomischer Sicht gut und richtig, weil man damit letztlich
mehr Wettbewerb schafft. Ich glaube, da liegt das wirklich große Potenzial.
So, wenn man sich diese Aufschlüsselung ansieht, also HZG-Betrug und daneben
kennen wir ja alle dieses Bild, Steuervermeidung, also das ist 100 Milliarden
gegen eine Viertel oder so.
Also wir haben 100 Milliarden, die uns einfach verloren gehen,
dadurch, dass es so Steuerschlupflöcher und so weiter gibt.
Wir haben ja vorhin vom Gregor Kirchhoff gehört, das ist eigentlich nicht so
ganz korrekt, wenn man ein Gesetz schon so schreibt, dass genug Umgehungsmöglichkeiten
da sind, ist verfassungswidrig. Das haben wir im Steuerrecht überall.
Ja, so. Also wir haben da einfach 100 Milliarden, die könnte man ja mal schöpfen, heben.
Da könnte man Verschuldung vermeiden und muss auch nicht an die Schuldenbremse ran.
Der einzige Posten im Bundeshaushalt, der groß genug ist, um überhaupt einen
Unterschied zu machen, sind die Renten.
Die Diskussion muss man dann führen. Ich habe gehört, Lars Feld wartet nur darauf,
die Diskussion endlich auf den Tisch zu legen.
Also an die Regelrente ranzugehen, halte ich für Wahnsinn.
Ich glaube auch, er wird vorher gebremst, weil die alten Republikkräfte bekannt
sind. Ja, das sind die Wähler.
Das heißt, ich habe ausgeschlossen.
Und ja, ansonsten, diese Unternehmen warten auf das Geld und die Bescheide,
wenn sie schon geschrieben sind, sind verpflichtend.
Deutschland muss das dann zahlen.
Und dann müssen sie sich irgendwie verfassungskonform refinanzieren,
wie auch immer. Ein Clip zum Abschluss.
Die FDP und die Steuererhöhung, das ist ja wirklich, also wenn der Fratsche
jetzt sagt, man kann ja einfach mal ohne Steuererhöhung, sondern einfach nur
durch einhaltende Regeln und das Vermeiden der Steuervermeidung 100 Milliarden auftreiben.
Die FDP ist da so ein bisschen anderer Meinung.
Oder braucht man sowieso viel länger. Also man kann Steuern erhöhen,
besser Verdienende zum Beispiel besteuern.
Ja Frau Zerweyert, das kann man natürlich machen. Es stellt sich nur die Frage,
im internationalen Vergleich, dann wird Deutschland gerade für die,
die besonders erfolgreich sind, noch unattraktiver.
Und wir bekommen das Problem, dass sie dann vielleicht sagen,
na in anderen Ländern ist es auch ganz hübsch.
Ja, in anderen Ländern ist es auch ganz hübsch.
Ich bin gespannt, in welchen Ländern dann?
Ja, das würde ich auch gerne mal wissen. Was glauben die denn?
Niederlande mit Gerd Wilders oder was strebt man dann an?
Genau, also man hat jetzt so 13 Häuser hier in Deutschland.
Und dann heißt es plötzlich, ne, wenn du die vererbst, muss aus deinem Barvermögen
100 Millionen gezahlt werden.
Sagen die dann, ich verkaufe alles, ich hau hier ab, ich wohne jetzt in Dubai bei 50 Grad im Sommer.
Das sagt doch keiner. Das macht doch niemand. Das ist doch bescheuert.
Ja, das waren so ein paar Influencer, aber das war es dann auch.
Ja, aber auch nur für ein Jahr.
Ja, da kommen die immer alle wieder zurück.
Also in der Hinsicht, das ist einfach alles Banane, was wir hier beobachten.
Aber ich will nochmal drauf Wert legen.
Das Problem ist größer als wir glauben. Und es hat auch nicht nur mit,
ach, ein Haushalt funktioniert anders als und so weiter, sondern jetzt grundsätzlich,
es geht um, wie finanzieren wir unseren Staat allgemein und lass die Finger
vom Grundgesetz. keine Klimafonds im Grundgesetz.
Außer 100 Milliarden im Jahr für die nächsten 17 Jahre.
Dann ja, aber darunter nicht.
Sondern entweder Schuldenbremse neu regeln, so dass Verschuldung möglich ist.
Oder, wäre noch besser, diese 100 Milliarden der Superreichen und Reichen und so weiter eintreiben.
Dazu müssen nicht mal Gesetze geändert werden. Es würde reichen,
den Finanz- und Ermittlungsbehörden und so weiter ein bisschen mehr Geld zu geben.
Wir Wir haben alle noch im Ohr, wie es damals hieß, allein die Ankündigung,
es gibt da eine Steuer-CD, die Deutschland kaufen könnte, es war das größte
Rendite-Geschäft ever, was Deutschland gemacht hat.
Diese eine CD, da wurde für drei Millionen gekauft oder so und man hat 30 Milliarden
Steuern eingenommen. Also da liegen die Potenziale.
Aber da sieht man ja auch eher das Gegenteil.
Die Finanzämter sind glaube ich hinter irgendwelchen Leuten her,
bei denen sie nicht sicher sind, ob die 15 Euro Quittung falsch verrechnet haben.
Das ist ja das Arbeitszimmer wirklich so groß.
Aber das steckt nicht wieder bei den anderen.
Wir kommen jetzt zu einem ganz großen Thema. Ich will es mal Rahmen mit Kapitalismus,
Ungleichheit, Arbeitskämpfe.
Wie geht es eigentlich jungen Menschen ökonomisch in Deutschland und was sagt die Philosophie dazu?
Und ja, wir beginnen jetzt mit Philosophie und ja, wir machen uns jetzt auch
ausführlich lustig über unseren, vor allem deinen Lieblingsphilosophen Markus Gabriel.
Yeah!
Ich habe schon mit Patrick Breitenbach, Huma Nagafi und Sebastian Thieme im
Critical Podcast über einen längeren Vortrag von Markus Gabriel in Luzern diskutiert.
Und es war nun so, dass in diesem Monat Markus Gabriel auch in der Sendung von
Gerd Skobel bei 3SAT zu Gast war.
Und das Thema war ethischer Kapitalismus. Zu Gast waren außerdem Fratscher,
den wir eben schon gehört haben, und Jens Beckert, ein Soziologe,
der vielleicht manchen auch vertraut ist.
Und es geht mir jetzt aber nicht darum, dass wir uns nur über Markus Gabriel
lustig machen, sondern ich will schon anhand dieser Äußerungen aufzeigen.
Das vielleicht nicht nur das Problem bei Markus Gabriel liegt,
sondern dass im Ganzen die Diskussion zum Kapitalismus ganz viel ausgeblendet hat.
Und was da ausgeblendet wurde, dazu kommen wir dann danach. Aber das erstmal so als Einstieg.
Wir hören jetzt Markus Gabriel, der ganz begeistert vom Kapitalismus ist.
Denn das ermöglicht uns allen Wohlstand, die freien Verträge,
die bewirken so viel z.B.
Auch die Abschaffung der Sklaverei.
Freie Gestaltung von Verträgen. Zwar ist es sicher so, dass Arbeitsverhältnisse
mit Machtungleichheiten einhergehen.
Aber ich würde die These wagen, dass ohne den Kapitalismus die Überwindung der
Sklaverei, also eine massive Form von moralischem Fortschritt,
nicht möglich gewesen wäre.
Moralischer Fortschritt in der Moderne, Gleichstellung, Themen,
die wir heute diskutieren, oder jetzt eben auch der Klimaschutz,
finden aus meiner Sicht spezifisch unter kapitalistischen Bedingungen statt.
Und das würde ich auch auf der positiven Seite dieses ambivalenten,
Janus-gesichtigen Systems verbuchen.
Was er uns hier sagen will, ist, der Kapitalismus bringt moralischen Fortschritt.
Was er nicht sagt, ist, der Kapitalismus will Profit machen.
Und dann gibt es auch einen moralischen Fortschritt und manchmal kommt das überein
und es ist tatsächlich so,
dass man im modernen Kapitalismus keine Sklaverei wie damals mehr brauchte,
weil die Leute heute aus anderen Gründen ihre Arbeitskraft verkaufen müssen
und dann ist das im Grunde genommen auch profitabler,
das so zu machen, wie es jetzt gekommen ist.
Er koppelt aber hier gleich das System Moral mit dem System Kapitalismus und
ich sehe schon an deinem Gesicht, dass du sehr begeistert bist.
Der Kapitalismus. Also er sagt ja, und ich will es nur an einem Punkt,
ich lasse mich nicht weiter trickern gleich.
Na doch, bestimmt.
Im Kapitalismus oder während kapitalistisch gehandelt wird oder während Geld
eine Rolle spielt, während Profitlogik umgesetzt wird, gibt es noch andere Kalküle. Stimmt.
Das ist, ich meine, die Sklaverei wurde abgeschafft.
Ich habe das auch mit Humann beschrieben, nachdem Armin Nasehi auch mit so einer
Argumentation kam, dass es durchaus moralische Fortschritte während Kapitalismus
gibt, weil wir haben ja zum Beispiel die Sklaverei abgeschafft.
Die Sklaverei wurde abgeschafft, nachdem es lukrativer war, nicht die Gesamtverantwortung
für Menschen zu übernehmen, sondern zu sagen, hier, du kriegst ein Entgelt,
ich bin frei von meiner Schuld, du gehst bitte selber zum Arzt.
Lass dich von deiner Ehefrau dahin bringen und tüchtig halten,
ist nicht mehr meine Aufgabe.
Also der Kapitalismus hat nicht die Sklaverei abgeschafft, das ist völlig Banane,
sowas überhaupt nur so in der Form zu sagen.
Sondern während kapitalistisch gehandelt wurde, ja wurde halt auch eine,
wie wir heute retrospektiv sagen, moralische Entscheidung getroffen.
Die Sklaverei insgesamt wurde nach marktwirtschaftlichen Kalkülen,
die dem Profit unterliegen, aussortiert.
Dass es dann in den Randbereichen noch zu erfolgreichen moralisch geführten
Kämpfen gab, um zu sagen.
Diesen Restsklaverei, die wir
da sehen, diese Phänomene treiben wir jetzt auch noch aus. Schön und gut.
Du hast es jetzt gerade schon so wunderbar gesagt, es war viel profitabler,
es so zu gestalten, als der klassischen Sklaverei. Ist bis heute so.
Was jetzt hier aber versucht wird, ist zu sagen, also profitabel zu agieren,
bedeutet moralisch zu agieren und zugleich macht der den meisten Profit,
der besonders moralisch agiert. Das ist die Grundannahme von Markus Gabriel.
Wir hören mal weiter.
Wenn wir Produktivität steigern wollen, ist es wichtig, dass wir Bedingungen
nicht entfremdeter Arbeit, auch am Arbeitsplatz, monetär messbaren Arbeitsplatz erzeugen.
Wir wissen alle, dass wir kreativer sind, wenn wir gewisse Freiheitsgrade haben.
Ich würde behaupten, je höher man die Freiheitsgrade in einem Unternehmen setzt,
dazu kann die 4-Tage-Woche gehören,
Gleitarbeitszeit und so weiter. Homeoffice und so weiter. Ich würde behaupten,
dass wir damit die Produktivität erhöhen.
Das ist Teil der Erklärung, warum wir diese Pandemie ökonomisch überhaupt überstanden haben.
Die Idee ist auch hier, wenn man moralisch handelt und sagt,
die Unternehmen gewähren mehr Freiheiten den Angestellten, dann steigt der Profit.
Jetzt fallen uns Branchen ein, bei denen flexible Arbeitszeiten,
Homeoffice, reduzierte Arbeitszeiten tatsächlich etwas bringen können und die
Produktivität steigern.
In der Werbebranche ist das meinetwegen möglich. Aber überlegen wir mal,
auf welche Arbeiten wir zurückgreifen, beziehungsweise wo wir Begegnungen mit
Arbeitskräften haben, bei den Produkten, die wir kaufen, in die Geschäfte,
die wir gehen, Restaurants, die wir essen.
Gilt das da auch, dass die produktiver sind, wenn die 30 Stunden statt 40 Stunden
arbeiten? Und die Antwort ist natürlich nein.
Und hier zeigt sich aber nicht der Punkt, dass man sagt, deswegen darf es keine
Arbeitsverkürzung geben, sondern hier zeigt sich nur, deswegen ist der Kampf
um Arbeitszeitverkürzung tatsächlich ein Kampf und nicht eine Frage von irgendeiner Einsicht.
Wenn die Müllabfuhr in Frankfurt beschließt, dass die Leute jetzt nur noch 28
Stunden arbeiten müssen, dann brauchen die dringend mehr Leute.
Weil die werden nicht, weil sie einen Tag weniger arbeiten müssen,
plötzlich so produktiv werden, dass sie das, was sie vorher an fünf Tagen gemacht
haben, jetzt an vier Tagen können.
Das heißt, dieses Produktivitätsargument, das da immer wieder gebracht wird,
gilt nur für wenige Bereiche.
Das gilt vielleicht für ihn als Professor oder gilt für den Fernsehmoderator.
Für viele gilt das aber nicht.
Wie kann man überhaupt so über Produktivität und Kreativität sprechen?
Das ist eine weitere berechtigte Frage.
Du hast doch nur ein Unternehmen, vielleicht sind es nur Stockwerke Unterschied,
dass du oben die Ingenieure hast, die sich irgendwas ausdenken,
die müssen tüfteln, klar sorgt man dafür andere Arbeitsbedingungen,
damit die den Kopf frei haben, um sich über Sachen Gedanken zu machen und unten
am Band, wo das dann zusammengesetzt wird, das oben ersonnene Produkt,
will man natürlich keine Kreativität, sondern Produktion nach.
Also da ist man dann, ja genau, und zwar bis heute.
Also da fördert man mit Absicht keine Kreativität. Er hat ja auch Kreativität
so als, ja das ist ja gut für den Arbeitgeber, wenn die Mitarbeiter kreativ sind.
Naja in manchen Bereichen ja, aber in anderen halt nicht.
Und er sagt dann auch, sonst wären wir gar nicht durch Corona gekommen.
Na ja, also dann hätten wir auf manche Dinge aus dem Homeoffice heraus verzichten
können. Zum Beispiel Professoren, die sich zuschalten.
Aber die Produktivität, die fand ja nicht im Homeoffice statt.
Also die Produktivität im Sinne von, wer sorgt dafür, dass ich auch Zahnpasta habe.
Ja, relativ viele Unternehmen sind ja wieder hardcore zurück.
So, jetzt ein Gedankenspiel, das hier in so einem Einspieler kommt.
Und denn Markus Gabriel macht es eigentlich so wie immer in seiner Karriere.
Er guckt, welche Diskurse gerade en vogue sind. Mal die neuen Realisten, mal dies, mal das.
Und jetzt die Leute, die einen ethischen Kapitalismus wollen.
Und da gibt es jetzt ganz findige Leute. Und jetzt, also wir bekommen das jetzt vorgestellt.
Und dann überlegen wir mal, ob wir das schon mal auch vielleicht irgendwo gehört
haben, so in den letzten 15 Jahren.
Ein Gedankenspiel. Eine Firma möchte im Amazonasregenwald Öl fördern.
Welche Kosten sind damit verbunden?
Die Firma muss das Land kaufen, die Fläche abholzen, eine Infrastruktur aufbauen
und Mitarbeiter bezahlen.
Dafür kann sie dann das geförderte Öl verkaufen. Sie macht einen Profit,
sobald sie mehr Geld für das Öl einnimmt, als es kostet, das Öl zu fördern.
Und genau da liegen wir komplett falsch.
Wir nehmen nicht die tatsächlichen Kosten, die ein Unternehmen verursacht,
und ziehen die von den Einnahmen ab.
Wir sollten mit fairen Gewinnen arbeiten, also dem, was übrig bleibt,
wenn man wirklich alle Kosten abzieht.
Diese Überlegungen haben jetzt schon so viele Angestellte. Da muss also nicht
noch mal Colin Mayer aus den USA kommen und sagen, ja, wenn man mal alles einpreisen
würde, was so ein Produkt oder ein Flug und so weiter kostet,
dann wären das ganz andere Preise.
Eva von Redeker hat ein Buch darüber geschrieben.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was mir hier noch mal neu verkauft wird.
Das ist doch alles klar, dass die Kosten, die Umweltkosten werden externalisiert.
Und die Gewinne behält das Unternehmen. Darüber reden wir doch seit Jahr und Tag.
Ich dachte auch, Ausbeutung ist ein Grundbegriff.
Hat man schon mal gehört, oder? Ja, wir hören mal weiter. Das ist jetzt die große Erkenntnis.
In unserem Beispiel nicht eingerechnet sind etwa die massiven Umweltschäden.
Der fehlende CO2-Speicher der Bäume, die Einbußen der lokalen Bauern sowie die
Folgen der schlechten Bezahlung der Mitarbeiter.
All das sind keine Werte, die in der klassischen Buchhaltung vorkommen.
Trotzdem beeinflussen sie den realen Profit eines Unternehmens gewaltig.
Aber wie kann man das ändern?
Ich will gar nicht sagen, dass das irgendwie falsch ist oder Fehl am Platz oder wie auch immer.
Denn wir haben ja vorhin gehört, dass Oma Erna die Chipfabrik von den Kartoffelchips
nicht unterscheiden kann und so.
Die Medien dokumentieren ja einfach wieder, wie krass unaufgeklärt ihr eigenes
Publikum ist, indem sie nämlich glauben, das kann man auch 2023 noch als Neuigkeit verkaufen.
Dass es so ist, ist wirklich ein Drama.
Ich wünschte, du hast recht, aber ich glaube das ist falsch.
Ich glaube, die Idee ist wirklich von Markus Gabriel und leider auch von Gerd
Skobel, dass man mit Colin Meyer einen neuen Meisterdenker jetzt hat,
der gerade ein Buch fertig geschrieben hat, das bislang nur als Manuskript da ist.
Also die haben es schon lesen können, Gabriel hat schon mit ihm gesprochen,
aber wir warten noch gespannt auf dieses Buch, dass genau diese These dann vertritt,
ach ja, wenn man mal alle Kosten da reinbringt.
Und jetzt haben wir ja über Umweltkosten zum einen geredet, jetzt sagen die,
ja die Lohnkosten, ja, was sind denn die richtigen Lohnkosten?
Also die werden ja ausgehandelt auf dem
Markt, beziehungsweise da spielen Gewerkschaften eine Rolle, et cetera.
Hier wird so getan, als würde der niedrige Lohn, den man zahlt,
als müsste man jetzt nur mal den richtigen Lohn reinrechnen.
Also was ist das für eine eigenartige Logik? Ja, das ist ja genau das im Kapitalismus,
dass da zwei Kräfte, zwei sich widerstreitende gegenüberstehen.
Der eine will möglichst geringe Lohnkosten, der andere will möglichst viel Lohn haben.
Ja, am 30. November 1923 hätten wir das genauso im Podcast gesagt.
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Und weiter.
Profit sollten diejenigen machen, die Lösungen für die Welt und jeden Einzelnen anbieten.
Dann würden Unternehmen es vermeiden, Probleme zu verursachen.
And companies need to avoid the latter.
Das wäre Kapitalismus, der ethischen Grundsätzen folgt.
Das ist ja jetzt hier Bildungsfernsehen, was wir hier uns ansehen.
Und jetzt frage ich dich, Profit sollen machen die Unternehmen,
die wirklich ganz, ganz viel auch uns Gutes tun.
Mitdenken.
Die mitdenken.
Also Scott Galloway, ich habe mir den Clip schon bereit gelegt,
vielleicht ich werde ihn im Salon dann mal spielen.
So einzeln einfach als Erinnerung. Wir haben doch jetzt Klimadiskurs,
sagen wir mal seit den 70ern.
Also ich glaube diesen Nobelpreis dieses Jahr für Erkenntnisse aus den 70ern
mit der CO2 Erwärmung ist und so weiter.
Wir haben jetzt 50 Jahre Klimadiskurs.
Das Kyoto-Protokoll liegt genau in der Mitte, so vor 25 Jahren,
irgendwann 1998 hat man das gemacht.
Damals hat man gesagt, Zäsur, wir belehren niemanden mehr, wir wissen auch was
eine moralische Keule ist und wie auch immer.
Es bringt aber alles nichts. Wir müssen anerkennen, die Wirtschaft funktioniert nach Profitlogik.
Wenn wir von der Wirtschaft irgendetwas wollen, und damit ist gemeint von den
Protagonisten, müssen wir Regulierung drumherum bauen.
Wir können es ihnen nicht abverlangen, selber moralisch zu denken.
Nur kleiner Diskurs, Exkurs, AI, ja, also wir haben künstliche Intelligenz und so weiter.
Und alle Welt sagt, das ist irgendwie gefährlich und so weiter,
außer Volker Wissing, der sagt, nee, da soll man es auf gar keinen Fall rein
regulieren. Ja. Man versteht es einfach nicht.
Und das ist das Argument jetzt von Markus Gabriel. Wir brauchen gar keine Regulierung,
sondern das ist seine große Idee.
Das ist genau falsch. Das ist genau die falsche Richtung.
Wir brauchen nur Erkenntnis. Wir brauchen Erkenntnisse in den Unternehmen.
Und da frage ich dich auch, gibt es irgendein Unternehmen, das nicht weiß,
was es zum Teil für ein Dreck produziert.
Ja genau. Wer hat denn die erste Klimaforschung gemacht zum Thema CO2? Ja Exxon Mobil.
Ja, es war ja auch nicht so, dass die Tabakindustrie nicht wusste,
dass möglicherweise das Rauchen Krebs verursachen kann.
Ich sag mal so.
Die Erkenntnis, dass Unternehmen im Rahmen des Wirtschaftssystems nach Profitlogik
kognitive Lernerfolge machen, die sie sofort einpreisen, weil sie dann Vorteile
gegenüber anderen Marktteilen, die man haben,
ist ein Zugeständnis an funktionale Differenzierung.
Wir labeln das im Grunde unter dem Hashtag Moderne.
Wenn man eine Philosophie vorstellt, die das nicht anerkennt,
hat man es mit vormoderner Philosophie zu tun. Auch wenn man vor dem Bindestrich neu schreibt.
Wie er das bei jedem Thema, das er jetzt aufgreift, macht.
Jetzt hier die Forschungsgruppe, die Colin Mayer da berät.
Sowohl Kosten wie Gewinne, die sich aus sozialer und ökologischer Verantwortung
ergeben, hätten so einen festen Platz in der Finanzbuchhaltung.
Forschende der Harvard Business School entwickeln ein solches System und rechnen
die wahren Kosten von Unternehmen aus.
Ja, das haben wir über CO2-Preiskalkulationen im Kyoto-Protokoll in antiker,
Geschichte gemacht und noch nie konsequent durchgezogen.
Das ist der Punkt und jetzt hier die große Erkenntnis, du wirst dich wundern.
Insgesamt haben die WirtschaftswissenschaftlerInnen knapp 1800 Firmen untersucht.
15% wären nach Abzug der Umweltkosten gar nicht mehr profitabel.
Weitere 33% hätten Einbußen von einem Viertel oder mehr.
Klassische Unternehmensbilanzen sagen also wenig darüber aus,
ob eine Firma wirklich profitabel ist.
Die nicht eingerechneten Kosten bezahlen wir alle.
So, jetzt nehmen wir mal ein anderes Beispiel, als immer nur über das Klima zu reden.
Die Zuckerindustrie. Säfte mit einem hohen Zuckeranteil sind sehr schlecht für die Zähne.
Wenn ich jetzt Ich sage, die sind zwar profitabel, aber eigentlich ja nicht.
Denn wenn ich da mal die Zahnarztkosten, die da anfallen, dazurechnen würde,
dann müssten die Säfte dreimal so teuer sein.
Ja, das ist ja eine schöne Argumentation.
Nur im Kapitalismus ist es ja so, dass die einen die Zuckersäfte herstellen,
die anderen die Zahnbürsten.
Und noch genialer ist es natürlich, wenn man beides herstellt,
dann kann man nämlich doppelt verdienen.
So funktioniert der Kapitalismus. Und hier wird jetzt so getan,
als sei man noch nie darauf gekommen, dass das eine irgendwas Negatives produziert.
Wenn wir heute Abend in der Bar ein zu viel trinken, dann hat der Barbetreiber
auch nur den Cocktail von mir bezahlt bekommen.
Aber soll ich dann da am nächsten Tag anrufen und sage, hör mal,
ich brauche jetzt mal so eine Packung Aspirin, die müsstest du mir jetzt mal
bitte finanzieren, denn ich habe hier gestern Abend bei dir Alkohol getrunken?
Ja, ich meine selbst in dieser Kalkulation.
Die Kohlelöcher in Sachsen, die ganz lange von Vattenfall ausgebuddelt wurden,
waren schon nicht mehr profitabel, als es noch gar keine Kohleregulierung oder
irgendetwas gab. Es war einfach zu teuer.
Dann hat das Land Sachsen gesagt, Vattenfall zieht sich zurück und wir finden
keinen Käufer. Was machen wir jetzt mit den Kohlekumpel? Die machen doch so
Ehrenwerte und so weiter und so.
Wir gründen selber eine GmbH. Also haben sie diese komische Leag oder wie sie heißt, gegründet.
Ein staatliches Unternehmen, das jetzt die Kohle ausbaggert.
Weil der Markt, es gibt keinen Marktteilnehmer mehr, der dort Profite sieht.
Und trotzdem geht das weiter. Also da braucht man doch gar keine Regulierung
von außen, die das noch mal teurer macht.
Wir handeln jetzt schon nicht nach diesen ethischen Maßstäben am Markt.
Wenn wir keinen Marktteilnehmer machen, der es unethisch macht,
macht es der Staat plötzlich selbst. Das ist doch das Problem, das wir haben.
Ja, dann bist du nicht Urkapitalist. Denn darum geht es, sagt Markus Gabriel.
Das leuchtet doch total ein, zu sagen, Profit sollten die machen,
die gute Lösungen für Probleme präsentieren.
Sagt Gerd Skobel, da muss man doch mal ganz kurz nachdenken,
worum geht es im Kapitalismus?
Darum Profit zu machen, nicht den Menschen irgendwas Gutes zu tun,
Bedürfnisse zu befriedigen.
Man kann Profit damit machen, indem man Zigaretten verkauft oder man kann Sportartikel
verkaufen oder was auch immer.
Das eine hat doch mit dem anderen einfach nichts zu tun.
Ich hab's ja vorhin beschrieben, wir gehen zur REWE und blenden einfach aus,
wie die Preise dort zustande kommen. Wie viel Ausbeutung, wie viel Zerstörung und so weiter.
Das wird ja jetzt hier kritisiert.
Genau.
Nur die Einpreisung kann ja nur über politische Regularien stattfinden.
Die kann ja nicht darüber stattfinden, dass die Unternehmen sagen, ach so.
Spiel den Anfang von dem Clip nochmal, was er sagt. Aber wir denken jetzt mal
nicht an die Unternehmen, die Produkte herstellen, sondern wir denken an uns
als Käufer, die die Kosten zahlen.
Ja.
Das leuchtet doch total ein, zu sagen, Profet sollten die machen,
die gute Lösungen für Probleme präsentieren.
So, das leuchtet doch total ein, dass ich in den Supermarkt gehe und alleine beim Obst.
Für die Handvoll Obst, die ich kaufe, 17 Euro bezahle. Das leuchtet doch total
ein, weil das sind doch die realen Preise.
Glaubt Gerd Skobel jetzt, damit könnte er sein Publikum abholen,
seinen Fernsehzuschauer? Nee.
Er redet einfach über die Welt der anderen, der Kapitaleigner,
der Produzenten, der Millionäre, und unterstellt da jetzt einfach,
ja, die sind ja klug und denken mit und so weiter.
Nee, die denken da genauso wenig mit wie Opa Enno, der Skobel sieht und dann
einkaufen geht und für drei Äpfel 17 Mark bezahlen soll. Also es passt einfach alles nicht zusammen.
Ja, Colin Mayer führt in diesem Buch, das bald erscheint, den Begriff eines
wahren Profits, des True Profits.
Profit bedeutet ja aus dem Lateinischen dasjenige, was uns nützt.
Und seine These ist eben zu sagen, dass der wirkliche Kapitalismus,
wenn man ordentlich buchhalterisch und so weiter arbeitet, eigentlich zeigen
würde, dass wir gar nicht in einem ordentlichen kapitalistischen System leben.
Das ist ja seine These, denn der Urkapitalismus ist eben ein System,
von dem er sagt, dass es auf einem moralischen Imperativ beruht.
Das ist jetzt nicht der von Immanuel Kant, sondern in dem Buch lesen wir dann,
dass dieser Imperativ darin besteht, dass wir Probleme lösen mit dem Ziel,
dass wir jemandem helfen, jemandem zu helfen, jemandem zu helfen.
Das habe ich anders verstanden damals in der Dissertation von Gunnar Heinsorn,
der die ersten zivilisatorischen, sagen wir mal, Maßnahmen beschreibt,
also noch 10.000, 20.000 Jahre vor der ersten Stadtgründung im antiken Griechenland,
also wir sind jetzt locker 25.000 Jahre in der Vergangenheit, da hieß es einfach,
wir verteilen jetzt Eigentum, mach damit, was du willst.
Deswegen macht man ja bis heute damit, was man will. Also man hat sich halt
ein Grundstück gekauft und natürlich baut man da ein Brunnen.
Und mit der Entstehung des Kapitalismus, sei sie jetzt 300, 350 Jahre alt,
wie auch immer, in England hat es wohl begonnen, kann man ja nicht in irgendeiner
Weise sagen, dass es da Gründerväter gegeben hat, die sagten,
ja Profit, das kommt ja aus dem Lateinischen, das heißt doch eigentlich,
dass es jedem nützen soll und so helfen wir einander, indem wir den Kapitalismus etablieren.
Nein, das ist überhaupt nicht angedacht.
Deswegen funktioniert ja der Kapitalismus auch in Staaten mit unglaublicher Ungleichheit.
Ich meine, die Goldgräberstimmung ist dadurch historisch so bedeutsam,
dass damals neben jedem Goldgräber jemand mit einer Peitsche stand,
der sagte preise alles ein, mach nicht was du willst und so weiter,
verschafft dir keine Vorteile indem du einfach den Konkurrenten erschießt oder
wie auch immer. Das ist doch völlig banal.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum solche Leute so was im Fernsehen ...
Jens Beckert widerspricht.
Warum, so Colin Meyer, denn nicht mal versuchen zu verstehen,
dass der Kapitalismus auch eine Utopie ist?
Es gibt den reinen Kapitalismus nicht. Und das ist aber kein Einwand gegen ihn.
Also, ich glaube, dass man betrachten muss, dass es nicht einfach um Einsichten geht.
Also, zumindest nicht um Einsichten im Sinne, dass der Unternehmer sagen kann,
also mir ist das so wichtig, und dann entsprechend handeln.
Sondern ich glaube, man muss schon die Systemzwänge innerhalb des kapitalistischen
Systems dabei mit berücksichtigen. Da bin ich vielleicht naiver Aufklärer oder
im Projekt der Aufklärung hängen geblieben.
Aber die Idee ist doch, dass sich das gerade durchsetzt.
Nein, es wird sich nur dann durchsetzen, wenn es eine politische Durchsetzung davon gibt.
Also Fratscher war mit in der Runde?
Fratscher war mit in der Runde und Beckert, nee, weil Fratscher auch nicht viel dazu sagt.
Beckert sagt ja jetzt hier, naja, das ist nicht eine Frage von Einsicht bei
den Unternehmen, dass die sagen, ach so, gut, dass ihr mir das von der Ethikkommission
mal erzählt, dass es hier Probleme gibt bei meiner Produktionsweise.
Sondern der macht das ja absichtlich, um in einer internationalen und auch nationalen
Konkurrenz bestehen zu können.
Und es gibt kein anderes Kriterium für den Unternehmer, als den Profit zu realisieren.
Und da ist es keine Frage von Aufklärung oder von Einsicht oder sonst irgendetwas.
Und dass das hier in der Philosophiesendung nochmal gesagt werden muss,
ist doch völlig verrückt.
Aber jetzt gehen wir mal weiter zu dem, was Gabriel sich da vorstellt.
Also wir kommen noch mal zu diesen Preisen.
Nur ein kurzer Funfact einfach zum Thema Aufklärung. Warum hat ExxonMobil damals
diese Forschung gemacht?
Zum Thema Erderwärmung durch Ereignisse zutun.
Weil sie wissen wollten, wann gewisse Liegenschaften einfach aufgetaut sind.
Damit sie da leichter bohren können. Also so viel zum partikularen Interesse
und wohin Aufklärung führt. Also zum Gemeinwohl nicht.
Das ist moralisch böse, sagt Markus Gabriel.
Dann wäre zum Beispiel die inzwischen fast sprichwörtliche Wochenendreise nach
Mallorca zu teuer, die Lufthansa gäbe es nicht mehr. Für wen zu teuer? Für alle.
Für die Leute mit Privatjet natürlich nicht, ne? Aber in dem Modell,
das er vorschlägt, wäre die Lufthansa pleite. Haben wir auch in dieser Harvard-Studie gesehen.
Und die meisten anderen Fluglinien auch. Nun wollen wir aber natürlich nach
Mallorca, dagegen spricht ja auch nichts.
Und die unternehmerische Idee dann des Kapitalismus wäre, dass man eine andere
Art des Transportes, Zeppeline oder sowas, entwickelt.
Das geht, ist skalierbar. Ich finde, unternehmerisch.
Ja, mit dem Zeppelin nach Mallorca. Ich wünsche viel Spaß dabei.
Übrigens heißt es Beförderung und nicht Transport. Menschen werden befördert.
Und sehr schön ist doch hier, dass er mal so ganz kurz von Fratscha zu hören
bekommt, ja aber für wen denn zu teuer?
Ja.
Denn das ist ja genau die Frage, die sich ergibt, auch bei der CO2-Bepreisung.
Und die CO2-Bepreisung ist ja ein uraltes Modell, das ja nicht entsprechend durchgesetzt wird.
Und das liegt an der Politik und er glaubt, man müsse das nur den Unternehmen
sagen und dann werden die das schon einpreisen.
Ja warum sollten die das denn tun? Das ist ja so, da kannst du auch jemanden
eine Axt aussendigen und sagen schlag dir die Hand ab.
Das ist eh, wir hatten ja vorhin schon gehört, wie auch Fradscher noch mal darauf
hinwies, konsumtive und investierende Staatsausgaben.
Wenn man den Sozialstaat kürzt, das hat Mubus Höfgen gestern im Wirtschaftsbriefing,
das ich wirklich allen empfehle, ganz hervorragende Sendung, auch nochmal betont,
wenn man beim Sozialstaat kürzt, wie die CDU es meint, also bei den Ärmsten,
greift man sofort in den Wirtschaftskreislauf ein, weil diese Menschen geben das Geld sofort aus.
Wenn man bei den Reichen, die Fraccia hier anspricht, denen ist einfach egal,
was es kostet, die konsumieren auf jeden Fall, die haben dann nur eine geringere Sparquote.
Also die legen einfach weniger zurück, die verzehren sozusagen mehr von ihrem,
aber grundsätzlich wachsenden Vermögen.
Und das ist auch ein ganz, ganz, ganz wichtiger Punkt bei allen Diskussionen.
Müsste man natürlich dann datengetrieben, aber wenn man eine rente kürzt oder
ein bürgergeld oder was auch immer, dann fehlt dieses geld im kreislauf.
Ja, ist ja völlig logisch.
So wie wir jetzt gesehen haben, dass zehn prozent inflation plus eine mehrwertsteuererhöhung
in verschiedenen bereichen, wie sie jetzt kommt, auch die haben ja zu recht angst.
Weil die Leute gehen dann da nicht mehr konsumieren. Zehn Prozent Inflation
führt eben zu zehn Prozent weniger Absatz im Supermarkt.
Also da kann man einfach die VWL und die BWL-Kalkulation eins zu eins aufeinander legen.
Im Supermarkt wird gekauft, was am Monatsende reinkommt. Am Monatsende ist das Geld weg.
Die Leute haben tausend Euro und die tausend Euro müssen sie ausgeben.
Bei den Reichen sieht es halt anders aus.
Die Leute, die 30.000 Euro im Monat zur Verfügung haben, die lassen die 30.000,
nicht komplett auf der Goethe-Straße in Frankfurt.
Die geben 5.000 dort auf, kaufen eine Handtasche und Schuhe oder so und dann sind die 5.000 weg.
Und wenn die jetzt statt den 30.000 28.000 haben, dann kaufen die immer noch
genau dasselbe, nur legen die dann nicht so viel an für irgendeine ETF-Sparen.
Und jetzt hören wir hier mal jemand anders.
Wir hatten heute schon die Rede von dem, ja mein Lieber, nämlich Thomas Gottschalk zum Thema Fliegen.
Du musst ja auch bald nach Hamburg Und da kannst du schon mal gucken,
wie man es auch machen kann. Ich sah diesen Clip bei YouTube.
Thomas Gottschalk ist hier im Interview mit Globe Air.
Das ist ein Unternehmen, das Privatschats zur Verfügung stellt.
Und Thomas Gottschalk macht sehr gern Gebrauch davon und erklärt hier mal, warum.
Ich versuche halt nach Möglichkeit mit meiner Zeit, die mir noch bleibt,
zu haushalten wie möglich.
Und man verliert einfach wahnsinnig viel Zeit, wenn man zwei Stunden eher da
sein muss. Und wenn man sich dann ansteht mit den Leuten und dann,
ach Gott, ich hab das in Amerika mal erlebt, da haben sie den Brad Pitt irgendwo
außen an der Schlange vorbeigeführt.
Da klatschen die Leute beifall. Mich haben sie mal in Frankfurt an der Schlange vorbeigeführt.
Da hat irgendeiner hinten gesagt, Herr Jotz, sag ihre Schoßgucken,
muss nicht mehr an. Weil die da natürlich sauer waren, dass ich den extra wurscht gekriegt hab.
Das ist in Deutschland alles ein bisschen anders. Es ist wesentlich für mich
von Baden-Baden nach Hamburg.
Wie würde das aussehen? Ich müsste nach Frankfurt mit dem Auto fahren, zwei Stunden.
Und dann hast du einen Stau bei Pforzheim und dann sitzt du in Frankfurt rum
und dann musst du gucken, dass die Maschine pünktlich ist und dann bist du im
Flughafen in Hamburg, dann bist du wieder in der Schlange und wartest auf dein Gepäck.
Ja, deswegen fliegt er von Baden-Baden mit Privatjet nach Hamburg.
Ja. Ich hab mal für dich nachgeguckt, wenn du nächste Woche nach Hamburg musst,
also das kostet so etwa 5800.
Naja, ich will dazu sagen, wir sagen noch nicht, warum ich nach Hamburg muss.
Und von Frankfurt aus würde ich natürlich mit dem Zug fahren,
weil ja gar keine, es sind sozusagen begründete, ich lasse später darüber urteilen,
ob ich zurecht geflogen bin.
Aber hier können wir einfach diese Differenz mal sehen und da wird es über den Preis gelöst.
Da sagt halt sich einfach jemand, ja, dann kostet das halt 5800 Euro,
aber ich muss nicht im Stau stehen und ich muss nicht auf mein Gepäck warten.
Ja, jetzt könnte man natürlich wirklich mal in so einer Sendung durchkalkulieren.
Also ich finde, das sollte dann auch Markus Gabriel selber machen,
sich ein Taschenrechner rausholen und mal alle Externalisierungskosten einpreisen
in diesen Flug von Thomas Gottschalk.
Ich würde zum einen vermuten, dass er das gar nicht kann und dass er zum zweiten,
wenn er uns die Liste vorlegt, welche Kosten er reingekalkuliert hat,
dass wir dann ganz hart kritisieren, dass da irgendwas fehlt oder so.
Also dass sie nicht abschließend ist, dass es da keine absolute letztendgültig
geltende Wahrheit gibt und so.
Kann es ja auch gar nicht geben. Also bei einem CO2 Preis kannst du es ja noch
leicht machen, aber wenn es um Gehälter geht, wie will man das nachvollziehen?
Wann ist es dann das gerechte Gehalt?
An welchem Mindestlohn muss ich denn was genau orientieren?
Welche Folgeschäden hat jemand, jemand der den ganzen Tag einen gewissen Lärm
abbekommt von Bohrern oder was weiß ich, wird im Alter schwerhörig sein.
Und wie wird das jetzt berechnet? Kostet nochmal 10.000 Euro extra den Arbeitgeber.
Das ist ja eine völlige Idiotie, die hier vorgestellt wird. Aber du hast schon
gesagt, man braucht da viele Leute, die das rechnen.
Das heißt, man hat hier eigentlich eine eigene Arbeitsbeschaffungsmaßnahme sich geschaffen.
Vor allem hat Thomas Gottschalk ja nicht mit dem Preis des Fluges argumentiert,
sondern mit seiner Lebenszeit.
Das sind natürlich moralisch ganz heikle Diskussionen, mit Lebenszeit zu argumentieren,
denn wir haben alle eine Lebenszeit und sind da nicht gleich, wie wir wissen. Ja.
Er möchte da Vorteile nutzen, also Lebenszeit zu kalkulieren wird immer heikler, sage ich mal so.
Wir haben jetzt im November einen ganz tollen wissenschaftlichen Fortschritt.
Die CRISPR-Genschere-Methode,
die.
Man immer so schön nennt, hat im ersten Anwendungsfall.
Und wir wissen ja, dafür gab es schon vor Ewigkeiten Nobelpreise und so,
hat für einen ersten Anwendungsfall praktische Relevanz, nämlich bei der Medikamentenherstellung.
Es gibt, glaube ich, irgendeinen Krebs oder so, den man noch mal heilen kann,
indem man die Stammzellen so umbaut, dass man die dann, wenn man die dem Körper
gibt, dass er dann wieder sich erholen kann.
Allerdings kosten pro Patient 2 Millionen Euro.
Bei einem Flug, den man auch vermeiden kann, im Sinne von, ja gut,
ich lebe zwar noch 40 Jahre und habe jetzt einen halben Tag davon verschwendet
für Transport oder Beförderung, wie ich sagen würde.
Schön und gut, aber wenn man jetzt eine Diagnose bekommt und dann heißt es 2
Millionen Euro, keine Kassenleistung.
Dann weißt du, dass dein Leben einfach zwei Millionen Euro wert ist.
Entweder du kannst sie auftreiben und irgendwem sagen, go fund me oder dann
sagen die, na ist aber keine Investition, kriege ich es denn zurück?
Es wird ja verkonsumiert.
Also es sind noch heikle Diskussionen, die uns so anstehen bei solchen,
wir preisen mal alles ein, weil mittlerweile gibt es die Produkte,
in denen sowas eingepreist ist. Von den zwei Millionen Euro könnte man ja auch
davon ausgehen, wenn es jetzt ein Massenprodukt wäre und so weiter,
werden die Kosten ja niedriger, dann würden sich das mehr Leute leisten können.
Wir haben es aber hier mit prototypischer Medikamentation zu tun und die hat
jetzt einfach den Einzelwert pro Patient von zwei Millionen Euro.
Und wir haben bestimmt ein paar Leute, die diese Diagnose bekommen.
Ich will Gott sei Dank nicht verteidigen, aber ich will auch mal ein Gedankenexperiment wagen.
Und zwar ist es ja so, dass wir uns mitunter Zeit kaufen.
Also es gibt Möglichkeiten, ein schnelleres Check-in zu haben,
indem man ein bisschen Aufschlag zahlt.
Man kann mit dem Taxi fahren, statt auf den Bus zu warten.
Also wir kaufen uns schon Zeit. Und jetzt ist das ein Betrag,
der für uns beide natürlich aus der Welt liegt, dass wir sagen,
ich fliege nach Hamburg und zahle 5.800 Euro dafür und bin ja dann noch nicht zurückgeflogen.
Aber jeder kann sich ja mal selbst überlegen, was jetzt wäre,
wenn der Privatschnittflug 120 Euro kosten würde.
Und so glaube ich kann man es jetzt, ich weiß nicht was Gottschalk besitzt,
vielleicht ist es für ihn auch eher wie 300 Euro oder so, aber so in etwa kann man ja mal rechnen.
Das wäre so eine erste Klasse Fahrt mit der Bahn, dafür könnte man auch mit dem Privatjet fahren.
Also kann ja mal jeder überlegen, wie er dann damit umgeht.
Zeppelin Flug nach Mallorca, du hast eine Woche Urlaub, aber es kostet zweimal
drei Tage Reisezeit in so einer kleinen Kabine.
Ja, dann ist die Antwort doch schon mal da gegeben. Jetzt aber machen wir Werbung für Markus Gabriel.
Er macht selbst für sich und seinem Projekt Werbung.
Nach einer allgemeinen gesellschaftlichen Aufgabe, die sich irgendwie auch wirtschaftlich
bewältigen lässt, also ganz kapitalistisch.
Und da bin ich dann gefragt worden, jetzt auch ein Modell zu entwickeln für
einen ethischen Kapitalismus.
Für die Debatte schreibt er ein Buch mit dem Arbeitstitel Profiting from human
happiness, also wie man aus Glückseligkeit Profit schlägt.
Was erstmal böse klingt. Das klingt erstmal böse, ja.
Aber in dem Kontext geht es eben wirklich darum, sich zu fragen.
Warum klingt das böse? Es gibt ja tatsächlich ganz viele Dinge,
die hergestellt werden, die profitabel sind, die Menschen glücklicher machen.
Das beginnt bei der Medizin und endet bei der Entertainment-Industrie.
Ich sag dazu nochmal, was, wenn der Clip durchgelaufen ist. Ich will gucken,
ob noch was kommt von Herrn Gabriel.
Ob wir zum Beispiel durch die Einführung einer interdisziplinären Ethik-Abteilung in Unternehmen,
Geschäftsmodelle aussortiert im Unternehmensalltag nach dem Kriterium,
ob sie dem allgemeinen moralischen Fortschritt der Menschheit dienen oder nicht.
Also Glückseligkeit, Einpreisen irgendwie. Ich bin jetzt immer mehr fasziniert von diesem Umstand,
sagen wir mal, die profane Einflugschneise ist, man hat den Leuten mehr Geld
gezahlt, man hat irgendwann festgestellt, relativ zügig ist so eine Grenze erreicht,
sie werden nicht mehr glücklicher, auch durch mehr Geld, das sie im Monat zur Verfügung haben.
Bis hin zu, dass man dann irgendwann auf Thomas Gottschalk Niveau da ist und
sagt, Also die 5.800 Euro mache ich nicht, um glücklicher zu werden,
sondern das ist mein Status quo.
Man hat sich dann so dran gewöhnt, dass alles, was darunter liegt,
sich anstellen an der Schlange. Ach du großer Gott, das ist sozusagen negativ.
Es wird negativ erfahren. Es ist so, wieso kann ich gerade nicht privat fliegen und so weiter.
Also plötzlich hat man sogar eine Quelle von sozusagen negativer Energie in seinem Leben.
Und das heißt ja, erstmal finanziell ausgedrückt, okay, so bei 5000 Euro im
Monat oder so, hört's auf.
Danach muss man sich andere Wege des Glücklichmachens suchen.
Und die sind dann aber, und das steckt ja da drin, nicht mehr finanzierbar.
Egal wie viel Geld man hat, man ist nicht mehr sicher vor unglücklich sein.
Und das findet alles im Bereich der Familie vor allem statt.
Also ob ein Date so klappt, dass man sich wirklich wohl damit fühlt,
mit jemandem Zeit verbracht zu haben, ist ganz entkoppelt von Vielgeld.
Also Fragen des Vielgeldes.
Man kann sich maximal eine Sauna, ein Kino, ein Freizeitpark mieten und dann
dazu zwei Zeit verbringen, aber irgendwo ist da eine Grenze und das fühlen wir, glaube ich, alle.
Und es ist wahnsinnig schwer, das auszuformulieren. Vielleicht schreibe ich
einfach das Gegenbuch zu dem, über das die hier sprechen, diese Herrschaftsliteratur,
die sie erst mal nur am Tisch kennen, weil sie noch nicht publiziert wurde.
Weil dieser, was er jetzt so, dieser Ultrakapitalismus, der Urkapitalismus,
der reicht dann doch nur so und so weit.
Und man kann das auch nur, so wie er darüber redet, kann man das nur ein Publikum
verklickern, das unterhalb dieser Grenze liegt. Also für die,
die viel Geld haben, ein unerfahrenes, unentdecktes Land ist.
Die sind dann noch empfänglich für so moralisch-gedankliche.
Auswüchse, irgendwie, das könnte ja alles viel besser sein und so weiter und so fort.
Menschen, die irgendwann mal genug Geld verdient haben, und davon gibt es ja
in Frankfurt einige, die man dann auch so trifft im Alltag, da stellen sich einfach andere Fragen.
Und da weiß man auch ganz schnell, da geht es echt nicht um Geld.
Also man kann ihnen jetzt nicht aushelfen im Sinne von, beziehungsweise man
wünscht sich sogar, man hätte es wieder mit armen Menschen in seinem Umfeld
zu tun, weil denen könnte man einfach 1.000 Euro geben und dann wäre schon ganz schön viel erreicht.
Und man hat's aber ganz schnell mit ganz vielen Menschen zu tun,
wo es diesen Shortcut, diesen Ausweg einfach nicht gibt.
Und wo es ganz schnell existenziell wird und wo dann auch die ganzen Depressionen reinkicken und so.
Von daher, ich glaube, ich schau mir dieses Scar-Pred-Zeug doch noch mal genauer
an, um einfach ordentlich dagegenhauen zu können.
Und hinzu kommt ja auch das, was er da beschreibt, dass Unternehmen,
die ethisch handeln, Profit machen können.
Also im Sinne von die Klimatransformation anstoßen.
Das stimmt ja, aber wir reden ja hier von Einzelunternehmen,
bei denen man sagen kann, oh das ist aber toll, dass ihr einen Staubsauger erfunden
habt, mit dem man CO2 aus der Luft bekommt.
Und da mag das ja der Fall sein, aber ganz viel im produzierenden Gewerbe ist
die Herstellung von Alltagsgegenständen.
Das, was wir jetzt gerade hier vor uns sehen, das unser Publikum jetzt gerade
vor sich sieht, das ist das, was hergestellt wird, was man die ganze Zeit kauft.
Und da geht es nicht um die Frage, habe ich jetzt hier moralisch etwas Fortschrittliches?
Nee, ich habe hier einfach ein Glas.
Ja, das haben wir ja bei China damals. Wir haben ja dieses Shenzhen Buch gelesen.
30 Millionen Einwohner, riesige Sonderwirtschaftszone, so und so viel,
Billionen Euro, riesiges Förderprogramm und so weiter. Und daneben ist einfach die nächste Stadt.
Doppelt so groß, doppelt so viele Menschen, dreifaches Budget.
Wozu? Ja, weil die Waschmaschinen herstellen müssen.
Ja, das hast du überall eigentlich. Das sage ich immer wieder,
man übersieht, wie groß die Welt wirklich ist.
Ja, und wir übersehen auch das, was eigentlich die Produktion ausmacht.
Und dazu will ich uns jetzt gleich führen, denn das, um das schon mal vorweg
zu nehmen, ist meine große These in dieser Ausgabe.
Wir haben durch die Klimadiskussion völlig den Arbeiter ausgeblendet.
Die Leute, die ihre Arbeitskraft verkaufen müssen, und das sind die meisten
in Deutschland und die meisten auf der Welt, die finden in den kapitalismuskritischen
Diskursen, Stichwort Ulrike Herrmann,
eigentlich überhaupt keine Erwähnung mehr.
Weil man nur darüber redet, wie man den Kapitalismus entweder so modulieren
kann, dass er selbst CO2 spart.
Oder wie man den Kapitalismus abschafft, damit wir keinen CO2 mehr emittieren.
Aber es geht überhaupt nicht mehr darum, in welchen Situationen Menschen sind,
die ihre Arbeitskraft verkaufen müssen. Dazu kommen wir aber gleich.
Wir schauen uns das Projekt von Gabriel an.
Mein Modell ist zu sagen, dass in einem erfolgreichen ethischen Kapitalismus
die Ethikabteilung aus der Sicht der UnternehmerInnen dasselbe Gewicht hat wie die Steuerberatung.
Dass es eine völlig irrsinnige Idee im Unternehmen wäre, nicht die Ethikabteilung
zu konsultieren. Das ist der normative Vorschlag.
Da sollen die Unternehmen dann profitieren, dass sie Markus Gabriel und die seinen anstellen.
Das wäre genauso profitabel wie ein Steuerberater. Ein Steuerberater spart auch,
wenn er gut ist. einem Geld, der zeigt, wie man Steuern sparen kann.
Die Ethikkommission, die privat organisiert ist, bzw.
Diese Ethikabteilung in einem Unternehmen, die sagt mir ja die ganze Zeit nur,
ja das ist aber moralisch nicht gut, dass sie jetzt hier so Einwegflaschen herstellen,
denken sie mal lieber darüber nach, ihr Unternehmen ganz sein zu lassen.
Sagt er das irgendwann mal explizit, dass man in seinem Modell keine Politik braucht?
Ja, das sagt er auch im Vortrag von Luzern mehrmals und mir hat ein Bekannter,
nachdem ich dort mit Humann und Co diskutiert habe,
dann gesagt, er war bei diesem Vortrag in Luzern, danach gab es eine Fragerunde,
die nicht bei YouTube ist und dann hat offenbar eine Frau gesagt,
ja aber was ist denn, wenn jetzt ein Pharmakonzern dies und das tut,
also irgendwas was Schlimmes macht, dann sagt er, ja das geht natürlich nicht,
dass Konzerne dies und das, also irgendwas böse machen.
Und dann haben wohl auch das Luzerner Publikum leicht gelächelt,
so nach dem Motto, naja bei Konzernen, es geht doch eh, was sie wollen.
Das ist sehr amüsant. Beckert kontert hier.
Es erinnert mich an einen bekannten Ausspruch von Niklas Luhmann,
dem deutschen Soziologen, der mal einen Vortrag über Wirtschaftsethik halten
sollte. und sagte, er kramt jetzt schon in seiner Tasche nach den Autoschlüsseln. Ja.
Also, der wollte da nur noch weg.
Ja, Ethik und Wirtschaft schnell die Autoschlüssel rausholen.
Einen Clip hören wir uns aber noch an.
Noch mal, was kann alles Großartiges passieren im ethischen Kapitalismus?
Ich würde sagen, das ist wahrscheinlich ein Aspekt, den Luhmann nicht gesehen hat.
Weil Luhmann davon ausging, dass diese Systeme immer nicht koppeln.
Es gibt aber clevere Wege, wie Sie doch koppeln.
Möchtest du dazu etwas sagen?
Das ist so dumm. Okay.
Also der Ökonom Dennis Noah, der sozusagen in derselben Debattenlage auch ist
wie Colin Mayer und die Beiträge, die ich gerade mache und viele andere in der
Diskussion, die unter New Moral Political Economy läuft.
New Moral Political Economy, muss man sich schon mal merken,
kommen wahrscheinlich jetzt zehn Jahre lang schlimme Sachen auf uns zu.
Alles New York Times Bestseller.
Margaret Levy, Deborah Setz waren da auch wichtige Theoretikerinnen,
die Impulse geliefert haben.
Was diese Debatte sagt, ist, dass wir eben tatsächlich Profit im messbaren Sinne
nach allen sozusagen mehr oder weniger Standardindikatoren erwirtschaften wollen,
also völlig kapitalistisch vorgehen.
Aber das Ziel ist eben, moralischen Fortschritt zu begünstigen.
Sehr, sehr einfaches Beispiel, wer mit unternehmerischen Mitteln,
wie auch immer, ich weiß ja auch nicht wie, sonst würde ich es tun,
das Klimaproblem lösen könnte, wäre garantiert sehr, sehr reich.
Oder man denke an die Pandemie.
Durch die kapitalistisch hergestellten Vakzine sind einige Menschen sehr, sehr reich geworden.
Das hat riesige Steuern nach Mainz gebracht, um den BioNTech-Fall zu bringen.
Wir hatten hier ein moralisch hochwertiges Produkt.
Das aber komischerweise in so ganz viele Länder so spät oder gar nicht ausgeliefert
wurde, kann das vielleicht auch mit dem Kapitalismus zusammenhängen?
Dass die da nicht genügend Geld auf den Tisch gelegt haben.
Ich hab die Geschichtsschreibung natürlich so ein bisschen verpasst,
aber sind auch Leute ärmer geworden durch die Pandemie?
Oder war das jetzt überall nur moralischer Fortschritt, was wir gesehen haben,
weil in Mainz mehr Gewerbesteuer aufgelaufen ist?
Ja.
Das ist der Indikator für, es war moralisch voll gut.
Die dann gesenkt wurde von der Politik.
Genau, der Gewerbesteuer stand einfach mal aufs kleinste Niveau deutschlandweit.
Ja, also auf diesem Niveau diskutieren wir, aber wir müssen es nicht tun,
wenn wir in die Wirklichkeit gehen.
Ich glaube, es wird sich ja doch immer mehr abzeichnen, dass wir der Podcast
sind, der noch weiß, wo die Wirklichkeit ist.
Und das erfährt man dann auch zum Beispiel im Deutschlandfunk.
Wir wissen ja sowieso, das Radio ist das bessere Fernsehen. Und dort gab es
ein herausragendes Feature von Nina Scholz und Sebastian Friedrich,
das hat den Titel gemobbt, gekündigt, abgefunden, wie Unternehmen gegen Betriebsräte vorgehen.
Und ich empfehle, das einem jeden sich dringend anzuhören und wir hören jetzt
in dieses Feature mal rein, um jetzt mal das zu tun, was die anderen nicht gemacht haben,
nämlich mal über die zu sprechen, die die Arbeitskraft verkaufen müssen,
was auch Ulrike Herrmann und all die Leute und Maja Göpel eigentlich gar nicht mehr interessiert.
Die sagen zwar immer, naja, so Klimagerechtigkeit muss auch mit der sozialen
Frage einhergehen, aber da kommt nie sonst irgendetwas.
Deswegen gucken wir mal, wie denn eigentlich so ein Arbeitskampf verläuft.
Ja hallo, ich bin Murat Datas, der Gesamtbetriebsratsvorsitzende FoodLocker Germany GmbH.
Das heißt, ich bin verantwortlich für knapp 1400 Mitarbeiter deutschlandweit.
Und ja, bin jetzt seit 2017 Betriebsrat und seit knapp zweieinhalb Jahren der
Gesamtbetriebsratsvorsitzende.
Der Gesamtbetriebsratsvorsitzende Murat von Footlocker.
Wir alle kennen diese Schuhfilialen in Deutschland. Ich glaube, es gibt etwa 90.
Weltweit sind es 2.000, 3.000.
Es ist ein sehr großes Unternehmen. Jetzt ist ein Kollege von Murat vor Gericht.
Er ist hier, um einen Kollegen zu unterstützen. Ihr gemeinsamer Arbeitgeber,
der Sportschuhhändler Footlocker, hat ihm fristlos gekündigt.
Sein Kollege steht neben ihm. Er trägt weiße Turnschuhe, schwarze Hose und eine
blau-weiße Trainingsjacke.
Ich bin Amin Barakat, 29 Jahre alt und ich arbeite seit 2012,
also seit 10 Jahren bei Vodafone.
Armin möchte hier heute vor Gericht gegen die Kündigung vorgehen.
Vorgeworfen wird mir Arbeitszeitbetrug von der Arbeitgeberin.
Aber Fakt ist, dass ich aufgrund meiner aktiven Betriebsratsarbeit jetzt bestraft werden soll.
Armin wirft Futtlocker vor, dass man ihm gekündigt habe, weil er sich als Betriebsrat
in den vergangenen Jahren für die Belange der Belegschaft eingesetzt hat.
So, dieser Armin ist auch Betriebsrat. Und als Betriebsrat kann man eine gewisse
Stundenzahl nutzen, um Betriebsratstätigkeiten auszuführen und hier wird jetzt vorgeworfen,
Armin, er habe da sich mehr Stunden angerechnet,
als er eigentlich gebraucht hat.
Hat also zu wenig gearbeitet, war zu viel Betriebsrat?
Das ist ja eigentlich glasklar geregelt und es gibt auch wenig Regelungen,
die von Seiten der Betriebsräte oder Vertrauensleute strenger eingehalten werden,
als ja, ich bin hier angestellt und arbeite hier, aber und da kommt ja der Begriff her, Abgeordnet,
um auch Politik zu machen.
Denkst du? Dachte ich auch. Ist aber gar nicht so.
Es ist zum Beispiel auch kein Offizialdelikt, wenn dort Schindluder getrieben wird mit diesen Zahlen.
Also wenn Unternehmen dort die Leute daran hindern, Betriebsratsarbeit zu leisten.
Das heißt Offizialdelikt, es kann nicht jeder das anzeigen, sondern es kann
dann nur der Einzelne das tun. Und tatsächlich muss eigentlich das Unternehmen
auch darüber buchführen, über diese Stunden.
Aber tatsächlich ist das ein Knackpunkt und es werden auch mehrere Experten
zu Wort kommen, die immer wieder sagen, ja genau dieses Kämpfen um die Stunden,
wer da wie eigentlich agitieren kann für den Betriebsrat,
das ist etwas, was keineswegs so festgelegt ist und da es auch ganz schwer ist dagegen zu gehen.
So jetzt ist also dieser Armin fristlos entlassen worden und der ist jetzt erst
mal vor Gericht, möchte wieder eingestellt werden.
Das kann man über so einen Eilantrag dann machen, so eine einstweilige Verfügung.
Dem gibt das Gericht erst mal nicht statt, aber es gibt große Aussicht darauf,
dass er eigentlich wieder eingestellt werden muss, weil das so nicht gehen kann.
Wir hören jetzt Murat nochmal.
Es wird immer wieder versucht, wirklich die Betriebsratsarbeit zu erschweren.
Aktuell haben wir so viele Baustellen, wo wir als Betriebsräte nur unsere Arbeit machen möchten.
Wirklich das Mindestmaß an Recht, was den Betriebsratsmitgliedern zusteht,
einfordern. Aber das wird uns verwehrt, das muss man klar sagen.
Zunächst ist das Interesse am Verfahren auch groß.
Obwohl das Verfahren in einem der größeren Säle stattfindet,
reichen die Stühle nicht aus.
Ich freue mich über die Unterstützung, die Solidarität hier von Linken,
von der SPD, von der Ver.di, Meine Freundin ist hier, der Betriebsrat.
Sehr viele Leute sind gerade gekommen.
Politik, Gewerkschaft, privates Umfeld, alle sind da. Hier nochmal der Vorwurf von Footlocker.
Footlocker wirft Armin vor, zu viele Stunden für Betriebsratsarbeit aufgeschrieben zu haben.
Footlockers Anwalt versucht zu erläutern, wie viele Minuten man braucht,
um Stimmen einer Betriebsratswahl zu zählen.
Wir sind also hier in einem Bereich, in dem um jede Minute gefeilscht wird.
Und wir haben noch eben Markus Gabriel im Ohr gehabt. Ja, das steigert die Produktivität
und Arbeitszeitverkürzung, das macht alle kreativ.
Nee, hier wird um jede Minute gestritten, denn ja, das sind ja Leute,
die in diesen Geschäften stehen und da müssen die sonst noch jemanden für eine Schicht herholen.
Vor allem so, wie man das jetzt raushört, da fand also eine Abstimmung statt,
die Belegschaft wurde gefragt vom Betriebsrat und dann ist die Frage,
wie lange darf man sich denn Zeit nehmen, um das demokratisch gesichert auszuziehen,
sodass man auch ein valides Ergebnis hat.
Ja, das ist wirklich, ja das ist, jetzt sind wir hier wirklich,
hier sind wir beim Urkapitalismus, können wir Markus Gafrey mal sagen.
Na die einsfältige Verfügung war ja dafür da, dass ich sofort wieder beschäftigt
werde, weil aktuell bin ich raus, arbeite nicht, verdiene somit auch gerade nichts.
Man geht an seiner Sparte, aber irgendwann ist es auch zu Ende und der Hauptprozess,
der wird ja etwas länger dauern und naja, das ist halt jetzt ein Ausdauerlauf. Das ist alles gemischt.
Jetzt gerade Zähne zusammenbeißen und durchhalten, durchhalten.
Wir haben hier einen Einzelnen, der einem Riesenkonzern gegenübersteht.
Und der jetzt erst mal kein Geld hat, muss sich jetzt was leihen,
muss mal sehen, wie er durchkommt. Er ist dabei kein Einzelfall.
Armin berichtet, es habe in der Vergangenheit in anderen Filialen schon Fälle
gegeben, bei denen Betriebsräte oder aktive Beschäftigte außerordentlich gekündigt worden seien.
Furtlocker habe es geschafft, die Betriebsräte zu zermürben und mit einem Vergleich
vor dem Arbeitsgericht zum Einknicken zu bringen.
Das soll dieses Mal anders ausgehen.
Das merken wir uns. Mit einem Vergleich möchte man dem eigentlichen Richterspruch entgehen.
Ein Vergleich heißt kein Urteil. Die Monate, die man nicht gearbeitet hat,
werden nicht im Nachhinein ausgeglichen.
Man hat das Urteil, wo das dann ...
Beziehungsweise das ist Teil des Vergleichs dann.
Hat man mit reingeschrieben.
Wir gucken jetzt mal, man glaubt gar nicht, wir hatten ja mehrmals hier schon
diese Gespräche und deswegen fand ich es auch mal so besonders interessant,
weil ich ja auch immer so denke, wie verstehe ich die Welt nicht mehr,
so volkswirtschaftlich ist es doch verrückt. Also wir haben jetzt...
Kaum Arbeitslosigkeit und ganz viel Fachkräftemangel.
Nicht nur Fachkräftemangel, sondern generell Personalmangel und dennoch gehen
die Löhne ja nicht nach oben.
Das können wir interessanterweise feststellen und das ist ja eigentlich verrückt,
denn sonst weiß man ja, wenn was knapp wird, dann steigen die Preise,
aber die Preise für Arbeitskräfte steigen merkwürdigerweise nicht.
Und ich konnte mir das nie so richtig erklären.
Aber es liegt wohl daran, wie wir jetzt im Folgenden sehen werden,
dass die Arbeiterschaft so schlecht organisiert ist, so wenig Chancen hat,
auf höhere Löhne zu klagen, dafür zu streiken, was auch immer sich einzusetzen,
dass das deshalb ausbleibt.
Denn eigentlich wäre ja klar, dass alles in die Richtung geht.
Und dass von der Unternehmerseite man offenbar bereit ist, große Summen in die
Hand zu nehmen, um es zu verhindern, dass die Lage an sich für alle besser wird.
Und das werden wir jetzt gleich vorgestellt bekommen. Erst mal ein Ausdruck
aus einer Studie von der Böckler Stiftung.
Die gewerkschaftsnahe Hans-Böckler-Stiftung schreibt in einer Studie,
dass 2010 noch 44 Prozent aller Beschäftigten in Betrieben mit Betriebsrat beschäftigt waren.
Dies galt im Jahr 2022 nur noch für 39 Prozent in Westdeutschland und sogar
nur noch für 34 Prozent der Betriebe in Ostdeutschland.
Betriebsräte sind also auf dem Rückzug.
Footlocker hat auch noch gar nicht so lange einen Betriebsrat.
Die Beschäftigten im Store in der Townsdienstraße gründen 2016 den ersten Betriebsrat
von Footlocker in Deutschland.
Murat ist da am Anfang noch nicht mit dabei. Er arbeitet damals in einem anderen
Store, hält aber Kontakt zu den KollegInnen in der Taunzienstraße, z.B. zu Armin.
Sie wollen, dass auch Murat aktiv wird.
Und so gründet Murat auch in seiner Filiale einen Betriebsrat.
Später wird er sogar zum Gesamtbetriebsratsvorsitzenden der Betriebsräte aller
Footlocker-Stores in Deutschland gewählt.
Sie feiern erste Erfolge, verhindern unter anderem eine neue Überstundenregelung,
die viele Beschäftigte gestört hat.
Diese Kalkulationen sind natürlich wahnwitzig, wenn man das sich aus Beraterperspektive
anschaut. Weil wenn du so ein Unternehmen wie Footlogger hast mit verschiedenen
Filialen, ist ja der Haupt-Quarter-Leitung,
sehr.
Daran gelegen, dass so ein Wissenstransfer stattfindet. Wir machen irgendwie
eine neue Filiale auf, die soll aber so funktionieren wie die anderen,
damit der Kunde nicht überrascht ist, wenn er plötzlich auftaucht.
Also müssen die irgendwie Kontakt miteinander aufnehmen, wie man das verkauft.
Gleichzeitig will man verhindern, dass die Kontakt aufnehmen,
um sich dann auch noch ihre Organisationsgrade und so hoch zu jubeln.
Und das läuft aber alles unter so einer Profitlogik, also im Sinne von Markus Gabriel,
dass man von Unternehmensseite aus, gerade in größeren Unternehmen,
ich habe das damals, als ich im Rahmen der IG Metall so ein bisschen unterwegs
war, bei den Autoherstellern erlebt,
dass die Autohersteller nichts dagegen tun können, dass ihre Belegschaften organisiert
sind, weil das da richtig tradiert ist.
Also da kommst du ja rein und wirst erst mal direkt eingeladen und so,
aber während der Betriebsrat so und so ein Budget hat, um seine Betriebsrat-Tage,
und was auch immer da seine Wahlen zu veranstalten, da kommt natürlich dann
das Unternehmen und sagt, wir laden zum Sommerfest ein.
Das Sommerfest ist dann doppelt so teuer, sage ich mal, was Bewirtung und Show
auf der Bühne und so weiter angeht.
Und da läuft aber das politische Programm des Managements gleich mit,
inklusive irgendwelchen informalen Abwerbeprojekten im Sinne von,
ich weiß, Sie haben nächste Woche diese Betriebsratssitzung,
aber es gäbe auch die eine Tagung in Dubai.
Wir wissen nicht, wen wir da hinschicken können. Haben Sie da vielleicht Zeit?
So ungefähr. Also, dass man das so richtig zerstört einfach.
Und da sind wir auf einem ganz hohen Niveau. Also, die haben ein tolles Standing.
Und da ist Geld vorhanden. Hier ist das natürlich ganz prekär.
Und so sind auch die Kämpfe, die da geführt werden müssen, wirklich,
welche die ganz unten stehen finden.
Und wenn die dann mal einen juristischen Kampf führen, preisen die das in ihre Profitlogik ein.
Die wissen, das wird für uns nicht gut ausgehen. Aber wenn wir das Urteil auf
in sieben Monaten statt auf in drei Monaten strecken können,
haben wir schon Erfolg, weil wir dann sieben Monate intern so eine Unzufriedenheit,
eine Unsicherheit haben.
Und dann wieder der Wissenstransfer zurück.
Die anderen Filialen sehen dann auch, was da los ist und überlegen sich umso
mehr, Also innerhalb der Belegschaft, wie weit sie es denn treiben wollen,
mit ihren Betriebsratsforderungen und was auch immer.
Also eigentlich ist das alles Urkapitalismus.
Das ist Urkapitalismus, ja.
Hier könnte man wirklich nur von außen, also wenn selbst der juristische Weg,
der Rechtsweg schon missbraucht wird.
Also ich sag's in Anführungszeichen, weil da nämlich eine Kopplung stattfindet,
wie Gerz Gobel, ja hat der Luhmann das übersehen, dass da gar nicht gekoppelt
wird? Doch, natürlich koppeln die.
Die lassen sich, die nutzen den Rechtsweg instrumentell für ihre eigene Rationalität,
nämlich die Profitlogik.
Und die zahlt sich dann aus, auch wenn wir dann hören, ah, sie haben vor Gericht verloren.
Ja, aber sieben Monate lang hat der Typ keinen Lohn gekriegt,
die haben sieben Monate lang Stress gehabt, intern und so weiter und so fort.
Das ist ein bisschen wie beim Bürgergeld.
Da läuft ja auch immer so eine informale Linie mit.
Abseits des finanziellen Stresses.
So richtig fad nimmt die Auseinandersetzung zwischen Footlocker und dem Betriebsrat im Jahr 2020 auf.
Die Corona-Pandemie und die verordneten Schließungen belasten alle.
Der Streit entzündet sich dann aber an einer vermeintlichen Kleinigkeit.
Es geht um die Mitarbeiter-Toilette im Store in der Taunzienstraße, wo Armin arbeitet.
Lange Zeit mussten die Mitarbeiter die Toilette selbst selbst putzen,
bis der Betriebsrat gegenüber Footlocker durchsetzte, dass das eine externe
Reinigungskraft macht.
Doch die kommt im Herbst 2020 auf einmal nicht mehr, erinnert sich Armin.
Dann geht das immer so weiter. Man lässt die da verwahrlosen.
Irgendwann sagen die, dann können wir nicht mehr arbeiten, dann können wir keine Dienstpläne machen.
Footlocker lenkt aber nicht ein, sondern macht immer fröhlich weiter.
Dann gibt es eine E-Mail.
Footlocker droht in einer Mail an die Beschäftigten in der Taunzinstraße binnen
weniger Tage die Gehälter einzufrieren.
Leider sind wir wegen des Grundsatzes ohne Arbeit kein Lohn gezwungen,
eure Gehälter ab dem 16.11. nicht mehr zu zahlen.
Da sehen wir auch, wie das Machtverhältnis ist.
Ja, das Footlocker-Management sieht natürlich auch, dass in anderen Branchen
einfach so ein, wie heißt das hier, wenn der Staat die Gehälter übernimmt, Null und so.
Die wollen natürlich auch diese Profite. Vielleicht kann man es auch mal so
rekoppeln, dass der deutsche Staat über dem Bundestag sich 60 Milliarden mehr
für die Corona-Pandemie bewilligte, als sie dann wirklich brauchten.
Kann ja auch ein Hinweis darauf sein, wie die politische Entscheidungsfindung
ablief, unter der Bedingung ganz schön viel Lobbyismus von Leuten,
die sagen, hier liegt gerade alles da nieder, wir brauchen Geld und zwar ganz viel.
Also da haben wahrscheinlich alle Unternehmen mal so ein bisschen geguckt,
wie sie es zusammenschleichen, welche Bedarfe es sind.
Es sind also Kämpfe um ganz kleine Dinge. Wenn wir über Arbeitskampf reden,
dann reden wir über ganz kleine, mühsame Schritte.
Da fliegen wir nicht hoch oben in Luzern mit Markus Gabriel über die große Transformation
und irgendwie die Glückseligkeit,
sondern hier ist die Glückseligkeit schon ein bisschen weiter gekommen,
wenn man eine Reinigungskraft wieder für die Toilette hat.
Und wir hören jetzt mal von der Studie, wie das eigentlich so läuft.
Also wir haben ja immer noch jetzt im Hintergrund, also dieser Armin,
der hat da diesen Prozess am Laufen, der wurde gekündigt und der klagt ja jetzt
auf Wiedereinstellungen und dass das alles nicht rechtens war.
Aber wir hören erst mal diese Studie.
Sehr direkte und konfrontative Maßnahmen wie die Kündigung von Betriebsratskandidaten
erwiesen sich als weit verbreitet.
Betriebliche Strukturveränderungen als Maßnahme gegen eine Betriebsratswahl
kommen zwar vergleichsweise selten vor,
dennoch ist bemerkenswert, dass Arbeitgeber selbst vor einer gezielten Reorganisation
oder Aufspaltung des Betriebs oder gar der Schließung bzw.
Der Verlagerung des Betriebs nicht zurückschrecken.
172 Geschäftsstellen haben dem WSI auf ihre Fragen geantwortet.
84 Arbeitgeber hätten laut der Studie ihren Betriebsräten gekündigt.
Also da ist etwas ganz Großes im Argen. Und wir hören jetzt auch,
da gibt es die ganze Zeit Trouble.
Da wollen die eine Reinigungskraft haben. Da haben die noch was für ihre Überstunden rausgeholt.
Oder dass sie nicht so viele Überstunden machen müssen. Und jetzt haben wir
gehört, da es gibt nur so ein paar Betriebsräte bei Footlocker und wenn das
jetzt 90 Betriebsräte waren, kann man das ja schon mal so hochrechnen,
wenn die jetzt alle sagen,
wir wollen anders die Überstunden geregelt haben.
Und was macht man jetzt in diesem gallischen Dorf dort, in dieser einen Footlocker-Filiale?
Na, man macht den Laden dicht.
Wieder ist es eine Mail, die für Unruhe unter den Beschäftigten sorgt.
Adressiert ist sie an den Betriebsrat. Wie eben mit Murat besprochen,
übersende ich euch per E-Mail die unternehmerische Entscheidung der Schließung,
der Food-Locker-Filiale 3255,
Tauenzienstraße.
Den Gesamtbetriebsrat werde ich heute im Laufe des Tages ebenso informieren
und die nächsten Schritte zu den Beratungen mit dem Betriebsrat für einen Interessenausgleich
und Sozialplan einleiten.
Markus Gabriel, alles eingepreist. Wir können auch mal dicht machen und bauen
irgendwo anders wieder neues Geschäft auf und das tun sie ja dann auch und zwar paar Meter weiter.
Genau, man kann auch gerne mal dicht machen, wie wir das machen.
Ich kündige erstmal mein Zeitungsabo, weil ich genau weiß, habe ich erstmal
gekündigt, kriege ich andere Angebote, als wenn es um die Verlängerung geht.
Und so kann man auch einzelne Filialen einfach mal zur Disposition stellen,
was super schwierig ist für die Gewerkschaften, weil du ja nicht in eine Management-Entscheidung,
eingreifen oder gar sie nur kritisieren darfst.
Du darfst dich nur für die Angestellten einsetzen.
Und wenn die sagen, wir schließen jetzt die Filiale, ja, dann hast du erst mal
keine Belegschaft mehr da, für die du irgendwas machen kannst.
Und einfach nur die Ankündigung, was weiß ich, am 15. August,
wir schließen zum Ende des Jahres.
Damit hast du für ein Vierteljahr einfach Schachmatt gesetzt. Für ein Dritteljahr so.
Wir sind jetzt bei einem weiteren Gerichtstermin von Armin nach einigen Monaten.
Diesmal ist Armin mit seinem Anwalt und uns alleine vor Gericht.
Die Verhandlung dauert länger als geplant.
Es geht hin und her zwischen dem Anwalt von Furtlocker und Amins Anwalt von Verdi.
Amin selbst sagt, wie unglücklich er darüber sei, dass man sich hier nun vor
Gerichten streiten müsse, was er zu welcher Uhrzeit an welchem Tag genau gemacht habe.
Dass man alles hätte doch klären können.
Seine Stimme wird brüchig.
Der Richter hört genau zu und fragt ihn.
In Richtung Footlocker sagt er mit strenger Stimme, es sei Aufgabe des Arbeitgebers,
die Arbeitszeit zu erfassen.
Und lässt durchblicken, dass Footlocker bei einem Urteil Amins Kündigung wohl
wieder zurücknehmen müsste.
Und dann fragt der Richter, ob denn auch ein Vergleich möglich wäre.
Und dieser Vergleich, das ist etwas, was man strukturell immer wieder findet, sagt eine Expertin.
Jessica Reisner vom Verein gegen Arbeitsunrecht beobachtet seit vielen Jahren,
wie engagierte Betriebsräte abgefunden werden.
Sie hinterlassen absolut verbrannte Erde.
In der Belegschaft kann zurecht danach der Mythos gefahren werden,
seht ihr, die wollen nur ihren Hintern in Sicherheit bringen,
sich finanziell absichern, die wollen sich bereichern.
In diesen Betrieben ist, glaube ich, auf Jahre kein guter Boden mehr für weitere
Betriebsratsgründungen.
Also wir haben Rechtsbereiche, in denen es absolut essentiell finde ich,
auf so Vergleiche und Mediationen abzustellen, Familienrecht oder sowas, ne?
Bei sowas würde ich sagen, und auch beim Finanzgericht, einmal vor Gericht muss es ein Urteil geben.
Ich würde ein Vergleichsverbot einfach machen.
Ja, ja.
Weil diese Finanzämter, die Ämter, hier diese Arbeitgeber, die ziehen sich einfach zurück.
Für die ist es ja wirklich nur so ein Kostenposten. Okay, dann führen wir jetzt
halt einen Rechtsstreit.
Management hat genehmigt, zack, und dann ist es Aufgabe der Anwälte.
Während die anderen so mit Fleisch und Blut davor sitzen.
Klar, die sind zermürbt nach Monaten kein Gehalt und dann bekommen die auch
mal so von den anderen schon so angedeutet, naja, so wie du willst du das vergleichen.
Und ein Vergleich hat so sachlich toll, dass es auch sein kann, es hat immer Nachteile.
Ja.
Schon allein, weil du keinen Rechtsfrieden hast im Sinne von,
wenn es vor Gericht ist und du hast ein Urteil, gilt das immer als Präzedenz.
Selbst wenn du nicht so ein Rechtssystem hast, das so funktioniert,
das Urteil wird halt publiziert in irgendwelchen special interest,
Dann liest man das so nach und sagt, bezieht sich dann darauf und so weiter und so fort.
Das kannst du bei Vergleichen nicht, schon allein, weil die alle geheim sind.
Dann ist einfach diese Kostenübernahme für die Anwaltskosten,
also klar in dem Fall zahlt das dann Verdi, aber ich finde auch Verdi hat da einen Anspruch drauf.
Wenn ein Urteil im negativen Sinne, dann muss halt einfach der Arbeitgeber alle Kosten bezahlen.
So, jetzt bleibt einfach jeder auf seinen Kosten sitzen und so.
Das ist, dieser Vergleichs, das ist nicht gut.
Und wir haben anfangs, also das ist wirklich toll, dieses Feature,
weil das die über zwei Jahre lang begleitet hat, also das gibt es ja auch nicht häufig.
Und wir haben jetzt am Anfang ja Murat, der nur so als Begleiter mitkam und
nun taucht Murat wieder auf.
Inzwischen befindet sich auch Murat in einem Rechtsstreit mit Footlocker.
Ein paar Wochen vor der Gerichtsverhandlung von Armin kommt heraus,
dass Futtlocker versucht, auch ihn loszuwerden.
Auch hier der Vorwurf, Arbeitszeitbetrug, wie bei Armin.
Ja, was ist da los?
Futtlocker hat ihm auch einen Teil seines Gehalts nicht gezahlt. Mehr als 4.000 Euro.
Ich bin froh, dass ich meine Familie und Freunde habe, die mich finanziell unterstützt haben.
Trotzdem konnte ich meinen Kredit nicht zahlen, meine Schufa ist schlechter
geworden, gesundheitlich gesehen. nervliche Belastung, mein Auge zuckt nonstop,
Magenschwür hatte ich gehabt, schlaflose Nächte an der Tagesordnung.
Also ich kann vormorgens drei, vier Uhr nicht schlafen.
Und so geht das weiter? Das ist der Arbeitskampf?
Hier kann man auch nochmal diese von uns vorhin so große Kritik,
wie geht die ganze klimapolitische Bewegung und so weiter damit um?
Das ist halt, wenn es man mit Subjekten zu tun hat.
Also wenn die nicht einfach das, was wir den Unternehmen vorwerfen,
da werden einfach so Kostenposten abgerechnet und dann übersieht man einfach,
dass es da ja um Menschen geht in dieser Tabellenspalte sozusagen.
Dass einfach nur Objekte abgerechnet
werden. Das ist im Grunde der große Fehler dieser Klimapolitik.
Dass sie einfach den großen Umbau und dann machen die Arbeiter,
wir müssen neue Maschinen und neue Arbeiter, so ungefähr. Oder einfach beides gleichgesetzt.
Nur die einen haben halt Gefühle und Bedürfnisse und denen zockt dann das Auge und das ist nicht gut.
Und dass das Subjekte sind, das sollte man überall wieder mehr ernst nehmen.
Und auch Murat muss dann vor Gericht.
Kurzer Schlagabtausch zwischen den Anwälten und dann die Frage des Richters nach einem Vergleich.
Der Footlocker könnte sich einen vorstellen. Murat zögert, nickt dann aber auch.
Nur über die Höhe gibt es keine Einigung. Der Richter appelliert an beide Seiten.
Die Verhandlung wird unterbrochen. Murat berät sich mit seinem Anwalt.
Der Footlocker-Anwalt meint, er müsste noch mal telefonieren.
Das Budget sei ausverhandelt.
Noch eine Unterbrechung, bevor es weitergeht. Ein langes Schweigen und dann
die Einigung. Ein Monatsgehalt für jedes Jahr seiner Betriebszugehörigkeit mal 1,3.
Damit sind auch die ausstehenden Gehaltszahlungen abgegolten.
1,3 ist ein vergleichsweise hoher Faktor bei solchen Einigungen.
Das passt zu unserem Eindruck im Gerichtssaal. Bei einem Richterspruch wäre
Futtlocker mit der Kündigung von Murat nicht durchgekommen.
D.h., auch die haben es wieder eingepreist. Und der Preis war es offenbar wert.
Denn auch hier wieder, wenn das die Runde macht, erst in Deutschland,
dann vielleicht noch in überall andere Länder hinaus, Footlocker ist ein Konzern,
dann hätte Footlocker ein großes Problem.
Und ich will ja nochmal ausdrücklich sagen, dieses Feature müsst ihr alle hören.
Und damit ihr das auch alle hört, habe ich jetzt noch einen Cliffhanger mitgebracht.
Und zwar treffen Nina Scholz und Sebastian Friedrich Murat und Armin noch mal wieder,
nachdem das so alles gelaufen ist, da über diese zwei Jahre.
Und dann geht es noch mal so.
Während der ganzen Recherche haben wir uns immer gefragt, warum eigentlich Armin
als Erster eine Kündigung erhalten hat und nicht etwa Murat als Gesamtbetriebsratsvorsitzender.
War es nur wegen seiner Betriebsratsarbeit oder ein paar ungeputzter Toiletten?
Diese Frage wird dann in dem Feature beantwortet und man staunt darüber.
Aber in gewisser Weise hat Stefan schon die Fährte heute richtig aufgenommen
gehabt, aber mehr verraten wir jetzt wirklich nicht.
Wir springen weiter zur sozialen Situation von Studierenden.
Denen geht es nämlich auch super. Wir hören hier vom Studierendenwerk jemanden,
der warnt nämlich vor den Krediten.
Können Sie uns erstmal einen Überblick geben, für wen ist so ein KfW-Studienkredit,
eigentlich was und welche Studierenden beanspruchen den?
Ja, ich wünsche, ich könnte jetzt antworten, eigentlich für niemanden.
Wir warnen als Deutsches Studierendenwerk ganz explizit, dass vor einem Studium
ausschließlich über einen Studienkredit
zu finanzieren, weil einfach die Verschuldungsgefahr viel zu hoch ist.
Derzeit beanspruchen wohl, wahrscheinlich ein geringer Prozentsatz von Studierenden
beanspruchen den KfW-Studienkredit oder haben schon einen abgeschlossen.
Und er ist eigentlich sowas wie das letzte Mittel, wenn alle anderen Optionen
der Studienfinanzierung die wichtigsten sind.
Elternunterhalt, Nebenjob, leider jetzt sehr viel weniger BAföG,
wenn all diese anderen Optionen nicht greifen.
Und er sollte eigentlich nur in so Phasen im Studium überhaupt ja in Betracht
gezogen werden, in denen nichts anderes geht, vielleicht vorm Abschluss oder
wenn man ein Auslandsstudium finanzieren will.
Ich kenne jemanden, der einen solchen Studienkredit hat. Kennst du jemanden?
Persönlich meinst du?
Ja, persönlich. Und der hat einen aufgenommen, 5000 Euro.
Bei 9% über 10 Jahre, wie viel ist das dann?
So und der hat den aber aufgenommen, als das noch bei einem oder bei 1,5 Prozent
lag und der bekam dann jetzt ein Schreiben und der soll jetzt einen Abtrag zahlen von,
also der Abtrag ist so, dass 45 Euro pro Monat gehen allein für die Zinskosten drauf.
Aber wurde das nochmal nachträglich geändert, die Zinsbelastung?
Ja die steigt ja dann mit.
Mit dem laufenden Vertrag?
Also üblicherweise unterschreibt man ja Verträge.
Das war nicht im Pest geschrieben.
Ach du großer Gott.
Ja, das geht jetzt ganz vielen so. Diese Studentenkredite sind ein Riesenproblem
und deshalb hat es auch...
Aber ich dachte nur wegen diesen hohen Zinssätzen, dass die Zinsen pro laufenden,
also in den laufenden Verträgen noch nachträglich plötzlich von 1 auf 8 Prozent springen können.
Ja, die gehen mit.
Oh Gott.
Ich weiß nicht, also nicht bei allen wird das so sein.
Das ist dann immer wahrscheinlich die Frage, was man so festlegt und wie schnell
man sich da irgendwie bindet oder nicht.
Das ist eigentlich der, also wirklich der ultimative Treppenwitz,
dass du den Leuten sagst, nur Bildung kann dir eine Perspektive im Leben geben
und der Bildungskritik nimmt dir, Kredit nimmt dir genau die Perspektive.
Ja überleg doch mal, wenn du 5.000 Euro Kredit hast, das ist ja jetzt nicht
so viel Geld, 5.000 Euro musst du zurückzahlen und du hast aber 10% Zinsen,
dann heißt das, du musst jeden Monat,
musst,
du
dann 45 Euro nur für die Zinsen zahlen.
Ja, also ich empfehle für sowas das neue Chat-GPT Turbo.
Hat ja jetzt diese ganzen Plug-ins und so weiter. WolframAlpha ist dabei,
macht ja 1A diese ganzen und mach mir noch einen Graph davon und so weiter und so fort.
Man kann jetzt, wie kompliziert auch immer seine eigenen Kalkulationen sind, die einfach GPT geben.
Und dann sieht man seine eigene Perspektive. Man ist nicht mehr den Beratern
ausgeliefert, die einem irgendwas vorrechnen, sondern man kann es noch mal richtig
sich erklären lassen und so weiter und so fort. Das sollte man hier ganz dringend
machen bei solchen Sachen.
Du erwähnst ja immer wieder die Vermieter. Da habe ich auch eine schöne Zahl
hier vor dem Statistischen Bundesamt 2021.
Studierende, die allein oder in Studierenden-WGs lebten, mussten im Schnitt 51,1.
Prozent ihres verfügbaren Einkommens für die Wohnkosten aufbringen.
51, ja. durchschnittlich. Alle Studierenden 31,6,
Prozent. Klar dann leben da manche daheim oder so.
Liegt die Wohnkostenbelastung auch nach Abzug möglicherweise erhaltener wohnbezogener
Transferleistung noch bei mehr als 40 Prozent, gelten Haushalte als überbelastet?
Im vergangenen Jahr lebte knapp ein Viertel der Studierenden in Haushalten, auf die das zutraf.
Wenn man sich ansieht, was Azubis verdienen, dann muss man auch sagen,
wie kann das eigentlich sein?
Also hier am meisten verdient man, zumindest jetzt hier in dieser Auflistung
von 22 im Gesundheits- und Pflegebereich.
Da sind das Bruttomonatsverdienste von 1139 Euro.
Dann kommt die Luftfahrt und die Schifffahrt und so weiter.
Und das geht dann rüber mit Handwerksberufe 901 Euro.
Und in keinem der jetzt genannten Bereiche entspricht der Bruttoverdienst der
eigentlich festgelegten Nettoeinkommensgrenze,
die man also braucht, um nicht arm zu sein.
Also es ist, wir haben wirklich einfach so gesagt,
junge Leute sind ganz wichtig, dass die ganz wichtige große Ausbildungen machen,
dass die als Fachkräfte bald zur Verfügung stehen, aber die sollen bitte während
dieser Zeit in Armut leben.
Da würde ich sagen, mal das Bürgergeld öffnen.
Warum nur aufstocken, wenn der...
Ja, die bekommen ja weniger, dazu kommen wir gleich.
Also es gab wieder so eine tolle Stunde in Mannheim, Bürger im Dialog mit dem Bundeskanzler.
Hier meldet sich ein Student zu Wort.
Guten Abend, Herr Bundeskanzler. Mein Name ist Ramaphom Gesell und ich studiere
Politikwissenschaft an der Universität Mannheim.
Und wir hatten ja jetzt Corona, die Mietpreise sind explodiert,
Der Lebensunterhalt ist fast nicht zahlbar für einen Studenten,
obwohl wir auch arbeiten gehen.
Und da bleibt es eigentlich nur noch übrig, BAföG zu nehmen,
wo nur 11 Prozent der Studenten überhaupt berechtigt dazu sind und was sie auch
kürzen wollen mit der Bundesregierung und einen KfW-Kredit.
Und da sind die Zinsen in den letzten 18 Monaten von 3,7 Prozent auf knapp 9 Prozent gestiegen.
Der KfW-Kredit von der staatlichen Bank ist, den Sie kontrollieren könnten,
auch den Zinssatz, könnte zu einer Schuldenfalle für viele Studenten werden.
Was sagen Sie dazu und können Sie das nicht beeinflussen?
Der Kanzler redet jetzt drei Minuten darüber, dass Sie eigentlich das BAföG-Jahr,
nicht kürzen und schiebt das dann alles hin und her.
Ich habe die Antwort mal zusammengekürzt, um an die zweite Antwort zu gelangen
beziehungsweise zur Antwort zur zweiten Frage. Was ist dann jetzt mit diesen
hohen Zinsen auf die Kredite?
Natürlich jetzt auch diesen Kredit, dessen aktuelle Höhe mir nicht bekannt ist.
Die Zahl, die sie mir da gesagt haben, irritiert mich auch.
Ich gucke mal, ob es so ist und wenn es so ist, werde ich mich dem Thema mal widmen.
Ja, seitdem ist ein Monat vergangen, nichts geschehen. So viel auch dazu,
dass wir so glücklich darüber sein können, dass so viele Junge im Bundestag sind.
Also das sind ja alles Leute, Kevin Kühnert oder Emilia Fester und wie diese Leutchen alle heißen,
müssen ja Leute kennen, die davon betroffen sind. Das kann ja nicht sein,
die sind ja noch nicht so abgehoben, dass die nur noch mit Thomas Gottschalk
hin und her fliegen oder so, ja.
Das kann doch gar nicht sein, dass das nicht von denen auf die Agenda gesetzt
wird. Wofür sind die denn eigentlich da?
Also wenn ich junge Politiker sehe und mit jungen meine ich ja inzwischen unter
40, also das ist ja, ist ja in Deutschland jung, ja.
Wenn ich die sehe, dann habe ich, wenn die da im Bundestag sind und ihre Videos
drehen, also ich habe immer den Eindruck,
dass die gar nicht als Politiker dort sind, sondern das ist wie man so mit dem
Sozialkundeunterricht mal dahin fährt und sich das mal anguckt.
Also die verhalten sich eigentlich wie Externe.
Und die reden ja zum Teil auch dann so, dass die dann irgendwas im Bundestag
sagen, Wo man eigentlich antworten müsste, ja, aber du bist doch hier Teil des Ganzen.
Das ist doch, wem sagst du das da draußen, sagt es hier zu dir.
Und das ist interessant, dass so diese jungen Leute nur so als Schaulustige
dort unterwegs sind, aber offenbar gar nicht wissen, dass sie jetzt auch regieren müssten.
Was ich an dem Clip so interessant finde, ist, dass wir mit Olaf Scholz jemanden
haben, der ja immer Erinnerungslücken hat, wenn es richtig brenzlig wird.
Wenn es so halb brenzlig ist, wie so ein Schuldenurteil oder was auch immer.
Ihm zerfliegt eigentlich der ganze Laden, dann ist das so ein scholziges Grinsen.
Er sagt nichts, aber möchte uns vermitteln.
Ich durchschaue es, ich habe es im Blick. Bitte beruhigen Sie sich.
Es ist alles in trockenen Tüchern. Wenn Olaf Scholz hier sagt.
Also richtig eingesteht, ich wusste das nicht, ich habe davon keine Ahnung,
ich habe das nicht gesehen.
Dann heißt das wirklich, der komplette Berliner Politikbetrieb und der Journalismus
außen drum rum ist blind für dieses Thema.
Und selbst wenn jemand wie Olaf Scholz, der nichts, nirgendwo jemals eingesteht,
insbesondere nicht Unwissen, wenn der das offen sagen, also wenn er sich traut,
das offen zu sagen, weiß er auch, da droht mir auch keine Gefahr.
Hier kommt jetzt kein Journalist und sagt, wie das wussten sie nicht?
Es betrifft doch irgendwie 2, und so weiter Millionen Studenten potenziell.
Wir wollen doch deren Bildung fördern und so.
Und das finde ich wirklich sehr bezeichnend.
Wir gehen mal zum BAföG Problem über.
Was diese Misere, über die wir sprechen, eben auch zeigt, ist,
wie wichtig es ist, dass jetzt eine BAföG-Reform kommt, eine BAföG-Reform,
bei der eben die Zahl der anspruchsberechtigten Studierenden,
die überhaupt BAföG bekommen können, wieder erhöht wird. Derzeit sind es 11 Prozent.
Die Bundesregierung hat selbst auch im Koalitionsvertrag gesagt,
nein, wir wollen, dass das wieder viel mehr werden. Wir wollen eine Trendwende.
Und das wäre enorm wichtig, dass eben jetzt dann individuell auf der Ebene muss
man gucken, Was kann ich sonst noch tun?
Aber auch strukturell muss bei der staatlichen Studienfinanzierung das BAföG
unbedingt gestärkt werden, damit eben nicht Studierende überhaupt erst in so
eine Verschuldungsverfahr geraten.
Ist ein bisschen gemein, aber rate doch mal, wie viel gibt der Staat in etwa
für das BAföG im Jahr aus für Schüler und Studenten?
Na, wenn 11 Prozent von zweieinhalb Millionen sind es ja schon 200.000 Leute,
die sagen wir mal 4000 Euro im Jahr kriegen,
also es müssten ja schon 200.000 mal 4.080.
Millionen,
oder,
sowas.
Nee, warte, lass es, lass es genau rechnen. Nee, nee, nee, nee,
warte, warte. Ich muss Siri fragen.
Ja, ich kann es dir auch verraten.
Wer, wer, sag mal.
Also es sind 2,98 Milliarden, also knapp 3 Milliarden.
Kennen wir die Bedarfe?
Für Studierende lag der durchschnittliche monatliche Förderbeitrag bei 611 Euro.
Und die geförderten Personen sind knapp 490.000.
490.000?
Ja, es gibt 2,9,
Millionen Studierende, aber nur 490.000 bekommen,
überhaupt BAföG.
Und nur die Hälfte von denen, die BAföG bekommt, bekommt auch den Höchstsatz.
Naja, gut. Also ich hatte mein Handy schon gezückt, um das nochmal nachzurechnen,
denn ich kann so wenig wie GPT von Text auf Mathemodus umschalten,
aber meine Herangehensweise aufgrund der Recherchen zur alten Republik sind,
dieses BAföG für Leute, die kein BAföG Anspruch haben, heißt das ja in dem Moment,
wo sie eigentlich ins eigene Leben starten, werden sie nochmal in besonderer
Weise auf die Eltern zurückgeworfen.
Und das ist ein echtes Problem, was man gar nicht in Geld nur ausdrücken kann,
sondern grundsätzlich in der Herangehensweise, wie studiere ich denn jetzt.
Weil plötzlich kommen dann die Eltern, die sagen, ich bezahle ja dein Studium
und entscheiden so mit, wie man, was man, wo man studiert.
Und um das zu durchbrechen, müsste man eigentlich eine prinzipielle Schranke
einführen und sagen, jeder, der sich für ein Studium entscheidet,
hat einen Anspruch darauf, sich dann da auszustatten finanziell.
Man kriegt dann keine Ahnung, was der Bar für Quizsatz ist, aber so von diesen
800 Euro ausgehend irgendwie oder was auch immer.
Mit der Ansage Du sammelst aber nicht mehr Schulden als 10.000 Euro insgesamt auf.
Solange du Regelstudienzeit und so weiter einhältst und so, das wäre eigentlich,
das wäre mal eine richtig gute Entkopplung auch des ganzen kognitiven Apparats im Kopf.
Kenne ich auch noch einen Fall aus der Vergangenheit von jemand,
der von den Eltern abhängig war, also kein BAföG erhalten konnte,
aber das Verhältnis zu den Eltern war sehr schlecht.
Ja, genau. Wodurch dann so Verbindlichkeiten entstehen, die man eigentlich dann
als junger Mensch gar nicht mehr haben möchte.
Ja, du kannst auch ein gutes Verhältnis zu deinen Eltern haben und plötzlich
kommst du mit dem Anspruch, sorry, ich will jetzt studieren und dann wird das Verhältnis schlecht.
Ja.
Oder es kann irgendwas passieren und wie auch immer.
Auch das kann passieren. Und im nächsten Jahr wird dann 400 Millionen weniger
für BAföG ausgegeben, weil man ja dann wieder diese, wer bekommt's und wer nicht.
Also ich finde halt die Summe so unglaublich klein. Also ich meine,
drei Milliarden, das ist doch so ein Kleckerbetrag, den Pistorius mitnimmt,
wenn er gerade in Kiew vorbeiläuft und sagt hier übrigens nochmal drei Milliarden obendrauf.
Also wir geben ja sonst mit vollen Händen aus.
Drei Milliarden, das ist ein Drittel von dem, was in manchen Budgets schon bewilligterweise
beim Wirtschaftsminister aufläuft, wo er einfach im Handstreich sagen kann, ja kriegt er.
Und dann kommt halt irgend so ein Typ und sagt, unser Saarstahl braucht jetzt
echt mal eine Unterstützung. Hier, zack, weg.
Gibt schon gar keine demokratische Entscheidung mehr darüber,
sondern ist alles schon pro forma gemacht.
Ja, also wenn man sieht, was Intel bekommt, das ist einfach so fast zehn Jahre
Bachwirk dann in Deutschland.
Ja, ich meine, Intel bekommt ja zweimal das ganze Forschungsvermögen der deutschen
Forschungsgesellschaft zum Beispiel, die für alle Universitäten zuständig sind.
Das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen.
Das ZDF hat sich dem Thema mal angenommen.
Selbst zu kochen ist seine große
Leidenschaft. Doch für die Zutaten fehlt Fabrice Eberle häufig das Geld.
Statt einkaufen zu gehen, holt sich der Student oft abends aussortierte Lebensmittel
aus Restaurants und Supermärkten.
Die Kartoffeln hatten schon so Triebe. Da kommen kleine Pömpelchen raus,
aber die schneidet man mit der Schale weg.
Dann Zwiebeln, eine Haarschlagsahne, die kostet auch nur 30 Cent.
Dann hast du mit drei Zutaten was, 50 Cent, vielleicht mit dem Öl so ein Euro.
Von dem Essen esse ich zwei, drei Tage abends. Dann tagsüber an der Mensa.
Man kommt gut über die Runden.
Jetzt hatte ich drei Monate, wo ich nicht mehr hungern musste.
Fabrice studiert in Düsseldorf Data Science und Künstliche Intelligenz.
Sein 1. Studium musste er aus gesundheitlichen Gründen abbrechen.
Jetzt hat er keinen Anspruch mehr auf BAföG.
Auch seine Eltern können ihn nicht unterstützen. Der Vater ist pflegebedürftig.
Deswegen hat er bei einer Bank ein Darlehen aufgenommen. Er rechnet zum Ende
des Studiums mit etwa 25.000 Euro Schulden.
Ich nehme jetzt gerade einen Kredit für 650 Euro im Monat auf,
damit ich hier meine Miete und ein paar Nebenkosten bezahlen kann.
Aber das über drei Jahre oder mit Master über fünf Jahre hinweg,
da sammelt sich natürlich eine Menge an.
Für die teurer gewordenen Strom- und Gasrechnungen reicht es schon nicht mehr.
Mh.
Ein weiterer Fall.
Unter Willy Brandt wurde 1971 das BAföG eingeführt. Studieren zu können,
sollte nicht länger vom Geldbeutel der Eltern abhängen.
In den Anfangsjahren Erhält fast die Hälfte der Studierenden BAföG.
Ab 1974 muss ein Teil des Geldes zurückgezahlt werden. Später wird es zum Folderlehen.
Die Zahl der Empfänger sackt ab.
Erst ab 1990 wird wieder die Hälfte des BAföGs als Zuschuss gewährt.
Die Zahl der Empfänger schwankt, bis sie in den vergangenen Jahren auf 11 % absackt.
Ein Grund dafür? Viele Studierende gehen lieber arbeiten als BAföG zu beantragen.
Aus Angst vor der Rückzahlung.
Ja, die kommen alle in die Schuldenfalle und dann ist es ja noch alles sehr
aufwendig, das zu genehmigen.
Es gibt da ja auch verrückte Geschichten, wenn man sich das dann so anhört,
dass die dann über Monate erstmal warten, bis es kommt und dann nochmal irgendwas einsenden.
Natürlich alles postalisch, nicht digital. Du kannst es dir vorstellen.
Und ja, so dann lieber mit Nebenjob.
Selbst mit BAföG bleibt Melissa auf ihren Job bei der Nachhilfe angewiesen.
Einen Nebenjob mit dem Studium zu vereinbaren, ist eine Herausforderung.
Ach ja, sie hat sogar BAföG und braucht noch einen Nebenjob.
Also auch das gibt es ja vielfach.
Studiengänge heute sind wesentlich regulierter und enger verplant als früher.
Es war so, dass ich vormittags meistens bis 13, 14 Uhr in der Uni war und dann
direkt von der Uni zum Arbeiten gefahren bin.
Als es dann in die Klausurenphase ging, wurde es schon eng von der Zeit her,
weil man gemerkt hat, es braucht viel Zeit zu lernen.
Und dann ging es halt von halb acht bis zehn noch mal in die Bibliothek zum
Lernen und dann heim essen und schlafen.
BAföG zu bekommen, dauert lange. Wenn es kommt, reicht es häufig nicht aus.
Weil deswegen viele nebenbei arbeiten müssen, verlängert sich auf das Studium.
Doch wer die Regelstudienzeit überschreitet, bekommt kein BAföG mehr.
Und so brechen nicht wenige kurz vor dem Abschluss ihr Studium ab.
Dabei hatte die Regierung mehr Geld versprochen.
Wir überspringen jetzt mal diese kleine Debatte ums Grunderbe.
Das wird sicherlich noch länger. Möchtest du das noch mal hören?
Ja, ich finde das für Sie sehr wichtig.
Das ist ja die einzige Idee, die uns da rätselt.
Die einzige Idee. Also in der SPD bei den Jusos gab es die Idee,
ein Grunderbe einzuführen und auch der, ich glaube Ostbeauftragte,
hat in ähnliche Richtung plädiert.
Wir hören jetzt mal kurz die Statements dazu von Monika Schnitzer.
Dann haben die Jusos eine Idee wieder hochgebracht, die es eigentlich schon
länger gibt, nämlich ein Grunderbe.
Mit 20 Jahren soll man zweckgebunden 60.000 Euro bekommen für Ausbildung oder Altersvorsorge.
Und jetzt mal abgesehen von den Summen, ist die Idee grundsätzlich...
Es hängt so stark vom Elternhaus ab, vom sozialen Background.
Welche Chancen ich habe? Das geht beim Bildungserfolg los.
Man schneidet besser in der Schule ab, wenn man von zu Hause aus besser unterstützt wird.
Und man hat mehr Bildung, beispielsweise Finanzbildung. Wie lege ich mein Geld an?
Und habe ich überhaupt Geld, was ich anlegen kann?
Jetzt versuchen wir, den Aufstieg zu ermöglichen, Indem wir einen Teil dieser
Ungleichheit ausgleichen, das halte ich für sehr vernünftig.
Also wir überlasten auf jeden Fall Familien damit, wie es gerade geregelt ist.
Denn wir hatten ja über Jahrzehnte diese Idee von, in der Jugend rebellisch
und sobald sie die Gelegenheit haben, auf und davon.
Und dann kommt man nach seinem Einstieg in sein eigenes Leben irgendwie zurück
und versöhnt sich wieder mit seinen Eltern und hat dann so ein gemeinsames,
keine Ahnung, wenn die Kinder dann da sind und so. dann kommen die Eltern über
die Großelternrolle wieder ins Gefüge.
Und diese Entkopplung gibt es ja gerade nicht mit wirklich vielen Folgen.
So was, persönliche Lebensplanung, Orientierung, für wen übernehme ich hier
eigentlich gerade die Verantwortung und so weiter.
Und dann haben wir ja dieses Sonderproblem, dass schon die Eltern heute,
wenn sie überhaupt noch Kinder bekommen haben, jetzt ja gerade wieder ein bisschen
mehr, relativ spät die Kinder bekommen.
Das heißt, man macht sich dann gerade vom Elternhaus los, wenn die eigenen Eltern
eigentlich einen schon wieder brauchen und so, steigen dann gerade ins Rentenalter
ein und alles kompliziert.
Und über so ein Grunderbe kann man, das sieht immer so aus wie nur so eine finanzielle
Angelegenheit, aber ist es echt nicht.
Sondern da kann man doch ganz schön viel machen. Ich würde hier auch wie Adam
Tewes gleich mal von Anfang an größer denken.
Also wie heißt er, der französische Superökonom? Piketty. Er hat ja gleich 100.000 Euro vorgelegt und so.
Fratscher diskutiert es ja ein bisschen kleiner und so weiter.
Da kommen diese 20.000 Euro.
Aber man muss, finde ich, mit der Volljährigkeit ins eigene Leben starten können.
Ohne die Eltern. Selbst wenn die Eltern genug Geld haben, um einen durchzukriegen,
muss man trotzdem in der Lage sein zu sagen, nö.
Einfach, also um das Geld ablehnen zu können und darüber hinaus dann andere
Ideen der Eltern auch von sich zu weisen, braucht man diese Unabhängigkeit.
Dieses Angebot muss zwingend da sein, sonst kommen wir hier echt noch in Teufelsküche.
Wir haben das ganz lange belächelt, dass irgendwie die Italiener ja nicht zu Hause ausziehen.
Und dann stellt man irgendwie fest, wie die Männer da so drauf sind,
wenn die mit 30 noch zu Hause wohnen und die Mutter, die immer noch die Bezugsperson
ist für alles, was wir so im eigenen Leben.
Also das ist wirklich, das ist alles nicht gut.
Von daher braucht man so einen ökonomisch groben Hobel, mit dem man mal in dieses Problem reingeht.
So, und das ist mit so einem Grunderbe ganz wunderbar zu managen.
Wenn wir tatsächlich so ein super geiles Land sind, beispielsweise haben wir
ja irgendwie den besten Staat ever.
Jedenfalls sagt mir die CDU immer, alle wollen hier nach Deutschland kommen.
Dann sollte Deutschland das auch mal zeigen, seinen eigenen,
beschäftigt, sage ich schon, der Deutschland AG, also seine eigene Bevölkerung,
wie viel Wert denn das Leben hier so ist.
Und wir haben ja gerade gesehen, faktisch, also nach drei Monaten,
jetzt mal drei Monate lang keinen Hunger gehabt, das erste Quartal ohne Hunger.
Das ist so die Bilanz Pressekonferenz dieses jungen Studenten.
In diesem Quartal habe ich keinen Hunger gehabt.
Erfolg. So. Das kann nicht die Bilanz Deutschlands sein, sondern hier müssen
wir andere Angebote machen.
Und wie gesagt 121 Milliarden Euro nehmen wir aus dem Bundeshaushalt und geben es den Alten.
Und bei den Jungen nehmen wir sogar die nicht existierende Kindergrundsicherung
schon wieder weg, bevor sie überhaupt in Amtsblatt erscheinen.
Und vergeben knapp drei Milliarden Migranten in den BAföG, aber unser Finanzminister sieht das anders.
Ich denke gerade an die immer wieder von links ins Gespräch gebrachte Idee eines
staatlichen Grunderbes, haben Sie das auch schon gelesen?
Jetzt vor einigen Tagen kam neu, ich glaube im Handelsblatt,
nochmal ein Beitrag, da prädierte jemand für ein Grunderbe.
20.000 Euro vom Staat für jeden, der volljährig wird.
20.000 Euro für je D und jeden 18-Jährigen vom Staat als Grunderbe.
Als Beitrag dazu, dass unsere Gesellschaft gerechter wird.
Und deshalb ist mein Vorschlag, kein 20.000 Euro Grunderbe am 18.
Geburtstag, sondern lieber staatliche Investitionen in die Bildung bis zum 18. Geburtstag.
Das eine schließt ja, wie wir wissen, das andere aus.
Das ist eine Frage der Ehre.
Wir hören ganz kurz Christoph Quarch, der ist auch Philosoph, aber etwas anderer Art.
Der wird hier im SWR dazu befragt.
Ist es gerecht, junge Menschen ohne Gegenleistung mit 20.000 Euro auszustatten?
Ich würde mal sagen, aus philosophischer Sicht, das ist ja nun mal meine,
spricht eigentlich nichts dagegen.
Wir Philosophen unterscheiden schon seit den Tagen des alten Aristoteles zwischen
proportionaler Gerechtigkeit und dann gibt es die distributive Gerechtigkeit.
Bei der einen, also bei der proportionalen Gerechtigkeit, der wird nach individuellen
Verdiensten verteilt, bei der anderen werden alle gleich behandelt.
Und die Frage ist immer, wo wird jetzt eigentlich welche Form der Gerechtigkeit
zur Anwendung gebracht? Bei dem Thema Grunderwerb scheint es mir jetzt wirklich
berechtigt zu sein, dass sie diese distributive Gerechtigkeit einzuwenden.
Das heißt also, alle die 18 werden, bekommen das gleiche Startkapital.
Ich glaube, das ist fair für die jungen Leute, aber auch für die älteren und
für die Senioren, weil es muss ja auch in deren Interesse sein,
dass die Gesellschaft eben nicht
aufgrund einer zunehmend ungleichen Vermögensverteilung auseinanderfällt.
Ja, wir müssen das immer aus zwei Seiten sehen. Wenn der jetzt einfach sagt,
dass sie unverdient dieses Geld bekommen.
Also diese Kinder, diese 18-Jährigen, waren zwölf Jahre in der Schule,
jeden Tag, sieben Stunden.
Und haben sich dort drangsaliert, nicht mit den Sachen, die sie gerne machen,
sondern mit denen, was wir von ihnen wollen.
Und das lassen wir die ganze Zeit laufen unter, ja, die haben ja dann später
was davon, nämlich einen Verdienst. Und dann haben wir aber gehört,
wie es Murat geht mit seinem Verdienst bei Foodlogger und so.
Diese Menschen würden ja, wenn sie ihren eigenen Neigungen nachgingen,
etwas anderes machen und dabei nicht sterben. Sie würden auch durchkommen.
Nur wir wollen halt was von denen. Nämlich, dass sie den Laden übernehmen und
beispielsweise die Renten finanzieren über ihre Lohnnebenkosten, wie man so schön sagt.
Niemand bekäme, wenn er es bis zum 20. Lebensjahr geschafft hat,
irgendetwas unverdient. Diese Denkweise ist wie ein bisschen von Campino.
Die können dann einmal im Leben auch mal ein Befehl bekommen.
Nachdem er die jeden Morgen um 7 Uhr aus dem Haus geschickt hat,
damit sie im öffentlichen Nahverkehr, weil sie dürfen ja nicht selber Auto fahren,
also durch die Hölle gegangen sind, um in der Schule anzukommen.
Und dort erleben das auch die Hälfte der Schüler als Hölle.
Und dann müssen die sich von dem Möchtegern Punk-Rocker, der seit Jahren nichts
richtiges gearbeitet hat, außer zu singen auf Bühnen, anhören lassen.
Ihr müsst auch mal zur Bundeswehr gehen und ich bin zwar selbst nicht gegangen,
aber jetzt, wo alle für den Krieg sind, finde ich Krieg auch toll.
Ja, man kann das auch so ein bisschen intertemporal denken. Zehn Jahre voraus,
jemand braucht eine Hilfe, beispielsweise eine regelmäßige Rentenzahlung oder
eine tatkräftige Hilfe von irgendwas, wie auch immer.
Und dann taucht ein Mensch auf, der diese Hilfe leistet. Ist es wirklich egal,
wo dessen Eltern, also ist es so wichtig, wo dessen Eltern herkamen?
Das blendet man, das ist vielleicht mal so nebenbei ein Thema im Sinne von,
wo kommst du wirklich her und so, ja, so in der dritten Woche eines täglichen Auseinandersetzens.
Kann das mal eine Rolle spielen, wo man herkam?
Aber ansonsten, also wenn ich jetzt über die alten Republiken und so weiter,
ich versteife mich jetzt immer auf so eine Floskel wie, wir brauchen Zuwanderung
in das Erwerbspersonenpotenzial.
Wir brauchen Zuwanderung. Die Familien sorgen für so und so viel Zuwanderung.
Das Ausland sorgt für so und so viel Zuwanderung. Da ist noch eine Lücke.
Also dass man schon mal Ausland und Familien absolut gleich setzt.
Weil am Ende ist es echt egal, woher die Leute zuwandern.
Und so ist das ja auch. In welchem Zustand die Leute zuwandern,
ist wirklich kriegsentscheidend und 20.000 Euro gespart zu haben.
Wenn man heute irgendwie sagen würde, deine Oma bekommt so und so viel Rente und.
Vor zehn Jahren haben wir einem dieser drei Leute, der für die Rente zuständig
ist, rechnerisch, die deine Oma bekommt, 20.000 Euro geschenkt.
Ob wir das gemacht haben oder nicht, spielt heute in der Bilanzierung gar keine Rolle mehr.
Das ist einfach unerheblich. Das ist wirklich ein Vogelschiss der Geschichte sozusagen.
Wir hören noch mal ganz kurz Quatsch.
Womit ich halt sagen will, dass man halt einfach irgendwo anfangen muss.
Ich glaube es ist dann schon am sinnvollsten dann auch bei der Generationengerechtigkeit anzusetzen.
Denn die Zahlen, die Sie gerade genannt haben, können wir noch dahingehend ergänzen,
dass wir festhalten, dass eben dieses Gesamtprivatvermögen in Deutschland zu
70 Prozent bei den Senioren liegt. Das heißt, die junge Generation ist also
schon jetzt wirklich mit Abstand am schlechtesten ausgestattet.
Ja und deshalb muss man sie besser ausstatten. Und jetzt hören wir zum Abschluss
dieses großen Blocks Kapitalismus, wie er eigentlich ist, noch etwas zum Thema
Wohnungsmarkt, weil dich das noch immer interessiert und dich jetzt auch ganz besonders betrifft.
Denn Frankfurt ist jetzt zum ersten Mal der allerteuerste Studienort.
Es war bislang immer noch so, dass man… – Eigentlich war München immer noch
so ein bisschen… – Und jetzt ist aber Frankfurt noch ein Euro teurer.
Also hier ist man jetzt bei 30 Quadratmetern für 696 Euro angelangt.
Und es gibt ja BAföG Wohnzuschlag und der liegt aber bei maximal 360 Euro.
Ja, sehr gut.
Das heißt, mit diesem Zuschlag kann man sich nur eine Studentenwohnung entweder
in Chemnitz oder in Magdeburg leisten.
Und sonst in keiner anderen Stadt, überall sonst ist es teurer.
Überall sonst ist es teurer.
Und selbst RTL, nicht für Klassenkampf bekannt, hat das Thema Wohnungsmangel,
Wohnungssuche mal aufgegriffen unter Studenten. Wir hören mal rein.
Hast du einen Freund? Und was hast du so an?
Ja, also ist es so, dass hier auf TikTok eine Challenge war,
oder Challenge kann man nicht sagen, aber ein gewisser Trend,
dass dort Studentinnen darauf aufmerksam machten, dass sie sich bei kleinen
Vermietern, also wir reden hier nicht über die bösen Wohnungskonzerne,
sondern über die lieben kleinen Vermieter, dass sie sich dort beworben haben
und dann solche Rückfragen bekommen. Wir hören das hier nochmal.
Hast du einen Freund? Und was hast du so an?
Falls du Lust hast, kann ich dir dann auch mal später die Stadt zeigen und so.
Jetzt kommen wir langsam ans Eingemachte.
Bedingung, um in diese Wohnung einzuziehen, ist ein Friends with Benefits Arrangement.
Absprache mit Respekt und Diskretion.
Diese TikToks, die gerade im Netz viral gehen, zeigen, wie es wirklich ablaufen
soll bei der Wohnungssuche.
Die Zeit hat mich schon vor Monaten, muss ich sagen, gefragt,
ob ich mal was zum Thema Wohnen schreiben möchte und ich komme leider aus zeitlichen
Gründen nicht dazu, aber den Tenor des Textes kann ich ja hier ansagen,
es ist keine Marktwirtschaft mehr.
Es gelten ganz viele Kriterien, aber Marktwirtschaft ist es nicht.
Und wir hatten aus Paris Erzählung genau dieser Art vor 10, 20 Jahren so in
diesem Range, als Lolita noch sozusagen der Hit war.
Ja, so Literatur und weit weg.
Also im Sinne von, das kann ich mir gerne im Fernsehen ansehen,
weil das ist so weit weg, das ist so absurd.
Also das betrifft ja niemanden und so. Das sind ja nur so Geschichten,
die sich halt irgendwelche Literaten ausgedacht haben.
Und dann hieß es plötzlich in Paris, es gibt so eine ganz große,
stille, wie soll man sagen, nicht heimliche, sondern so eine latente Prostitution.
Ja, das hat Michelle Wolbeck auch in Vernichten geschrieben,
da gibt es da eine sehr pikante Szene.
Genau, da schleicht sich das dann so ein und da liest man es dann wahrscheinlich
und hat schon so eine Ahnung.
Achso, meine, wer auch immer nicht, wohnt ja auch in Paris und studiert da, betrifft die das auch?
Und dann traut man sich gar nicht nachzufragen, weil es könnte durchaus sein, dass sie sagt, ja klar.
Und jetzt haben wir das in Deutschland auch, flächendeckend.
Während wir, also die FDP und so weiter, über diesen, ja die Marktwirtschaft
und so weiter und so fort. Nee, wir haben mittlerweile wirklich ausfallende,
also ausgefallene Märkte.
Wir denken ja, wenn eine Wirtschaftskrise ist, wenn Geld fehlt,
dann muss man irgendwas machen, Konjunkturpaket oder sowas.
Aber dass Geld nicht mehr funktioniert, also dass es nicht am Mangel des Geldes
liegt, sondern dass genug Geld im Markt ist, aber die Vermieter trotzdem sagen
können, nee, die andere war irgendwie netter zu mir. Die kriegt die Wohnung.
Und dass danach auch wirklich entschieden wird, wer die Wohnung kriegt.
Das ist eine ganz gefährliche Sache irgendwie, Weil wir können uns ungefähr
vorstellen, wenn der Murat ...
Wegen zu wenig Geld schon ein flatterndes Auge bekommt. Wie geht es dann diesen
jungen Mädels, die da irgendwie das erste Mal in der Großstadt und so weiter.
Die halten das ja auch irgendwie für normal. Die denken dann,
ach so, läuft das hier, ja gut, okay. Dann läuft es halt so. Alle erzählen das.
Da hat TikTok jetzt mal eine positive Seite wieder, dass sowas dann dort viral
geht und dort diskutiert wird.
Und RTL hat dann mal so ein Fake-Profil angelegt und haben mal geschaut, was dann so passiert.
Schon nach wenigen Minuten erhält Jana die ersten Nachrichten von vermeintlichen Vermietern.
Alle bieten ihr eine Wohnung an, allerdings unter speziellen Bedingungen.
Zusammen baden für weniger Miete? Wollte die Miete gerne in Naturalien von dir,
falls du Interesse hast.
Schlafen öfters miteinander, so
hast du keine Miet- und Nebenkosten und unterstütze dich finanziell noch.
Das ist echt unglaublich. Bei circa 20 Nachrichten, die ich in den ersten Minuten,
Stunden erhalten habe, war nur eine einzige Nachricht dabei,
wo ich ein weitestgehend gutes Gefühl hatte, dass sie auch ernst gemeint ist.
Der Rest waren alles anzügliche Nachrichten.
Und es kommt noch schlimmer. Dieser vermeintliche Vermieter bietet unserer Reporterin
ein 25 qm großes Zimmer mit eigenem Bad in Köln an.
Mietpreis 250 Euro im Monat. Klingt zu schön, um wahr zu sein.
Jana lässt sich auf das Gespräch mit ihm ein und merkt schnell,
je mehr sie schreibt, desto krasser werden seine Nachrichten.
Als wir nach einem Besichtigungstermin fragen, erhalten wir folgende Forderungen von ihm.
Bei der Besichtigung oben ohne Leggings, ohne Unterwäsche. An meinem Geburtstag nackt Kellnern.
Seine restlichen Forderungen sind so abscheulich und unter der Gürtellinie,
dass wir sie hier nicht offen zeigen können.
Ja, ist doch erstaunlich. Wo ist da unsere Familienpartei CDU, die da reingreift?
Ganz kurz noch, es gibt ganz wenig zu Azubis. Oder man findet das nicht so richtig.
Also Azubis sind Social Media, meine ich jetzt.
Ich glaube, dass deren Anliegen ja nicht nur in der Politik,
sondern auch in der Öffentlichkeit stark unterrepräsentiert sind.
Fast nicht Gehör finden. Bei Studenten ist es dann doch so eine andere Vernetzung,
die auch einfach an dieser Zentralisierung liegt.
Große Universitäten und so. Aber die ganzen, die so in kleineren Betrieben unterwegs
sind, die finden kein Gehör. Ich habe dann jemanden gefunden, der heißt Ben.
Das ist ein Jetzt-Geselle, der hat seine Ausbildung als Tischler gemacht und,
ist jetzt da auch so bei Instagram unterwegs, macht sehr viele witzige Videos,
irgendwas so für seine Tischler-Community,
und.
Auch andere, die da interessiert dran sind. Also generell auch bei so Ausbildungs-Events ist er dabei.
Ich kann das nicht einschätzen, wie politisch der tatsächlich ist.
Mir ist da nur ein Video aufgefallen, das wir jetzt mal gerade abspielen,
wo er also durchaus auch mal auf etwas hinweist, was mir zum Beispiel gar nicht
bekannt war, aber was auch eigentlich ein großes politisches Thema wäre.
Denn er hat immer wieder so angesprochen auch, dass man die Handelskammer ja
nicht als seinen Verbündeten erlebt als Azubi,
Sondern die Handelskammer ist halt mit den Arbeitgebern voll besetzt und wohin
wendet man sich dann eigentlich als Azubi?
Ich hab meinen ehemaligen Ausbilder verklagt. Und die Antwort auf mein anwaltliches
Schreiben? Leute, ich hab noch nie sowas lächerliches gesehen.
Mein Ex-Chef sagte zu mir wortwörtlich, ich geb dir keinen Cent für dein Gesellenstück dazu.
Dabei sagt das Berufsbildungsgesetz ganz klar, der Ausbilder hat die Materialien
für Zwischen- und Abschlussprüfungen kostenlos zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Aber stattdessen wurde mir in der Ausbildung gedroht, sollte ich noch einmal
aufmucken, auf meine Rechte wahren, würde er mich auch noch vor der Prüfung
rausschmeißen und mir die Ausbildung damit versauen.
Also hab ich mich um die Materialien selbst gekümmert. Ja, allerdings wurde
ich 20% unter Tarif bezahlt.
Also bat ich ganz einfach Firmen um ihre Mithilfe. Häfle sponserte mir die Beschläge.
Adler stellte die Lacke. Wickert Holzhandel die Platten.
Und sogar eine andere Schreinerei, das Linoleum. Und jetzt wollte ich wenigstens
die 300 Euro für das Holz wiederhaben. Und forderte die auch anwaltlich ein.
Aber mein ehemaliger Ausbilder verweigerte das Ganze mit der Begründung,
Achtung, er könne nicht zuordnen, dass die Bohle, die in seine Werkstatt geliefert
wurde, dort von mir verarbeitet.
Auch wirklich zu meinem Gesellenstück gehört.
Und dann wundern die sich, dass ich der siebte Azubi in Folge bin,
der den Betrieb sofort wieder verlässt. Was würdest du an meiner Stelle machen?
Ja, sehr gut, dass es so Videos gibt, aber es gibt definitiv zu wenige davon.
Klar ist es für mich ein bisschen schwierig, da in so eine Timeline reinzukommen,
wo so Videos auftauchen.
Aber ich würde mal sagen, es ist zu wenig.
Es ist einfach zu wenig und vielleicht sollte da auch nochmal tatsächlich ein
gutes Social Media Programm aufgelegt werden von Seiten der Azubis.
Ich weiß nicht auch, wie die nochmal darüber auch vielleicht die Möglichkeit
hätten, sich anders zu vernetzen, auszutauschen.
Denn ich glaube, dass wir da auch einfach so eine riesen Dunkelziffer haben
von Leuten, die gar nicht wissen, dass man sich anders vernetzen kann.
Und die werden auch von den Gewerkschaften nicht immer erreicht.
Beziehungsweise ist wirklich das so interessant, dass wir durch diese große
Akademisierung der Gesellschaft dafür sehr stark gesorgt haben,
dass wir überhaupt das Thema Azubis aus dem Blick verloren haben.
Nur die klagen darüber, dass sie gerade irgendwo fehlen.
Aber wie eigentlich ihre Situationen sind, was sie da eigentlich verdienen.
Ich erinnere mich an eine Unterhaltung mit Journalisten, da gab es gerade so
ein Gesetz, da gibt es so einen Mindestlohn für Azubis oder so eine Untergrenze.
Und dann sagten plötzlich zwei ältere Journalisten mir, Ich wusste gar nicht,
dass die so wenig verdienen.
Also überhaupt kein Bewusstsein dafür da.
Das ist ja alles. Es ist alles super dramatisch. Wir verschieben heute natürlich
das Open-AI-Drama, also,
der Coup, der da stattfand. Sam Altman hat mit seiner, wie soll man sagen, etwas losen Ideologie,
einfach mal machen, egal wo nach mir die Sinnflut, jetzt den Laden übernommen,
mit Microsofts Hilfe. Es werden alle Ressourcen gestellt.
Aber man kann natürlich solche künstlichen Intelligenzen auch wirklich gut für
den Klassenkampf nutzen, weil sie wirklich gut aufklären, insbesondere ganz
individuell über die eigene Situation im Vergleich zu was auch immer.
Ich habe jetzt wenig Sorgen, dass diese jungen Menschen nicht wissen,
wie man mit der Technik umgeht, denn wenn ich so sehe, wie die Kinder ihre Hausaufgaben
machen, denke ich mir, okay, die sind wirklich ihren Lehrern weit voraus.
Wie stelle ich mir das vor? Deine Kinder sind jetzt nach 10 Minuten fertig.
Na, meine betrifft es noch nicht ganz so. Maximal 13 Jahre, da muss man ja noch
auf Papier und so weiter.
Aber du hast jetzt immer jemanden, mit dem du abschreiben kannst.
Und wenn du es nicht verstanden hast, kannst du dir nochmal erklären lassen.
Also ich würde nicht mal sagen, dass es schlecht ist, sondern GPT funktioniert
doch als Wissenstransferagent relativ gut. Also jetzt bist du wieder gehypt, merke ich gerade, oder?
Doch, ein bisschen schon. Komm.
Ich sag mal so, die Welt wird untergehen mit GPT, aber auf dem Weg dahin wird
es für die einen oder anderen noch ein paar positive Seiteneffekte haben.
Unter anderem für junge Menschen und Schüler, die interessiert daran sind diese
Technik zu benutzen, deren Arbeitgeber nämlich nicht, die Lehrer auch nicht und so weiter.
Die sind alle außen raus. Also ich bin nicht gehypt, aber ich sehe natürlich
die Möglichkeiten, die es bietet.
Und wir hatten einen Koalitionsvertrag, der jetzt nicht mehr gilt,
wo ja drin stand, für die Azubis möchten wir frei nach Michael Sendel, Respekt und so weiter.
Sie sollten auf Augenhöhe mit den Studenten sein, also Auslandssemester, warum nicht?
Große Austausche, natürlich Stipendiensysteme und so weiter und so fort,
alles nicht gekommen. Also in Sachen Fortschritt, zivilisatorische Art,
liegt ja die Ampel wirklich blank, so.
Es ist nichts, weder im Familienrecht, noch irgendwo in irgendeine Richtung gekommen.
Deswegen hat diese junge Generation sowieso nur eine Möglichkeit,
sich nämlich selbst herauszukämpfen.
Und es gibt so ein paar Möglichkeiten. Also wir werden es auf der Bühne einfach
durchspielen, was GPT so bedeutet.
Ich denke, wir müssen dann auch China ansprechen. Wir sind nämlich jetzt ja
tatsächlich schon mit unserer Zeit durch.
Hast du noch zum Abschluss einen Clip? Sonst habe ich zum Abschluss einen.
Ich gucke nur kurz. Harald Schmidt hat sich der Demografie geäußert.
Das fand ich ganz witzig, aber muss hier nicht gespielt werden.
Ich bring dir jetzt noch einen, der ist ganz unten, der Clip zum Thema große
Orientierungslosigkeit bei jungen Männern.
Ist ja auch ein Thema, das dich interessiert.
Und zwar hat mir ein Hörer das geschickt über Instagram, dass es da jetzt so
eine neue Formation gibt, beziehungsweise ein neues Business.
Hast du schon mal vom Rudel gehört? Das Rudel, also wir kennen ja ganz viele
Coaches und Motivatoren und wir kennen den Fight Club noch von Brad Pitt.
Und nun gibt es dort so einen Social Media Account mit entsprechender Homepage
und unter allem dort kann man sich akkreditieren als junger Mann,
wenn man zu den Machern gehören will.
Man sieht dort bei diesem Instagram-Profil lauter aufgepumpte junge Männer,
die wie wild geworden mit freiem Oberkörper durch die Wallachei springen und,
zelten und sich gegenseitig anschreien oder weiß ich nicht was machen.
Männerkram halt.
Ja, aber wirklich, also ich weiß nicht, also urzeitlich, so kommt es einem vor.
Und ich habe mal hier noch einen Clip zur Belustigung mitgebracht.
Was hat es überhaupt mit dem Rudel auf sich? Meine Erklärung,
weil so viele gefragt haben.
Mit dem Beitritt ins Rudel hat die Reise zu meinem Sinn des Lebens erst so richtig Fahrt aufgenommen.
Also wir sehen ihn jetzt hier, einen Typen, Muskel überpackt mit freiem Oberkörper,
im Wald stehen, hinten im Hintergrund einen Wasserfall, eingeblendet werden
immer wieder irgendwelche Clips vom Bergsteigen oder Schwimmen.
Ich fühle mich wie ein Zeichen vom Leben, dass ich auf dem richtigen Pfad bin.
Durch Angelo bin ich ins Rudel gekommen. Ich hatte mit ihm meinen 10-minütigen Bewerbungscall.
Angelo scheint wohl der Chef dieses Rudels zu sein oder der Rudelführer.
Und konnte in dieser kurzen Zeit zur Schau stellen, dass ich dazu in der Lage
bin, meinen Mehrwert weiterzugeben und dass ich ein Macher bin.
Beim Rudel handelt es sich um eine Gruppe von Männern, die sich bei Rudeltrips,
bei Calls auf Zoom oder auf der Plattform Skool Mehrwert weitergeben und ja,
sich einfach gegenseitig pushen und sich gegenseitig eben immer wieder an die Ziele erinnern.
Nimm die Entwicklung, die ich durch das Rudel mache mit und folg mir,
lebe unabhängig und zieh durch.
So.
Geben sich Mehrwert weiter.
Ja, der Mehrwert ist natürlich rein körperlich erarbeitet durch was auch immer, wie man hier sieht.
Ich habe mich ja lange gefragt, was ist die Antwort auf Taylor Swift?
Ich habe es ja schon ein paar Mal betont.
Aber das hier nicht.
Ja doch. Taylor Swift steht als Frau auf einer Bühne, auf der auch ansonsten
nur Frauen sind. Das Geschäft wird irgendwie von ihren Eltern geleitet,
vor allem von ihrer Mutter.
Und im Publikum sind auch nur Frauen.
Dann bringt sie diesen Film ins Kino und auch zu den Streams.
Und auch da ist es nur ihr Management, also nur ihre Familie und so weiter.
Es spielen nirgendwo Männer eine Rolle.
Im größten Entertainment Business, das wir derzeit haben.
Aber die Band besteht aus Männern. Ich war ja im Kinofilm.
Genau. Es gibt auch männliche Tänzer, die mit Übergewicht nochmal zeigen können,
dass es auch fragile Männlichkeit gibt, die wir durchaus zeigen und nicht verstecken.
Die dürfen normal mit tanzen, kriegen auch ein Tanz-Solo, alle dürfen jubeln,
und so weiter. Die nicht bedrohliche.
Männlichkeit.
Ja, aber da ist doch ein Tänzer, der so ein bisschen aussieht wie jemand vom Rudel so.
Irgendwer muss ja auch mal eine Hebefigur machen oder so, aber das sind keine
Protagonisten. Wir kennen deren Namen nicht. Wir wissen nicht und so weiter.
Es sind die Protagonisten auf der Bühne und im Publikum sind Frauen.
Insbesondere war ja der ganze Hype um Taylor Swift über diese Selfie Videos aus dem Publikum.
Mütter zeigen, wie ihre Töchter ausrasten, nachdem sie ihn ermöglicht haben,
Taylor Swift live zu sehen und solche Sachen. Also das ist eine reine Frauenangelegenheit.
Du kennst dieses berühmte Zitat von Cher, dass Chers Mutter mal zu ihr sagte,
irgendwann, Cher, musst doch du einen reichen Mann finden.
Und sie antwortete, Mom, ich bin ein reicher Mann.
Wie hat sie denn das gemeint? Ich bin ein reicher Mann im Sinne von?
Naja, sie muss ja nicht jemanden suchen, der für sie sorgt.
Ach so.
Sie ist, I am a rich man. Und es gibt ja ein ähnliches Lied auch von Taylor
Swift, wenn ich ein Boss wäre oder so, also es gibt, glaub ich, schon diesen Move.
Aber wo, ich habe jetzt verstanden, das ist halt so sehr weibliches Terrain,
wenngleich ich im Kino auch Männer gesehen habe, jetzt nicht nur drei.
Also es waren schon auch Männer da und ich hab dann mal so geguckt ins Publikum.
So, aber was sind das für Männer?
Und habe dann, nein, es sind nicht Männer, die beim Rudel mitmachen.
Es sind nicht die Rudelmänner, wir müssen unterscheiden zwischen Männern und
Männlichkeit, frei nach Herrn Bolz, dass wir da klarziehen.
Es gibt auch Männer, die auf die Frauen ins Frauenlager wechseln, Zwiftis werden.
Man kann nicht als Rudeltyp plötzlich ein Zwifti werden, also da ist irgendwo die Grenze.
Übrigens zu der Geschichte mit Cher, es gibt eine andere schöne,
die habe ich letztens bei TikTok gesehen.
Michelle Obama geht mit Barack Obama in eine Pizzeria und dort stellt sie fest,
dass sie mit dem Eigner mal ein Date hatte.
Und dann sagt Barack zu ihr und findet es nicht gut, hätte es ja auch heute
die Frau, der der Pizzaladen gehört sein können.
Dann sagt sie so, nee, er wäre dann Präsident geworden.
Sehr gut, ja.
So, also wir haben so eine neue, was heißt neue, das Selbstbewusstsein ist nicht
neu, aber die Art und Weise, wie man es vorträgt.
Ja.
Also wie Taylor Swift auf der Bühne steht, mir fällt jetzt kein männliches Pendant
ein, sondern die super erfolgreichen The Weeknd, Harry Styles oder so,
das sind mehr so, die machen es halt wie Taylor Swift.
Oder auch mit dieser Selbstbehauptung wie Beyoncé oder so, die stehen einfach anders auf einer Bühne.
Ja, ich denke kurz darüber nach und würde dir zustimmen, also sagen wir so,
die männlichen Popstars heute sind Popstars für,
Oft ein weibliches Publikum, also Shawn Mendes, wird sicherlich,
ich kenne mich mit dem nicht genau aus, aber ich würde jetzt sagen,
wird wahrscheinlich ein überwiegend weibliches Publikum haben.
Dann gibt es noch jemanden wie Troy Sivan, der sicherlich ein besonders großes
LGBT-Publikum haben wird.
Aber was du jetzt, glaube ich, meinst ist, also so wie dieses weibliche Selbstbewusstsein,
mit dem Taylor Swift auftritt, so mir gehört die Welt, das ist ja eigentlich
ein Auftreten, das wir von den älteren Stars kennen, wenn man jetzt an Frank Sinatra denkt, ja.
Der hat auch ein großes männliches Publikum angesprochen, bestimmt sogar vielleicht
mehr als ein weibliches Publikum und ich würde sagen,
dass der auftritt und sagt, ja, was kostet die Welt, ich bin Frank Sinatra.
Genau, oder wir hatten eben Cher, Madonna und so weiter, die sich dann mit irgendwelcher
besonderen Mode, die nochmal die weiblichen Formen hervor, aber auch so überspitzt zeigt.
Ja, das ist ja Camp.
Ja, wo immer klar war, das ist auch, hier ist so ein Kampf mit dabei,
das hat eine politische Dimension, wie auch immer.
Und das ist ja jetzt bei Taylor Swift nicht mehr, also die steht ja nicht auf
der Bühne und macht irgendwie einen politischen Kampf oder so, sondern das sind dann.
Die ist einfach da.
Genau, das sind einfach so gefällige Anleihen, dann zeigt sie nochmal ihre weiblichen
Armmuskeln und so weiter und die ganzen Mädels rasten aus, aber es ist nicht
mehr eine Bühnenperformance, die über, wie bei Britney Spears vor 20 Jahren,
sexuelle was auch immer ikonografie dann doch irgendwie für die männer gemacht
ist oder wie auch immer schon allein eben weil es keine management ebene gibt
der man das verkaufen der es gefallen muss also es wird nicht über bande gespielt
sondern es ist der direkte da steht sie auf der bühne und da sind die teenager
im publikum und es ist eins zu eins und so weiter und so fort.
Und weil die Zeiten sich auch geändert haben. Also das sind glaube ich jetzt,
heute würde man nicht mehr sowas wie Oops I did it again, würde heute nicht mehr auch gut ankommen.
Also auch nicht bei einem Teenie Publikum unbedingt. Obwohl ich da auch schon
wieder sehr skeptisch bin, wenn man sieht, welche TikTok Stars,
Musik Stars es so gibt und welche Körperbilder und so weiter dort vertreten werden,
dann würde ich sagen holt lieber nochmal die alten Britney Spears Videos hervor.
Aber wo ist jetzt der Punkt, dass du sagst, also wir stellen jetzt fest,
also es gibt Taylor Swift,
für die Männer gab es aber vielleicht nie diese Art des Fantoms gegenüber einem musikalischen Star.
Jetzt keine thematischen Vergleiche, sondern mir geht es nur um.
Sondern die haben das im Sport. Wir sind jetzt hier sehr kategorisch,
es gibt natürlich auch Frauen, die Fußball toll finden oder so,
aber Männer haben das ja viel stärker im Sport.
Dass es zum Beispiel jetzt gelungen ist, mit klugem Marketing hier in Deutschland
einen NFL-Hype auszulösen, wo ich sagen würde, vor zehn Jahren hat das noch
niemand von euch wahrgenommen, Zeigt ja, dass also da das Taylor Swift Phänomen funktioniert.
Also es ist doch lustig, dass Taylor Swift doch auch mit so einem NFL Spieler
zusammen zu sein scheint.
Und da gibt es jetzt für jeden was dabei.
Genau, und das wird ja auch wieder begleitet von, das hast du auch schon gesehen, von so,
ich sag jetzt mal Meme dazu, also das immer gleiche Muster des Videos,
dass nämlich Frauen ihre Männer dabei filmen, wie sie ihnen sagen,
Ist doch interessant, dass sich die Leute jetzt plötzlich für diesen Footballer da interessieren.
Wie heißt der nochmal? Und die Männer dann so...
Äh, hier, Kecik oder wie er heißt und so. Also für die ist das ja die totale Koryphäe.
Und die müssen sich jetzt grad von ihren Frauen anhören, dass die Mainstream-Definition,
von Seiten Taylor Swifts ausgeht.
Taylor Swift hat Football jetzt cool gemacht.
Ja.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass man heute ins Kino geht, den Taylor-Swift-Film sieht,
und der ganze Zeit von NFL-Sachen unterbrochen ist, sondern man guckt ein NFL-Spiel,
Taylor Swift ist auch im Stadion Und bei jedem Spielzug wird sofort auf die
Reaktion von Taylor Swift geschaut.
Also sie kolonialisiert sozusagen den männlichen Bereich, während seine Rolle,
ja, er steht halt so mit im Stadion, und wenn sie eine Textzeile ändert,
Kamer ist, und dann kommt sie plötzlich mit den Männern von The Chiefs und so, mit solchen Sprüchen,
dann kommt mal die Kamera auch zu ihm und zeigt ihn so.
Aber da muss sie schon wirklich den Trigger setzen. Und diese Verdrehung,
dieses Umschiften eines erstmal nur semantischen, das ist nur der Kunstbereich,
das ist nur Entertainment, dieses Konzert findet nur an einem Abend im Jahr
und dann muss man auch ewig lange sparen, das prägt nicht die ganze Lebenswelt,
aber für dieses mediale Phänomen dann schon.
Egal wie man es definiert, es brauchte ein Pendant.
Und zwar insbesondere auf dieser Social Media Ebene. Ich kann nicht 25 Videos
von Taylor Swift auf der Bühne und so weiter.
Und womit wird es dann unterbrochen, sodass daran erfolgreich angeschlossen werden kann? Mit sowas.
Wir sehen Männer, deren Namen wir nicht kennen, die, muss man ja dann auch sagen,
während völlig klar ist, dass man jetzt Taylor Swift folgt und damit ist vor
allem diese Idee Taylor Swift aber eben doch an eine Person gekoppelt,
hat man es hier schon mit so einer Orientierunglosigkeit zu tun,
Im Sinne von es kommt auf den Körper an, nicht auf den Kopf.
Also man kann sich nicht mal auf den Führer einigen oder sowas.
Doch, doch, doch. Das ist der Rudelführer.
Ist das in Rosanz am Bahnhof?
Wie heißt er? Massimo oder was? Das ist der Rudelführer. Und die anderen,
das ist wie beim Fight Club. Da gibt es ja auch einen Chef.
Und was ja hier deutlich wird und das macht das ja so unangenehm.
Also du hast es gerade so schön bei Taylor Swift beschrieben.
Es ist jetzt nicht noch mal die ganz große Politik, aber hier weißt du ja schon,
egal welches Thema, das man irgendwie als progressiv framen würde,
man mit diesen Herren besprechen müsste,
es wäre glaube ich nicht so angenehm.
Also verstehst du?
Ja, das würde auf inhaltlicher Ebene nicht statt.
Ja, ich glaube noch nicht mal, dass es nur nicht stattfindet,
sondern dass es, wenn er sehr regressiv sein wird.
Also ich sage mal Männern, die wie wild geworden durch die Gegend springen und
sich gegenseitig in jeder Weise huschen müssen und sagen, wir sind Macher,
wir produzieren Mehrwert.
Und da kann man nicht auch mal was Harmloses machen, kann man nicht mal sagen, wir ...
Also muss das immer gleich schon, also man sieht ja schon irgendwo den Bitcoin
nicht weit und vielleicht aber auch noch Christian Lindner drauf finden.
Es ist schon wieder, also bei Männern ist das jetzt gerade so,
dass wenn so eine Identitätsfindung mal dann stattfindet über Social Media,
dann geht das sehr häufig direkt in so ein All-in,
Krypto, FDP.
Und generell müssen wir den Feminismus eigentlich auch nochmal abschaffen.
Ich meine, er zeigt ja hier diese Welt, wie sie aussähe, wenn der Gregor Kirchhoff recht hätte.
Wir hätten uns niemals verschulden dürfen in Deutschland. Dann hätten wir aber
auch null irgendwas mal anstoßen können, dann würden wir alle noch im Wald leben.
Und dann sagen die, naja, aber es geht doch, wir können es doch,
wir müssen es nur machen, während die Frauen daneben stehen und sagen,
äh, nee, ich will hier das Maximale an Zivilisation.
Erstens, es muss alles übertrieben und sinnlos sein.
Also klar, das Stadion ist da, weil es häufiger gebraucht wird,
aber da muss eine ganz sinnlos teure Bühne mit der absurdesten Technologie, die es gibt, rein.
Es bringt alles niemanden irgendeinen Mehrwert, es kostet einfach nur jeden
tausend Dollar, allein vor Ort zu sein.
Aber es ist die größte Party der Welt. Das ist genau das konträre Programm zu
diesem stehen im Wald mitteltoes.
Also ich sehe hier ein großes Gegenprogramm in unserem Zeitgeist einfach.
Ja, aber nicht im Sinne von wir. Ja, also als Gegenprogramm kann ich es verstehen,
aber eigentlich ist es...
Resultat eines Mangels. Also das offenbar ist ja nicht für alle Männer,
aber doch für einige schwierig ist Orientierung zu finden.
Und diese Verwirrung wird dann sehr schnell ausgenutzt von irgendwelchen Hainis,
die sagen komm mal in die Gruppe, ich erkläre dir heute Abend mal bei Discord,
wie du deinen Mehrwert steigern kannst und ein Macher wirst.
Dann wird dir gleich erklärt, durch welche Rituale du durch musst und dann hast
du schon die Faxen dicker wie.
Ja, also das ist ja auch interessant, dass Leute so aus dieser,
du hast es eben so schön beschrieben, Qual der Schulzeit heraus sind,
um sich dann einer neuen Qual zu unterwerfen, um dann hart genug zu werden für
das Leben, das dann noch auf einen so zukommt.
Da dann doch vielleicht lieber aufs Taylor Swift Konzert gehen.
Oder sonst was zu machen. Also wie gesagt, ich möchte hier nochmal dafür werben,
das Angebot der Stadttheater, Konzerthallen und so weiter wahrzunehmen.
Es gibt wahnsinnig tolle Sachen zu sehen und oftmals sind sie nicht so teuer.
Kammerkonzerte 10, 20, 30 Euro und man kann herausragende Streichquartette erleben.
Ich habe das jetzt gerade mit dem Leon Coro Quartett wieder erfahren,
da war ich jetzt schon zum zweiten Mal, die genial sind.
Aber auch vieles andere kann man besuchen. Wir gehen ja heute auch noch in die Oper.
Wir gehen heute wieder in die Oper.
Le Grand Macabre, eine Oper von Digeti.
Ich bin sehr gespannt.
Sie wird uns viel abverlangen.
Aber wir haben schon einiges durchgestanden. Meine allererste Oper war ja 12-Ton-Musik.
Wird schon hinhauen. Ich will auch noch mal zum Ende den Appell zum sinnlosen Konsum.
Wir haben jetzt immer im Ohr dieses nein, wir müssen nur noch investieren und super klug.
Es muss auf jeden Fall eine Return on Investment geben. Und die Glücksforschung
sagt uns, wenn man in Erlebnisse konsumiert, Erlebnisse konsumieren,
vergänglich, austauschbar,
eigentlich sinnlos, unter Investitionskalkülgesichtspunkten,
dann hat man was absolviert, etwas erfahren,
wie auch immer, dann ist man innerlich reicher geworden. Innerlich reicher.
Ich suche noch einen an. Es gibt wahrscheinlich kein Wort, das nicht bescheuert
klingt dabei, aber ja, ja, ich bin total dafür.
Unvernünftig zu konsumieren, denn das muss nicht die Welt kosten.
Das ist es eben. Opa ist teuer, Theater nicht.
Ja, Opa ist teuer, Theater geht, aber wir haben generell ein Problem, es ist zu wenig Geld da.
Und die Vernunft ist aber auch meines Erachtens ein bisschen zu groß.
Das versuche ich zu ändern mit dem nächsten Salon.
Denn ich stelle einen Roman vor von einem, der in den 80er Jahren auszog,
um das wilde München zu erleben. Und ich kann schon sagen, es wird verrucht
und verschwitzt und es ist ein sehr großartiger Roman.
Außerdem werde ich einen Text vorstellen, der uns ganz klar sagt,
autonomes Fahren wird nicht kommen.
Und das ist ein Text, der das begründet. Ja, ich war sehr traurig,
bin ja inzwischen auch schon jemand, der sagte, Mensch, wenn das mal bald mit
dem autonomen Fahren geht, sieht sehr, sehr schlecht aus, wird nicht kommen.
Das dann im Salon und wir sprechen, wie schon angekündigt, über Extremly Online.
Hast du schon was auf dem Schirm?
Einiges, aber ich sortiere erst unterwegs. Wir haben ja noch eine Woche.
Ich empfehle, ja holt euch doch Tyler Lawrence, er holt es euch ja eh immer,
obwohl wir es für euch besprechen.
Aber ich glaube diesmal wird die Diskussion weit über das Buch hinaus gehen.
Gut, wir reden dann darüber im Salon, wie gesagt buchbar über Patreon,
Apple, wir präferieren aber Steady und am besten geht ihr einfach auf neu20er.de,
dort gibt es dann die entsprechenden Links rechts oben, wie man dorthin kommt
und sich dort ganz ganz einfach anmelden kann, ab 2,50 Euro ist das möglich.
Und wir können auch noch hinzufügen, dass man jetzt, wer Weihnachten noch nicht
weiß, was er verschenken kann, will, man kann auch diesen Salon verschenken für ein Jahr.
Also wenn man jemanden aufklären will über die Lage der Welt,
dann kann man das auch so tun und dann sehen wir uns im Salon wieder.
So ist es.
Haut rein.